It's 4 o'clock. Now it's 4 o'clock.
All right, we'll go ahead and get started. Welcome everybody to the work session,
the Eagle Mountain City Council meeting, October 6th. It's 4 o'clock
and we'll go ahead and get started. The first item on our
agenda is a discussion,
an overview of UFA and UFSA, and Chief Burchett's here with his army.
I don't know who else is coming up, but We'll welcome you to the podium,
and anyone else that needs to join can as needed.
Well, thank you, and Mayor, uh, thank Mayor and Council for giving us a few
minutes. Um, the reason that we're here today is just to present on the
history since when Eagle Mountain joined UFSA and
the fire district, and subsequently joining UFA, and just talk through some of
those numbers. We're going to talk about, uh, the cost the revenue, the apparatus,
and the facility upgrades, just to give you all awareness as you're making these next
decisions for your city. Tonight,
Tony and I— Tony Hill, our CFO— will be here
to walk through all of that with you and happy to answer any questions that
you may have. And, and that commitment tonight
is— it's— it goes beyond just tonight. So if there's other questions, we're available to
help you answer We understand that the decisions that you're going to be making here
are going to be difficult and challenging, and there's going to be a lot of
questions. So we're happy to, happy to be here for you and answer
any questions that you have. So with the
slide— oh,
here it is. Sorry, I didn't realize it
was going off my computer, so I apologize. Neither did I.
While you're pulling that up, I'm just— I was going to say this in a
minute, but I, I'm going to jump backwards. I skipped item 1A,
and I did not mention why, but I knew why, and I forgot to mention
it. Uh, I'm switching the order on those, but then David Stroud called
in. Uh, he was not going to be here, so he wanted to move that
item to 10:20. I do want to have a short discussion
discussion, if there's anything that we can at least give direction. So I'll come right
back to that for the council. Okay, now that
we're all set up with this, Tony is going to take over to first talk
about the, the revenue and the expense side of things, and then I'll take it
back from him after that. All right,
thanks, Chief. Mayor, it's good to see you. Council, thank you. As Chief
said, for just a few minutes today to Just go over a little bit of
history and answer any questions that you may have. So I'm
going to take the first three or four slides,
and Chief will go
from there. So Eagle Mountain joined the service area,
UFSA and UFA in 2012,
and so the first year that UFSA, which is
the taxing side of the agreement
of the 2 organizations that Eagle Mountain is a part of was in
2013. And so you can see in
2013, UFSA collected $1.6
million in revenue. And the revenue
is mostly made up of property tax. There is
a little bit of other revenue, some motor vehicle fee-in-lieu and some impact
fees. that go into this number, but it's when we—
when you see these numbers, it's generally the property tax. And so it was $1.6
million in 2013, and you can see where it is
now in 2026, up to $10.9
million. So as you're all aware, right, you are
down here, lots of growth in property tax in that time.
The next slide is the Expenditures, and I went the wrong way.
And you can see it's of course a very similar pattern there.
And so the the expenditures are mostly made up
of the UFA member fee payment, which covers the
staffing at the station as well as the apparatus.
So the engines, trucks, and ambulances that are
at your three stations. There are some miscellaneous other
expenses as well. There's bond payments. For fire station construction.
There's capital maintenance on our current— on the current stations,
and then some other admin costs. So you can see
there again, similar pattern, started with $2.1 million
in total cost in 2013,
and it's up to a little bit over $12 million now
in 2026. So the next slide we have
of puts those 2 things together. And so you can see
the green line is
the revenue or the total available revenue,
and then the yellow line— or the yellow— the red line is the expenses.
So early on, the expenditures were higher than the revenue.
That changed in around 2020.
And as those lines come together,
UFA would add capacity,
would add service to what's being provided down here.
So in 2020, the 4th firefighter was added
at the stations. They were staffed with 3 before that,
and then an ambulance went full-time. And so
you can see that that sort of brought the expenditures
and the revenue back together again. 2023,
it sort of flipped again, and that was when
UFSA raised taxes with the intention of
building the 2 new fire stations and staffing
the 3rd station down here in Eagle Mountain. And so for— so
that took a couple years for the full cost to be realized,
and you can see that in the graph in 2024 and '25.
Where the revenue was a little bit ahead of the costs.
And then in 2026, when the full cost of, again,
the 2 stations, the bond payments, as well as the
full cost of staffing that 3rd station— and
you can see what that looks like now in 2026 with about $12 million
in expenditures and a little under $11 million in revenue.
And And this was really— this visual you
have in front of you, in my view, is really kind of the biggest benefit
that Eagle Mountain had as you were
a part of UFSA. It allows you to leverage the rest
of UFSA and get the needed service level increases before the
revenue was actually being collected. And so then
the last slide from me. There's a lot going on on this
slide, so I'll just kind of talk you through it and we'll leave it in
front of you and you can look at it. ask any questions.
But the top line, the orange
line, is showing the yearly
or the annual shortfall or excess
from the slide that we just looked at. If you recall,
the first handful of years, you can see those numbers are in red,
meaning there was a shortfall. Then it flips
over in the early 2000s, kind of levels off.
The tax increase comes, and then the additional
staff station comes on, and you can see where
it's sitting now. Then the black line below
it just is adding those together, so the cumulative effect.
You can see that in 2019, it dropped
to as much as a Had $2.6 million shortfall,
came back to about neutral, and then currently it's sitting about
$1.1 million. So like I
said, we'll leave that there and you
can continue to look at that. That's the last thing for
me. I'll be right here to answer any questions, but we'll turn it over to
Chief to talk about a couple other things. Thank you.
Okay, thanks, Tony. The, the next thing that we're going to talk about here is,
is the staffing levels and how those have changed since
2013. Back then in 2013, there were 3 full-time firefighters
and 3 part-time firefighters that served the entire city out
of 2 stations. As you can see over the years, as Tony mentioned,
the staffing level has increased when service demand increases
and when revenue is available. But as of today, we're staffing the
city out of 3 fire stations with 14 full-time FTEs.
So, or excuse me, full-time positions, firefighters a day.
And that was with the recent opening of Station 253, which is—
was our most recent station here.
As far as the stations go, when Eagle Mountain joined
back in 2013, UFSA actually purchased Station
251, which used to be right here, and Station
252. And since that time, a significant
number of remodels have, have occurred, and totaling in
both of those expenses is about $1.3 million or
so. And additionally, with that bond in 2021
that Tony mentioned, Station 251 was moved slightly down the road
to serve better, serve the community better.
And then also 253 was open. So significant
investments in both stations and the new station.
Then when we look at what apparatus were here in 2013
versus what are currently here, I pulled a report
from, from Tony's team. And what
I could find was that back then there was a 1978 pumper,
multiple vehicles in that '80, '90 range, but the newest vehicle
was a 2009 pickup. And there's a couple of pictures that we were able
to find. These are probably from Captain Conger and all
of his years here. But today we have one brand
new ladder truck in the city. We have a relatively
new Type 13 pumper and then a relatively new Type 1 pumper,
as well as 3 ambulances in the city. So significant
changes with, with both station and apparatus
and how we're able to provide that service.
That's, that's really the information that we wanted to share, just to give
you that high-level overview as you continue to make these decisions working
towards how to provide that fire and EMS service and how
to fund it. And what I can say and what I want to end with
is that as the fire chief at UFA, I love being down here. I love
the opportunity to serve the community, and I look forward to hopefully
many more years of that. So we're happy to answer any questions.
The district administrator is here as well, Rachel Anderson. If there's any questions specific to
her, we can open it up for questions.
Can we go back to the revenue and expenses?
Sorry, this wasn't in our prep, so I haven't— I'm
just taking these slides in. One more. Yeah, one more.
So the costs that are being presented here, are these actual
costs for Eagle Mountain? As I understand
it, UFSA is a group of cities together,
usually those costs kind of get apportioned out. I'm just curious
if these are actual expenses incurred by Eagle Mountain or if these are
prorated expenses from a larger pool.
That total— what that total includes is the, is the member
fee to UFA as well as the station costs and the bond payments
to, to the bond carrier. So that
would be if you were a direct member with UFA,
That would be the amount minus the bond payments, if that's the question you're
answering. And I don't know if, Tony, you have anything else to say on that.
I mean, you're right on your question. I mean, this is for the most
part direct costs in Eagle Mountain, but as you said, we're one organization.
We make, you know, we get our property taxes all come in and we
make our member fees, right? And it all comes in together, right? So there's definitely
some— Other cities. Well, yeah, it's everybody's stuff
in there. And so there's definitely some allocations that we have
to make, right? We look at taxable value and Eagle Mountain's about 14%
of the taxable value of UFSA. So for some of the expenditures that
are sort of agency-wide, we have to use an allocation like
that. But for like the member fee, that's pretty easy for us. You're not
sharing your stations with any other members of UFA
or UFSA. So Some of our cities are neighbors, so the stations
are shared, you know, 50/50, 60/40. For you guys,
it's 100% because you're not sharing with anybody, right? So for us,
when we calculate the member fee, which is the largest piece in that,
we can be certain that we know 100% of
the costs are Eagle Mountain's. And so
when we talk about this, the allocations part, right, we're talking about
some of the admin costs, right? The administrator costs,
some of those things. But the bulk of the costs we can tie directly
back to Eagle Mountain. Does that help answer your question? It does, yeah. Thank you.
How much is the debt service payment every year for the station
houses, and how long does that bond go on?
Yeah, so we have to— Are you specific on Eagle Mountain Station, or are you
talking— Yeah, our debt service. Ours, because there's the bond covers Covered
our stations plus 2 others. How much is our
portion of the debt service payment?
So again, we have to do a little of the allocation there.
But if you look at the 2021 bond, it was,
it was about $37 million total and the
annual payments in the $2.3 to $2.4 depending
on the year. And the 2 stations, took about a little
over half of the constructions. And so the bond payment
on the 2021 bond for Eagle Mountain is about $1.2
million. Um, and then the— for the 2016 bond,
you have no direct stations on that one, and so
we have to allocate that piece using that taxable
value. And so that 14%, and so you're about
$350 The 2016
bond expires in 2035, and the
2021 bond expires in 2041. They're both
20-year debts. With that
in mind, Tony, the 14%, is that this year's
taxable value? Seems like we're at 11 or 12, just going off memory. I don't
remember. 14 point— well, that's the 5-year moving average.
average. In 2026, you're about, yeah, about 14.5%
of the total taxable value of UFSA is Eagle
Mountain. That's right.
I mean, I'm going to ask
some obvious questions because I feel like maybe I'm missing some pieces of this.
So we're talking about UFSA perhaps leaving that
organization and doing a contract. What does that look like for
us as far as our financial obligation when we have the bonds that you're talking
about? You've talked about the member fees, which would obviously be paying
for personnel, equipment, et cetera.
So the obligations to UFSA, if you— if
and when you choose to separate, will be the bond payment for
the 2 stations that were— that are— so those— that $1.2
plus the $350,000, right? So the 2 outstanding bonds Eagle
Mountain would need to continue. So we'll complete the bond basically. You need to continue
your portion of the bond. And then 252 is the other
station UFSA owns that was purchased from Eagle Mountain
in 2013. So there would need to be a negotiation
on how Eagle Mountain purchases that back from
UFSA. Let me hang on one second.
So is the, the actual land for each of the,
um, the fire stations something that normally
when a city contracts with you that they buy that portion of it and
then they're just doing a contract for services and equipment? Yeah,
all the direct members own their own stations, and since UFSA's Acting
as the direct member for Eagle Mountain and Mill Creek and all of those,
UFSA owns all the stations,
but Harriman owns their stations, Riverton owns theirs,
Cottonwood Heights, Holiday, etc., owns their stations. And so
as a direct member, you—that's why—that's why you need to continue with the bond
payment because you take over the ownership, and that's why the
discussion on 252 needs to happen. as part of this separation.
Okay, go ahead. What were you saying? I was just going to say there's a
lot of that still isn't worked out, to your question, and that's why Rachel's here,
and that's something that we're going to start working forward on.
Is it okay if I don't, or can I keep going? Go ahead.
Sorry, I didn't mean to cut you off. No, no, I wasn't cut off.
I just— it's good to have the discussion. What are— who are the top
3 cities with UFSA?
Top 3 in which way? In terms of what?
Population size. Mill Creek,
Taylorsville, and Eagle Mountain would
be the top 3. And then we have Midvale and Kearns and
Magna that would kind of be the next. Are those same 3 the same thing
for expenditures as well? Yeah. Okay.
It just depends on how many station crews that they have
in there. station or in their city. Mill Creek has 3 like
you. Taylorsville has 3 like you. Midville only has 2.
So, um, so yeah, it just depends on how many
crews run out of the city. And in, in the last fiscal
cycle, I'm just curious what, what, uh, by comparison, what is the
taxable value of each of those cities? I mean, compare us to the top 3.
Uh, I don't, I don't have that off the top of my head. I know
Mill Creek's Taxable value is by far the largest in
UFSA. They were like 17%? Yeah, 18%. Or they
might have— just UFSA, they might be in the, in the 20s.
So you have the unincorporated Salt Lake County has a
large portion of the taxable value too. They don't have the population,
but they have a large taxable value. They might be second.
And then Eagle Mountain is probably pretty similar to like Taylorsville.
But don't 100% quote me on that. I'm going a little bit off the
top of my head. So, but Mill Creek's for sure the largest.
I'm just thinking about the member cities and just how many
of those that you serve are members of the USFA
versus just those who contract with you?
Members that are direct members. The remaining 12 or 13
members are members through UFSA.
Who are the 4 cities that are direct? Cottonwood Heights,
Holiday, Riverton, and Herriman.
Thank you.
And Herriman and Riverton became direct members in 2020.
They were, were a part of UFSA Cottonwood Heights and Holiday
have always been direct.
Which year did you say Riverton and Herriman became direct members?
2020. Sorry, one other question. When, when tax increases happen,
can you walk us through that process?
Yeah, I mean, I think you guys just went through one. It would be exactly
the same. Yeah. So we are a calendar year entity, so we have
to, you know, make our intention known in October time.
We go through the budget process.
The budget gets adopted in December, and we hold a tax
hearing in December as well. We have to do all of the advertising
in newspapers. We have to send out postcards to all the residents, to all the
parcels, things like that. Is that what you're after?
I mean, really, and then the process, right? It starts with the board looking at
the budget and deciding that, okay, we need a little more revenue. The last time
we did it, it was because we were expanding service, right? We needed
to pay for the new bond that we just built the
4 stations with. We needed to staff 253 out here.
Had a station in Kearns that we weren't staffing. We started
staffing that. So there was like a 3 or 4 year plan to build up
to, okay, all right, we're ready now. Station 253 is built.
Now's the time to go through the tax increase so we can get these employees
hired, trained, and start staffing the station. So each city is—
you set a different rate, I would imagine,
or you set the same rate? No, UFSA has one rate. One rate.
Everybody. So it's 0.001756,
I think. For everybody. Eagle Mountain residents pay that, Mill Creek.
When we raise taxes, it's the same across the board.
Everybody has one rate. And it's even the same down here in Utah County
versus Salt Lake. They equalize that rate across the
whole service area. Okay. And in the 13 years that
going back in time, it looks like there's been a rate increase
pretty Consistently? I don't think there was one this year. Just 3 total in
that whole time. 3, oh, OK. So once in 2018. So 3
increases. Once in 2018, and then the, the 2 we
did back to back for all the reasons that I just talked about in '24
and '25. Other than that, there's been no Truth in Tax. OK,
and in those 3 rate increases, did you ever have a referendum?
No. In any of those 3? OK.
Well, that— yeah, that's kind of my thought process. It's, it's,
it's difficult. It would be difficult for citizens to have
a referendum on a large— an entity that large.
Okay, thank you.
You had a slide— sorry, did I cut somebody out? Um,
you had a slide that had the different apparatus on it and just kind of
the state of what we had previously.
How often— I know apparatus are very expensive, and it
takes a while for them to even just get, like, built after you order them
and stuff like that. How frequently of a cadence are
your different communities getting
new apparatus or changing things out? I'll take
a shot at that, or you can just have it. We have a capital
replacement plan that replaces— the heavy apparatus are typically on a 9-year lifespan.
Okay. Those get rotated through 'cause we have busy stations
that run the wheels off and slow stations that don't. So we have a
kind of a replacement pattern. Even when they go out of,
you know, let's say a Mill Creek area, they could go to Copperton and get
a few more years out of 'em. But we basically buy
about 5 Type 1 engines, 3 ladder
trucks, and 5 ambulances every 3 years. So that's
the number that we need to circulate through. So everybody, all of our stations
now are equipped with, with, you know, within the last 5 years
have had something new in their station. How do you ensure that across
all the different communities that you serve that it's balanced and no
one community ends up with all the new and no one community ends up with
all the old? That's— they've got like— that's part of that replacement cycle. Yeah.
But they're— they are all, again, with our plan that's been in place
for about 9, 10 years now, the capital replacement plan, we've been able to
cycle through everything. Many, many years ago, we bought all brand
new ambulances and all brand new heavy apparatus. And so that
replacement was coming up and the total would have been $30 to $40 million to
replace them all at once again. So we implemented that. Rotational plan
to every 5 years by a handful. I don't know who's going to answer this
question, but I'll ask it and I'll let you guys work it out. You mentioned
that everyone has the same tax rate across all of the UFSA
cities. How is it determined which
of those cities got to have a 3-man team for
years and why some got to have 4-man team?
The, the decision is, is on the member. So being UFSA is
one member, the direction from the board is to push for four-handed
staffing in all of the stations. There's only 2 UFSA
stations that don't have it right now. One of them's in Immigration Canyon
and one's in Copperton. Okay. And the call volume there is not high
enough necessarily to warrant that. It's still a, it's still
a goal. But all of the other direct members, Holiday,
Conewood Heights, Riverton, and Herriman, get to decide that, and that's
how they can control their costs. Do any of them decide to do 3-man
teams instead of 4, or are they all on 4? Only Cottonwood
Heights has one 3-person staffed engine. All right, thank you.
Anything else? Okay, thank you for your time.
Appreciate it. Yeah, thank you.
Can I just say one last— yeah, I just want to say thank you for
the service that you have provided us. We're grateful for it, and I think it's
been— I think it's been top-notch. I mean, I went to your fire school,
I enjoyed that. I just want you guys to know that I'm grateful for the
service that your firefighters have provided to Eagle Mountain City. Thank you.
I was going to exactly say the same thing. I mean, there's, there's no doubt
every single council meeting our council members are extending appreciation
to their first responders. You guys do an exceptionally good job for us. We're very
much appreciative for all the work that I was also gonna just ask if
you could send those slides to us. That would be greatly appreciated. Yep, we'll shoot
them your way. Okay, and I was
waiting till the end to say it's been a pleasure to be on the board.
It's fun, and at no point ever have we as
a body or me on the board not been really appreciative
to be a member of UFA and UFSA. I think it's been a
privilege and an honor, We love the service and appreciate everything we
get, and especially from the boots on the ground too.
I mean, these guys already know, but I'm eating dinner
Saturday with the 251, no, no, no,
252. Yeah. I was with 253 the other night.
I mean, I hang out with these guys all the time when I get a
chance, and it's just an honor to be out there with these guys,
and thanks for your leadership too. And Tony for all the numbers and everybody
that supports us. Even the— I appreciate you making the drive
down here, by the way. Thank you very much.
Yeah, thanks.
All right. No other discussion or questions on that, right?
I was going to, just for everybody's sake, state some other facts,
but it doesn't— I don't think it matters and we covered it, so we'll move
on. I want to go back to 1A. I mentioned that we're going to push
that back to 10/20. I just want to know if
there's any notes specifically that we can say, hey,
maybe look at this or look at that, so when it comes back,
it's maybe a little bit more prepared or
ready. Is there anything specific that you want to
ask if there's some— Go ahead. Yeah,
I was just gonna say, I think that what I'm trying to balance
in my mind is there are, in my
neighborhood, for example, there's a property that has 6 trailers lined
up. I can't imagine anyone owning 6 trailers. So I have
to imagine they either have a lot of family members or it's become kind
of a community parking lot. It's hard to tell
who's renting what. There was a, uh, a, uh,
someone who posted, I think they have some acreage, and they just posted
on the Eagle Mountain Citizens page, hey, you know, rent out
my land, come just park your trailer here. And so
I think there needs to be some definition around what the code— to give our
code enforcement folks some actual tangibles
of, I don't know if we're looking up license plate numbers to see if they're
registered. To that property owner. But I also understand
there's situations where maybe you do have 5 acres and a family member is
parking their RV. So they're, you know,
potentially for larger lots might be some room to have
more than maybe 1 or 2 recreational vehicles. But as,
you know, smaller lots, it just doesn't look great and
it does impact property values people
that are their next-door neighbor maybe trying to sell their house. So that's
the balance I think I'm trying to strike in my mind is what code
should exist to do that. So is there something that was in the packet that
you think needs to kind of be worked on a little bit so we can
have some specific direction to tie it to? How to enforce? How to enforce
as well. That was something that I kind of was wondering based off
of what you said. It's like how would How would staff even
begin to know if it's a relative or not is one of the questions
that I have. So Brandon, did the code enforcement
guys, have they weighed into this? I just want to know if they feel like,
or if they're going to be here to answer if they thought that this is
going to be, you know, how they would go about enforcing it.
Yeah, they want some more direction. The current code,
they feel kind of is vague. Vague enough that it doesn't
help them as much as it could. So I think that's what— between
now and the 20th, are they going to have a
chance to say this isn't going to work so that we can get a little
bit further down the road? I know that the attached code that
was in your packet, they had neighborhood improvement
work with David Stroud to prepare that, and so they felt like that—
They like it. that code. So they have worked on this issue,
and they, they— that, yeah, that, that code was based on
working with them.
Did it go? Yeah. I mean, I just want to bring up the fact
that we've already reviewed this and denied almost identically what it
says in here, uh, within the last 12 months. Um,
I am never going to be in favor of us trying to have our code
enforcement try to establish licensure? Are we going to go start knocking
on doors and having them provide documents? I think that that's not even
feasible. So I think if we're going to spend time on
this, I think we ought to make sure that there's support from at least a
majority of people. Otherwise, I think it's a waste of time. So, so are you—
so are you suggesting then that you'd be okay with
someone parking as many trailers as they can on their lot? That's not what I
said. Well, that's why I'm asking the clarifying question. I don't think there's a way
for you to be able to determine that? How are you going to determine if
they're doing it for a friend? How many is too many? Are you going
to base it on size of lot? Are you going to base it on what
your personal perspective is on a piece of land? I think
that there's too many variables in there that become worldview rather than
it's actually creating a nuisance. You know,
I talked with Brett about this before. I mean, we've had this discussion at
length. I am not in favor of being
overly punitive for how people use their
property. When people buy large properties, interesting enough,
Brett drove around and identified many trailers on
pieces of property that would probably be shocking to the people sitting on the
dais here. And so I think perhaps
we ought to make sure that our own houses are in order before we do
something So,
so you— if there were a way to enforce
well enough, you'd be open to some kind of— I just think we become an
HOA at that point, and you know how I feel about HOAs. Let them use
their property unless they're doing something that's a nuisance. Yeah, having 12
trailers on there is probably not appropriate, but what is the right number and
who gets to make that determination? Well, and then I, and I think
that's the purpose of bringing it back for a discussion, to see, to see if
we could figure out a nuanced way to, to handle that. Is there 3 people
who want to do that? Because the staff's already been through this cycle,
and how this is written is no different than what we said no to.
I'm, I'm open for discussion. I am, I am as well. I,
I am too, because I think that we have zoning for a
reason. I feel like there's people who are on our council that have said that
to me in the past. And whether it's commercial or residential
really dictates the use that you can use for it. And if you're renting out
37 slots for 37
RVs on your 1 or 2-acre piece of property,
that's probably extending past what residential is.
Um, I don't want to be punitive. I want people to be able to use
their land, but I also think we have a due duty to make sure
that their neighbor's property rights are protected as well.
So I would like to discuss it. And I've, I've been thinking about this too.
I mean, and I did have some conversations with Council Member Wood about this.
And for me, I'm just— I, I'm not sure that this
is the right approach. From my perspective, I'd like to see us perhaps
revisit our home-based business code and see if there's not something that we could already
do to that code to tighten it up a little bit,
create some definitions. Because for me, the substantive
difference is this: is it a residential use in
a residential neighborhood by a resident that owns the property, or is it
a semi-commercial use or something that's grown beyond the
scale of a residential use? And how do you tell the difference between the two?
I'm not sure how you do that, but I think that's the— I think
that's the gray area that causes the I think
in my mind, if I see a trailer,
which is pretty common throughout the city, you'll see it on a side yard or
no big deal. But when you see 5 or 6 trailers
on a property, I'm like, what is the personal
use that's not screened? But Zach, I went by one of my
neighbors on the way to the— on the way to the building today, and they
had 6 trailers sitting there. There was a dump trailer, there's a UTV
hauler, there's a camp trailer, there's a— I
can't remember all of them— a horse trailer. I mean, there's just— so— But I
think to blanket that is, I think there are some folks who
probably have a need for that and it's their personal residence.
And are we going to say 2 and you're done, that's a problem?
I'm not willing to go there. But I, I, but I But I
also think it's a real problem when we have some of our residents who are
saying, I'm going to house 30 or 40 trailers that don't belong
to me, charge a rent for that, and subject
all of my neighbors to the traffic and to the blight that that brings.
So I think there is a balance that we need to find.
Agreed. And I think that, you know, the different
types of trailers, you know, there's like my— I have family He's
a brick mason. He's got an RV trailer, OHV,
all good. I think here this is talking about— Yeah,
probably a wheelbarrow on a trailer that you mix concrete in, right? But this,
this specifically I think identifies a recreational vehicle,
something that you can live in, vacation in. You know,
a horse trailer wouldn't qualify under this definition that I'm reading.
So we're specifically looking for You know,
fifth wheels, motorhome, truck camper,
camping trailer, travel trailer. That's what it's identified in here. And I think
that kind of narrows the list of what's being rented out, at least
in my mind. But I think that it's— I think the problem is bigger in
a very minor way and small way. I mean, we have lots that have half
a dozen dump trucks or some big commercial vehicles
that are being stored or that come come every morning and leave every night.
And it's, it's a commercial hub of business in a residential area.
And so I just think those are the things that, that are, that are operating
outside of what I believe should be happening in a residential neighborhood.
And so I don't know if this is the perfect approach,
but that's the problem that I think we ought to tackle rather than being so
myopically focused on how many trailers and what type of trailers. It's like,
how can we allow people to use their property in the
way that they choose? And if they have 6 trailers and they're their trailers,
who cares? I don't care. But I do care when
it becomes an issue for the neighbors. It's perhaps— perhaps some screening needs
to be considered. I mean, I've thought about that. Maybe some screening requirements if you're
going to do something that's a little more excessive. Maybe those trips per day that
we talk about in the, in the in
the home-based business code. I mean, once you generate, I don't remember the
number, 15 or 20 trips a day, you're no longer a home-based business.
If you've got more than one employee and yourself that's working there,
you're outside of the code function. So I think there's some other mechanisms
that we could evaluate and perhaps tweak to allow
some of this to be used in a way
that is meaningful for the residents, But detrimental to commercial
operations that are happening in our residential neighborhoods. I just
want to make one clarification here. The definition for the recreation vehicles
include fifth-wheel trailers, boat,
OHV, self-propelled, used for recreation. So it's
not just livable trailers in 10.10.090.
So I think that encompasses a lot of the things that we were talking about.
I just My
biggest problem with this is that this is really not about a nuisance
that it's causing to adjoining people. It's more or
less people, I don't like the look of it. That's such
a subjective thing. And I think we have
way too much of that, frankly. We start to impede
on people's ability to use the property they're spending hundreds hundreds of thousands of dollars
on, uh, to be able to live there without everybody else telling them how
to live. So for me, look,
I get it if they have a trailer on every speck of
their property. I think it's pretty obvious there's an issue there.
If we're going to go forward with this, then let's set some guidelines that are
achievable. I think asking our code
enforcement to go chase down registrations is not suitable for
them. That's too much. And I think they would probably agree with that. When we
went through that before, they weren't in favor of that. To Brett's point with
the home businesses, again, you're still going to have to establish— look,
they've got 6 trailers on there. Are we going to go knock on the door
and ask them if they have a business license to operate those? They say they're
all my family. How are you going to determine one way or the other?
Would you, would you be open to screening Requirements. I think
screening is fine. I even said to Brett, maybe there's, uh, you can look at—
and again, I'm not in favor of being punitive in any way,
but maybe there's a lot size that allows for a certain envelope
of that property to be utilized for vehicular storage
that is running, or trailers, or whatever. Maybe that's, maybe that's a direction
that we can at least talk about. But yeah, they should be screened.
But if they get to agricultural and rural and we're talking that big, I mean,
how are you going to screen 5 acres, 10 acres? I think that there needs
to be a further conversation. But I think this all leads back to— I think
we can workshop this and try to reach a better spot than where we currently
are. And so, and then, so do we do that in another work
session? Yeah, just move it to the 20th. I guess I was wondering if
there's anything specifically that— and there's good
Is there enough time? So like, we're going to need— like,
15 minutes won't solve the problem, and 30 minutes might not. We might
need 45 minutes in a work session, maybe an hour. I don't know what
else is on the docket that day. I was just going to say, it sounds
like policing is probably not going to be a viable
option for code enforcement anyway. So maybe we're talking about lot
I would maybe go one step further. If you feel strongly about this, maybe 2
of you can go and work with David to figure that out and then bring
it for the rest of us to review. Yeah, I think maybe
that's what I was looking for, because what I was getting at,
Councilmember Wood, is what you said, is we've looked at this and what,
what could David do any different than, uh, this got put back
on the priority list. And we're trying to figure out how we
move it forward, and it's still— it's tough. So I know,
Councilmember Heros, just something you— I think you're the one that put it on there.
So would you work throughout the next couple weeks to get this
in a good place?
He's not jumping forward.
I'm just thinking about my plate. We could Huh?
I said all of a sudden everyone wants to table it. No, I'm just kidding.
No, I'll work with you, Councilmember Hewish.
Yeah, we'll get it done. Maybe, Melissa, it would be
good for you to give some input. I mean, you voted against it the last
time, but if you see something differently now, maybe you should give some input as
to why. I'll share this since we won't be able to work as
a quorum, but I have,
had multiple businesses talk to me about how it's unfair that
some people are operating commercial entities out of their home and
they are kind of paying less for
their land, paying less for their taxes, all of those things.
And then there's ones who are following the letter of the law and doing everything
the way they're supposed to. And they're the ones that are following the
law are at a disadvantage to the ones that are just kind of doing things
under the table and not within code. So I think that might
be something to look at, because I do think Councilmember Wright has a point that
this may have more to do with home-based business requirements
than how many trailers per square foot.
So— We're good then? Okay, if you guys would get together and Brandon,
let him know that These 2 will set up a meeting and see if we
can move forward. I'm wondering if it's, uh,
I'm wondering if October 20th is enough time.
I think we should hold it off until it's ready. Yeah.
Because, so, so go ahead and just put that as a future. There's nothing
pressing other than it's on the list, and we know, I know we've been to
some meetings. It's got— we need to move it forward, but let's
give it some time. So Just tell David to get some meetings,
and when it's ready, we'll bring it back. So,
okay, then we'll hold that one off. Let's move on to—
actually, Lacey, did you hear from— I
was just reaching out. Lacey and I've been communicating back and forth on this,
and we don't see the Giffords here to be able to
talk to this, but the information
is in the council's packet. Packet, I provided some context for the council,
um, and I'm happy to maybe just at least represent the issue
and see if there's any questions or concerns of whether the council has a desire
or not to move forward with this, um, in next—
because there's no, no actionable item this time. But long
story short, um, the city of Eagle Mountain was approached by, um, Mr.
and Mrs. Gifford, who are trained, uh, chaplains and
have offered their services to the city of Eagle Mountain. In my
last city, we had chaplain services for our
police and our fire departments. It's another form of employee assistance
program. It's kind of in times of crisis.
And in fact, there was one particular week when in
my last community, we had 3 baby deaths in a
row that our EMTs and firefighters had responded to, and it was taking
quite a toll on the mental state of our
first responders. And so we had a chaplain that
was just part of the organization, both for police and fire. They had an office.
It was completely volunteer, no costs, no obligation, no proselyting,
no— completely non-denominational
and whatnot. Just a quick question. Just a resource not only
to city personnel but also
to victims and victim advocacy,
members of the public if there's some sort of a traumatic event.
And in order for someone to become a chaplain,
they have to go through specific training and,
and obtain that certification and, and also receive the
endorsement from a municipality. So this is what their request
was of the mayor. Um, uh, I am
completely indifferent on the issue, just wanted to bring it to you for your consideration.
And, um, if it's something the council would like to move forward with, we can
put it on a future agenda. I only have one question. How do you
determine who you want to use as your chaplain? Let's say that, uh,
the Giffords are great, they move, or the Giffords aren't great
and we want to find somebody else, or, you know,
whatever the reasons are, how is that decision made? So, um,
the way that it works is the certification program, the entity itself that
does provide that, that mental health training that they've received their certification
from, would be the responsible entity that would be providing that service for
us. And when that question was asked of them, that mayor asked that
exact same question, they did indicate in that room that they
would want to try to bring others on board, at least 1 or 2 or
whatnot, so that they have some sort of succession planning and continuity.
You know, because there's times when they might be out of town or something of
that nature and other assistance might be needed. Does that require us doing an agreement
with that organization so that the continuity is there?
You know, I don't know. I don't— Honestly, I've never
had an agreement before. It wasn't a formal interlocal or anything like
that. It was something that was in establishment before I got there,
and it's something I think evolved. I think it's very common
back east, especially in fire and police situations.
But you
know, maybe if the council is inclined to do that, maybe. is something
that you can assign as a mayoral responsibility
that he could, you know, bring the next one on or something of that nature
without necessarily having to have council action. Yeah, I just— I'm trying to walk through.
I assume that we just need to recognize that there is a program.
That's what I read. And then how do we institute
it to begin and what the— I, I— it's
a little more Like, I guess, understanding of
how to help them to be successful in that. I understand what they do.
How do we make sure that it's moving forward? And maybe you're
right, maybe it is the mayor that kind of oversees that and reappointing
them after a period of time, maybe if they're going to retire or whatever.
It could be probably as simple as an appointment with the consent of council,
something like that that we could put together. And, uh,
and certainly we would want to make sure that contact
information was available to the public if some kind of event occurred or whatnot,
that they would have resources. Okay, thanks.
Mayor, go ahead. Um, Ben, you mentioned that this is
pretty common back east. Um, are there other cities in
Utah that are doing this, and does ULCT have any resources to
be able to address some of the concerns that Council Member Wood brought up,
because I do think the continuity of service and letting people
know that they exist, like, all of those things are important. Um,
so I'm just wondering, do you know of more cities that have this?
I don't know in Utah. Um, it's a good question. I can certainly put that
out to the city managers group to see who, who might have one or,
or more on board. Um, uh,
and I'm, I'm not— it's never come up in the time that I've served as
city manager with any of the league entities, you know,
league meetings or anything that I've been involved in. Definitely it
was something I saw growing up in New York, and it was something in Iowa
as well. Thank you. Yep. Do the individual public
safety organizations not have chaplains of their own? I thought
that the Sheriff's Department and the UFA both had chaplains. I don't
know. Does the Sheriff's Department? I don't think UFA I think UFA does, but I,
I'm not sure. But you do have a chaplain?
I'm pretty sure UFA does as well, as far as I know.
Yeah, yeah, I think— and I was looking— How's this going to function differently then?
Maybe that's my question. It would be available also to city staff
or to the public in general. I know that they— it's my understanding anyway
that they responded to the fire that we had out on the ranches in that
apartment complex. It's a resource that's available. I see
it as a benefit. I think we should engage in this.
Camp Williams has one. There's a lot around. And our
discussion, just for context, wasn't designating them the
Eagle Mountain chaplain. It's recognizing them
as a chaplain. That way if they show up, they've got basically
a recognition that, yeah, it's not just some Joe
Blow that's saying he's a chaplain. And it's a rec— you know, that's what
I think they're trying to accomplish. It just identifies that they've been
certified. And you can use them in city functions?
Could. Don't have to. I don't think the intent is for them to become the
city's chaplain, like we would say for Camp Williams.
But they're a chaplain within the city. Yeah.
Yeah, I mean, I engaged with the— It's the
Giffords, right? I engaged with them at the 4th of July celebration,
um, at the— not the 4th of July celebration, sorry, the, uh,
what was it? It's a Memorial Day celebration at the cemetery. That's where it was.
I had to think about where it was. I remember we were at the cemetery
when we talked, and I mean, they seem like really great people. And the
question that I keep wondering is, what's the downside? I mean, and I tend to
agree with you, Councilmember Whiting. I, I'm not seeing a downside.
I mean, if they were trying to proselytize or trying to
convert or some of those things, then maybe that creates some
angst. That's correct. Because I'm certainly not interested in doing that.
But just being a resource that's available to the community, that the community can approach
and say, I just really need to talk to somebody that can listen
and that can offer me some— just a listening ear
and some guidance if I choose to accept that, you know.
I just, I think there's some real benefit in that.
I was just thinking how it might be useful. I mean, we're a fairly sizable
city, and it might be useful to put
it out there to different denominations and just say, hey,
if you have a trained chaplain in your midst, we would love
to include them on the list of chaplains that the city associates
with, just to kind of have a deep bench.
I just— I think, especially during
tight budget times, any time that you can get additional
services, or victim advocate services,
like all of those things, it's worth doing it. But I want
us to make sure that we're getting as many
as that are out there, so that we have enough people to help when there
is something that goes wrong. Thank you. I'm not against it. Let's do it.
The only thing I would suggest is that they would be required
to go through the same type of training program so that they have the skills
necessary. Okay, so we
can reschedule this when they can come. We'll put it on either the
consent— We had anticipated having this on the consent on the 20th, but we can
maybe have them here this— that night. Then they can at least
address it through the consent in the work session. So make sure that they they
can be here, and then, yeah, let's look at it.
Sounds great. Okay,
next discussion is a portfolio update by Jace,
and we'd invite Aaron to
come and introduce us.
So, um,
I've invited our investment advisor to come kind
of give you guys a brief economic update and an overview.
of our investment portfolio, just to give a
kind of overview of where we're at as a city. We're hoping to
have them do this for us biannually with the
timing of, like, our state reporting that we have to fill out. So I'm
going to turn over the time to Jace Richards with Nieder Public
Funds.
Thank you, Mayor and councilmembers, for letting us come and present a little bit.
Just a brief introduction on Meader. So last time you heard
from us, we were Morton Asset Management. We have since merged with Meader
Public Funds, a public funds manager out of Ohio.
We've seen— Can you speak up? Yeah, sorry. Is that better? Okay,
perfect. Yeah, we've known Meader for quite a long time.
It's a public entity— or a private— privately held entity out of Ohio,
and they just seemed like a seamless fit. So we've since merged with them
back in April, and it's been a great merger so
far. We hope our clients have felt the same, particularly Eagle Mountain. So,
I can get right to it. I'll briefly go over the— just an economic
update. I'll keep it very high level, although if there's questions,
let me know, and then we can just dive into the portfolio, if that works.
Going into it, so, 5 things we're particularly looking
at when we're thinking about investing in your portfolio. Is what
the Fed's gonna do, inflation, growth, employment, and yields.
Really, these are the 5 key things that we believe impact the portfolio,
particularly what the Fed does with interest rates. So,
hopping to what the market's
expectation is for the Fed moving forward, whether we see interest rate hikes,
cuts, or them holding. At the beginning of the year, you can see the
market was predicting about 2 cuts throughout 2026,
which are typically a quarter of a percent. That has
since shifted, particularly around the time of the Iran war— or
the Iran conflict starting, to where now the market
is actually predicting that we may likely see 3 to 4 quarter-based—
or quarter-percent hikes in the next 12 months. We have already seen
one quarter-percent hike here in September.
In the October meeting, the market does not expect another hike. However, in the December
meeting, there is a higher probability. That being said, as the forecasts
go out, we just take a little bit more of a— you take it with
a grain of salt just because it's so far out. So much could change.
Much of these interest rate hike decisions have been based on inflation,
particularly because of the Iran war. We have seen a pretty big
surge in oil prices. With the surge in oil prices, oil prices, we've started to
see it trickle down into particularly gas and diesel.
Obviously, a major part of our economy is transportation,
so seeing gas and diesel go up can have trickle effects even further.
And so to curb potential inflation, they've pushed
into more of a hiking cycle, you could say.
With that, you can look here, you can see, so the blue line is CPI
going up above 3% again, and then below is
a figure called Truflation. Essentially, it's a data scrape
of more prices, still above 2%, the 2% target,
but a little bit lower. What Kevin Warsh,
the chairman of the Fed, has said is that really this is going
to be a meeting-by-meeting decision. We, we don't
expect it to be a hiking cycle quite like in 2022
where they jumped 500 or 5%.
This is likely going to be you know one
or two cuts, and then see what they need to do in the future.
So with that, we are still seeing pretty stable employment
and growth in the economy. Consumers still are spending,
and we're not seeing a major surge in unemployment. So with that,
there really is no reason for the Fed to cut rates right now. If we
started to see a little bit more of that, that would raise concern and maybe
put the Fed on edge to either keep rates steady or potentially cut.
But right now, the bigger picture is the inflation picture. So with
that, it really does benefit the portfolio. We've seen yields come up over the last
month to where this is covering the 2-year Treasury note.
You can see we're up in about the 4.9% range right
now in 2026. This is really higher than we've been in a long
time. So with your portfolio, it's a great opportunity because we're able
to invest at these higher rates. That being said, I make the
joke that what's good for your portfolio maybe isn't always good as we see interest
rates on mortgages and everything up as well. So with
that, one other benefit we're seeing in the portfolio is this is the
U.S. Treasury yield curve. This tells you U.S. Treasuries from 3 months all the
way out to 30 years. The orange line is where we are right now,
and you can see it is what we call upward sloping. Essentially, that means
that long-term rates are higher than short-term rates. So as we
look to invest in things out to the 5-year for your portfolio,
we're able to get a higher rate in today's current environment. So really benefiting
there.
I can skip over this. This essentially shows kind of the Essentially
cash, which would be the orange line, or the Fed funds rate versus the 2-year
Treasury. Typically the 2-year Treasury's higher. We're starting to see,
we've seen that inflection point where the 2-year Treasury is once again outperforming
the Fed funds rate, or you could argue that is what your cash
accounts would get. Any questions or thoughts
on the economy before we move forward? Last question.
Oh, this is just, this is the end of the economic portion.
rest of the portfolio, but do you have economic questions you'd like to?
No. Okay. All right.
I'll hop into the portfolio. So, as you can see right now,
we're sitting at about $51.2 million market
value in the portfolio, getting around 4.3% at about
a 2.1 weighted average maturity on
the investments that we hold. We do expect this yield to go to go up
over the next year, particularly as we see interest rates have gone
up. And I'll show you that on the next slide, kind of what we've been
investing in over the last 6 to 7 months.
But yeah, in a really good spot, pretty well laddered from zero out—
zero year— or from your zero to 1 year out to your 4 to
5 year range. As we look to invest, we might look— we may look to
invest a little bit longer term as rates are getting higher and kind of at
a longer term or a more unique position relative to the
last 20 years of investing. Any questions there before
I move on to the next? Okay.
So, this is what we've been able to purchase in the portfolio since the beginning
of the year. You can see when the Fed— when there was an expectation
of Fed cuts going forward, you can see we were kind of investing,
if you look in the yield to maturity bar, We were investing in the 4%
range. As you come down, a little bit of high 3-percenters,
but then as we go into the end of this,
the end of the summer and coming out into October,
we're looking more in the mid to high 4s, and even now today, we're starting
to invest in the low 5s. So that's where we see that yield,
or the expectation of yield growth over the next year come from,
is as we're looking to invest.
This is just a historical report showing net income,
or net income from the— for the portfolio over the past fiscal
years. You can see obviously 2022 when there was, you know,
abysmal interest rates, you could barely get 1%. We were at
about 1.22%, moving up to now fiscal year 2025
ended at 4.6%, fiscal year 2026 at 4.3%. Thank you.
And we expect with where interest rates are fiscal year 2027
likely around that 4.5 range again with that
expectation. So in a really good spot.
Also probably just above $2 million.
However, on this next page, this is with the securities that
are currently held in the Eagle Mountain portfolio. You should expect
about one or at least $1.9 million.
This is what is could argue contractually owed due to the securities
you own. So this is what you will get, even just
in income, not considering any reinvestment or any change
in price. This is strictly just income. So any
thoughts or questions or concerns about the portfolio?
I'll just wait until the end. Okay.
This is the last slide. This is just showing your breakdown between investments the
PTIF holdings and deposits. The only update to this one
would be that we've added fiscal year 2025, or the end of fiscal
year 2025 breakdown. But really sitting in a great
spot. We can see the growth in cash reserves over the last
almost decade as Eagle Mountain has grown kind of
at a same pace. So in a good spot.
Outside of that, that really ends the Before
Councilmember Herwish jumps in, and I'm sorry, Councilmember Clark,
to do this, but I'm just wondering if you or Ben or someone could just
explain to those, those of us that are a little more laypeople when
it comes to this. Yes. I'm really interested in helping our citizens
understand why does Eagle Mountain have a $52 million portfolio? Where does that money
come from? And where's it going?
And what, what, Why are we managing a portfolio of this size?
Thank you. That was exactly what I wanted to know. So I think it's
important context for people to know rather than good grief,
there's $52 million in an account that's drawing interest. What is
Eagle Mountain doing with that money? I think it's important for people to understand where
that money came from and where it's going. And just to add to that,
this is just a portion of the city's total liquid
assets. So this is— no, no. Well,
go ahead. I was just going to say some is with the PTIF,
with the state fund, and some has been broken out and METER is managing that
portion. Yeah, so I can answer this question. Really,
at the end of the day, it's good for a city to have a healthy
size of cash reserves, especially a city
like Eagle Mountain considering you've had pretty, I'd argue,
explosive growth over the last 10 years.
Having healthy reserves to compete or to keep up with that Essentially
helps the taxpayer today, but also helps the taxpayer tomorrow. With that
as well, the reason why you invest in a portfolio with Meader, as— sorry,
what was your last name? Hewish. Hewish. As Councilmember Hewish said, quite a
bit of the funds, if you look here, are actually with the PTIF, the Utah
Treasurer's Office, about 65%. However, the rationale
for keeping a little bit with investment firms like Meader is that METER
is a little bit more strategic and can tailor investment solutions to the city.
Now, METER does have to follow the Utah Money Management Act, which requires us
to follow very conservative guidelines. We cannot invest the funds longer than 5
years. However, as I showed before, typically when you
invest longer term over a long time period, you can expect a little
bit of a higher yield while also creating more stable interest
income. So as yields fall, if the Fed comes out
and cuts rates, your portfolio is somewhat insulated as we're
investing a little bit longer term. You're covered in
that aspect, if that makes sense. I think you're— oh, sorry. I think
you're doing a really good job of explaining what the money is and what it's
doing. Okay. I think Councilmember Wright— Why does it exist? Yeah,
Councilmember Wright and I, and I'm sure many taxpayers, are like,
Where is this money coming from? What's the source of it?
And then what does the city use it for? When do we spend it?
What is it like? Tell us more, someone. A real simple
explanation. Yeah. Yes. Okay. Maybe I'll jump in. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Those questions and whatnot. So revenues can come from various different sources,
but the primary sources would be from taxes,
from fees, and,
and those, and firm user rates and whatnot. So basically,
as far as the city is concerned, we need to have a certain amount of
reserves as a rainy day fund. So the state of Utah allows
us to have no more than 35% but no less than
5% of next year's projected revenues. And so
we, we have those in place in case something happens. You want to
have a certain amount of reserves that if we did not have operations If
some catastrophe happened, you didn't have revenue coming in, you could maintain operations
for a certain number of days throughout the year. At any given
point in time, we also fall into different times
of the year. So much of our tax resources come in, as far as like
property taxes, all at one time. And, and so we
might be up in a certain part of the year and down in another part
of the year. So rather than stick those revenues in a shoebox,
Right. We choose to invest them and get a return on
the taxpayers' investments of user
fees. Correct. And of taxes. I just think it's really important to understand what,
what is there and why it's being generated. And there might be a
capital project that's out there on the list that's going to be funded out of
some of these funds, but it's not done yet and we haven't received a bill
yet, so we can't pay it. So what are you doing with the resources in
the meantime? I just think it's really important. important that people understand that, that these
are not unallocated, right? They're not— they don't have a home.
They're not extra, with the exception of the reserve.
Anyway, and, and the reserve that we've chosen to keep is 35%, and we're struggling
to do that this year with some of the tax issues that we're having.
It's likely going to be less than that, just so people hear that and understand
it. And even at a 35% reserve, we're only looking
at a 6-month a 6-month window to be able to get from
here to solving whatever problem we have with those reserves. So I
just, I want the layperson, I want my daughter and my son
who live here to understand that if they have questions. I don't want it to
be hard for them to understand. Exactly right. And it's probably
also important to understand that there are times when a city might
take on a major project for which we might have a lot of bond proceeds
that are sitting in the bank that we then have until
anticipated costs that come out of that. So there's different times, not only in the
cyclical nature of a city but also in a cyclical nature of
a project. And then it's also important to note that we have many different buckets.
So the general fund is different from the water fund and the sewer fund
and, and that type of thing. And so we, we have— each of our enterprise
funds has to work like a business and has to have its own
reserves in place to be able to cover its own debt, debt coverage
ratios and things like that. But it needs to operate
so that it's not being— so we're not stealing money to come back into general
fund, nor is it being subsidized by the general fund. It's being operated as a
business entity. So there's lots of different reasons of how we get to
where we get, but you're absolutely right, we are stewards of the taxpayer resources,
and it's incumbent upon us to make sure that we utilize those resources to
the best our ability, and any interest coming off of those can be used for
the benefit of the residents we also serve. I couldn't have
said it better. I have a couple questions. I was just going to ask,
as far as you mentioned the Utah Money Management Act, what restrictions
on investments must METAs abide by, such as equities,
precious metals, et cetera? Could you tell us what confines you operate
in? Yeah, absolutely. As far as what we're able to invest in,
the vast majority of what we are able to invest in is essentially bonds
or loan issuances from the U.S.
government, from corporations, although corporations have a high A1
rating or higher. If you look at your asset allocation here,
only about 23% is in corporate bonds. Everything else is more
either implicitly or explicitly backed by the U.S. government. So certificates
of deposit are only up to the $250,000, or under the Utah Money
Management Act, it's $242,000 maximum.
And then U.S. agencies, U.S. Treasuries, and cash equivalents. So no equities,
no gold, no— essentially a very safe
bond portfolio is what we hold. So, and arguing this
again, only out to about 5 years, specifically for
managing both interest rates and liquidity. You, you do— we do
want an ample amount of liquidity available to the city within a few-year
time period. So, and then that's— Does that help answer the question?
Yeah, okay, I think so. And just kind of a little bit of a side
note, I guess, but you mentioned earlier, um,
like diesel prices and the war and different things, so I was
just curious if And especially here on the staff level, the executive order
this morning. Did you see this executive order? No highway
tax on— Yeah, red dye. So diesel can run— any
diesels that we have, especially snowplowing this winter, will be important.
Any diesel-ran trucks can run red dye on highway.
That's about 24.5 cents, I think. Almost 25 cents a gallon.
Yeah, almost 25 cents a gallon that goes to the federal
tax. And so it's
hot off the press, but are we going to implement a plan for
anything that's running diesel to go ahead and run that red
dye? Well, Mayor, my question
is, where are you going to find it? I think we store it. If we
do, that's great, because I mean, I just— I only know of one place that
sells it in Lehi. So I'm just curious what that supply chain looks like.
If not, we need to get a tank. And if that's the case, then that's
council if you wanna allocate that. We run a lot of diesel through
these trucks, I suppose, and that's why I'm kinda bringing it up in this discussion.
It was mentioned, but— Mayor, we do get our
taxes remated on fuel, the fuel and excise taxes,
so it doesn't make a difference. Even federal?
Yep. Okay, that's what I was asking, if it changed anything.
Doesn't matter to you, matters to me.
Thanks for your report. So I've just got a few questions. Yeah,
go ahead. If we could work through these. Do you know how long Morton/Meter
has been managing this section of the portfolio? I believe— let me
go here. I believe since around— let's
see, maybe I could ask Erin. I believe it's been since around 2015.
It was first when the city did the utility sales. Okay,
and, and that would be another thing, Brett, the $3 million from the utility sales
sitting in here, uh, somewhere. Okay,
and, um, would it be possible
in future presentations to benchmark? I would love to see—
it looks like our duration is a 2-year treasury. I'd love to see
that kind of— some kind of benchmarking data of— so that
the council can actually see the value. I think we pay 15 basis
points. Is that accurate as a fee to meter? Yeah, I believe 15
or around 12.5. Okay, so about 12 basis points.
It'd be nice to see that value creation
of here's what your portfolio did, here's what the 2-year Treasury did,
and maybe even here's what the state fund— I'm a big believer
that we have a lot of talent outside of the state of Utah managing fixed
income portfolios, and I would just love to see that borne out
in the presentation. And again, in a future presentation, if you could just break
out, here's the 2-year, here's where we're at, here's where the PTIF is, and we're
smoking them. That's what I'd love to see. No, absolutely. I think that'd be great.
We can include that in future. For now, I guess I could give a
basic number. So that'd be great. Yeah, PTIF came out at
around 3.97 for the same measure, uh,
at the end of September. Whereas these numbers are at the September
29th coming out about 4.3%, so you can kind of see the outperformance there.
Net of fees? I think net of fees it comes out to about 4
point— just under 4.2% or just over,
around 4.2%. 4.2%. So we got about 23 basis
points extra by having Meader manage the
portfolio. That's great. And then, yeah, in future meetings,
I can definitely provide something a little bit more detailed. Okay.
You mentioned the ability to ladder portfolios. So going back to Ben's
comments, as we have— as we take out a bond,
for example, for the sewer, which is going to be a pretty big project,
I don't imagine— does that all get funded at once? When we sell
the bond portfolio, we've got $250 million to figure
out how to build a bond duration
in our portfolio. It's gonna be a sizable amount.
Am I stating that correctly? I was gonna say, I know Mac
would love $250 million. Or whatever the number is.
It's a big number. But yes, and it will all come up front
in terms of that. We do have the spend-down schedule,
and we will have those funds
invested based on that. We have to directly try to match it to what
we anticipate for the cash flow. And that's where Metered could be helpful.
With PTIF, it's just one portfolio for the whole
state managed the same way without any thought of cash flows.
So that's where a private investment manager can kind of help us
ladder out those expenses. Can you
maybe just give us a little bit of understanding of What
the state requirements are for the—
kind of how are you handcuffed? You mentioned no equities.
Could you push all of the portfolio out to a 5-year
duration, or do you have to keep a certain duration of the portfolio at
2 years? So there— right
now there's only a final maturity of 5 years.
However, with the duration portfolio, We kind of
have an internal push to keep it under 3 years, arguably around
the 2.5 range. The rationale for this really is liquidity.
So when I say ladder portfolio, you can see you're invested a little
bit in the 0 to 1 year, a little bit in the 1 to 2
year, and the 2 to 3 year. What this does is it kind of helps
us to get the best of both worlds of investing longer term, so getting the
higher 5-year yield, but at the same time, we're not putting equal come out in
trouble if there does, you know, if there's an impending need to
use the funds. And so with that, the 5-year minimum,
or the 5-year maximum maturity set by the state of Utah,
is arguably already very conservative. However,
we like to keep a duration even shorter just
for the sake of liquidity. Does that help answer the question? Yeah. Okay. I think
so. And then my last question is, do we have an active investment
committee. What are you seeing with other cities as you're reviewing
this duration and decisions are being made within the portfolio?
Maybe report back, what are we doing and what are you seeing other
cities within Utah that are using METR in terms of an investment
committee, investment policy statement? Where could we improve our
practice? Yeah, yeah, great question. I think What we're seeing with other cities
is actually very similar to how we work with Eagle Mountain. So obviously here we
work with Kimberly and Erin, have either semi-annually
or 3 times a year visits. I think with Eagle Mountain,
actually, you're at a size now where we're having discussions about meeting 4
times a year, whether that's in person or Teams, where we get
a liquidity update, where we get a kind
of what is the city spending in the next year, or 6 months to a
year, even out to 2 years, just so that we can better plan
the shorter end of the portfolio. From there,
though, other cities— we do work with a couple other cities who have a finance
committee that meet together. However, similar to
Eagle Mountain, a lot of cities use us as more of a rainy day,
longer-term investment fund. And so typically the finance
committee discussions revolve around more of like what we're spending in the next 3
to 6 months. So METER, for most of
our Utah municipalities, we don't join those meetings unless it's
to do a presentation or if they are talking about longer-term reserves.
Does that make sense? Does that help answer the question? Yeah, I think
so. Are you seeing any cities— I'm just curious,
how much are you managing of the city's total assets
relative to PTIF? Are you seeing more
money move your way out of PTIF?
From what I can find, it sounds like there's only 4 or 5 cities in
the state that are breaking outside of the state portfolio.
Just curious what you're seeing as a trend. For the most part,
I'd say we have about half of our cities that use us more
as a rainy day fund that keep us at about 50% of their
total reserves or less. Other cities use us up to about 80% of
their reserves. We at METER have decided
we don't recommend giving us more than 80% of your reserves
to manage, simply because it— you know,
we could, we would just front-load it, but there's better options. We believe the
PTIF for the cash portion could be much better.
So we have a maximum that we usually top out at about 80%.
Okay. But I'd say it's about half that use us in that function, and the
other half use us just under 50%. Okay. Thank you. And I
guess here, I think it's about 30% that we manage.
Okay. Thank you. Perfect. Any other questions or
thoughts before I— Perfect. Well, thank you so much. I appreciate the
time to present. Okay, thank you. Is there anything else, Erin?
No, we're good. Thank you for your time. Okay, thank you. Appreciate you guys being
here. All right, um, Ben?
Um, boy, things are busy as ever and good things are happening.
Um, we are working just to keep the council informed.
We're working, uh, really hard on the wastewater treatment
facility and trying to get the permits necessary to be able to move forward,
hopefully setting groundbreakings in, in the,
in the weeks ahead, and working with
the state of Utah to ensure that we get the permits necessary to move forward.
We're also working with our, our financial advisors as far
as bonding is for that, that project is concerned, as well as for the RDA
project and the Kroger's and Lowe's project moving forward.
Please stop me if you have any questions on any of these things as I,
as I move forward with them. We are looking at our technology here
in our city and how we can make enhancements to that. So we're going to
be doing some analysis there. We're— I'm getting reports as we
speak about the volume, and I've got Carson, these guys kind of
working on it, but definitely a question mark.
Okay. We are actively moving
forward. We appreciate all of our staff and our HR team with all
of our new personnel that we're bringing on and the council support of bringing that
new staff on. A lot of hiring is going on, a lot of onboarding going
on, and there's going to be a lot of training. And so that's going to
be an extra workload for, for some of our staff as they bring new personnel
on, but with a long-term relief at the end when we, when we add these
great people to our team. We are continuing our leadership training
with leaders at every level of the organization and those who aspire to be leaders
within our organization, continuing to, to read a book
together. And we're going through Good to Great and going through the first several
chapters of that here next week. We're also
going through our water storage and drought mitigation planning and the
different activities that are involved in that with Central Utah Water and
other cities and, and planning and reviewing our,
our water portfolio in general and making sure our record keeping
is up to date. And so that activity is, is still going
forward. Of course, our— the council's been heavily involved in
our strategic planning of late, working on vision statements and working
on our focus areas, and we look forward to continuing
that discussion with our staff at every level to ensure that we're aligned with the
direction and the will of the council in serving the, the residents.
Of course, we're going to be kicking off our, our budget here in
the weeks ahead and our audit in the next couple of weeks. And so there's
lots of meetings popping up on calendars with regard to,
to our budget as well. And then there's been a lot of activity when it
comes to economic development, different activities at
council has been invited out to, uh, new restaurants and, and new businesses opening up.
So great, great activity, um, on behalf of our economic development
team as well. Um, several road projects underway— our Trailhead
intersection here outside of City Hall, um, Campus Drive intersection,
um, widening south of Pony Express, south of, uh, Eagle Mountain
Boulevard. And the, the— we're all looking forward to reviewing the safety study
tonight. Not looking forward to losing David, but we're appreciative
of the service that has been rendered and the good work
that's going on in that regard. Several wells are moving forward.
Well 7 is under design, and as far as
that wellhouse is concerned, Well 8 is about to come online in the
week— a week or two ahead with a testing, water quality testing
that would be needed to put that into, into implementation.
And the drilling is complete on Well 9, and, um,
and the work is going forward to be able to test pump that here soon,
as well as the water tank, uh, the new 4 million gallon water tank
that is progressing as well. Our community service,
um, organization is doing a great job, and the boards, uh, and the
volunteer work and the different aspects of the projects that they're moving forward with.
They're working hand in hand with our
parks crews and our streets crews. They just finished
off the paving of the trail out in the Wilden Park
area. Our crews are working on the widening
of the sidewalk over on Golden Eagle, and great work is moving forward
in that regard too. I'm sure that I'm missing people
people, but, um, and, and some of the activities that we have going on.
But just know that our staff is actively working in every area.
And later on when I review all of the different activities
coming up, it's important to note that our farmers market,
the last farmers market, is going to be this coming week. And so we want
to thank Jen for all the work that has been
done to make our farmers market such a success this past
Yeah, lots of fun stuff. Any questions on that update? Okay,
then we need to get through some of these consent items.
Um, the— I'm going to start off with 10A,
the Firefly, uh, Phase 8,
Plat 9. Mayor, I'm, I'm going to ask I'd like to move that both item
10A and 10B removed so that I can recuse myself from
any vote on those.
OK, and so those will be voted on separately.
And we'll do that right after the consent agenda vote.
We'll just pull those vote and then go back to anything else. So 10A
and 10B, then Harmony Phase A. Stop me
if there's any questions. Overland Village 2 Phase A and Overland
Village 2 Phase A, uh, it's Plat 4 and Plat 5.
Uh, minutes A and B from September 15th,
September 24th.
Resolutions 12A, um,
the resolution of Eagle Mountain approving the ranch's Parkway Improvement Interlocal
Agreement with Utah County. Is there any questions,
or did you have any presentation at all?
No, no presentation, just that we're eager to get starting that project. Design has
been funded already, so we're here. We have RFP kind of ready to go once
that's approved. Has to go to County Commission the following week, and then we can
get started on that RFP for design. Okay, who did
you have? Uh, 12B, Resolution of Eagle Mountain approving
a purchase agreement with Smith's Food and Drug.
Nothing. And then 12C,
Resolution of Eagle Mountain, Utah approving the purchase agreement with various residents
to purchase Utah land. Uh, it's a multiple of parcels.
Is there any questions on that? The only question I have about that, Mayor,
is where's the money going? I'm just curious. Is it just
going in the general fund? Is that what happens to it from
the sale of those properties? I mean, when we, when we dispose of property,
and there's several of them that they've been working on for a year plus,
right? Yes. Um, where does that money go? It does go into the general
fund. And does it show up under a certain line item,
or does it just— how does it come in? We do have a line item
that says sale of assets. OK, that's what I wanted to know. Thank you.
While we're talking about that for one second, when we talked about
this a long time ago, and this has come back and forth, one of the
things was that we set it aside specifically for some improvements in either parks or
open space. Is that— That's the reason I wanted to know. I just
want to make sure that it comes in separate so that when we're looking at
the budget, we can, we can assess that and say, look,
we sold $45,000 worth of property in this area.
What kind of improvements do we want to bring and where are we going to
locate them? So that, that, that's the reason I asked. I also— oh,
go ahead. Sorry, Mayor. Um, I also would like to see it really kind of
separated in a way so that we can track it but
also be accountable to the residents. In our strategic
planning meeting that we had last week, we talked about different park spaces and
expanding and, you know, different things like that. It'd be really great to
say that we funded the purchase of land for expansion
by using the funds from selling some of the land. And I
think that's just a good practice. So if there's a way, just like from a
bookkeeping standpoint, Kimberly, that we can watch it and monitor And
know we've got about this. And I'm not like how we did
the utility fund per se. I just,
just a way for us to be able to see what it is. And because
if it comes in in the way that you described, if we sell a truck,
if we sell vehicles, it's going to be all lumped together, right?
No, that would all happen in the fleet fund separately
from that. But just in regards to the land disposals of what the
council's done, we I just want to make sure that everybody understands that we haven't
had any significant revenues come in on that,
and the ones we had previously talked about either
didn't end up going through or they were ones where they would pay when they
sold their property, like a separate agreement was done, not something where the
city had received money up front. But when we initially looked at some of these
pieces when Todd Black was involved in it,
some of the money as we recouped it was to hopefully be able
to go to offset the cost of trying to work through these open space
mitigation of— and the land disposals themselves.
Have any of the residents in this specific application chosen
the path of waiting to pay for it or paying for it over time?
I can't remember. So they're all prepared to pay for it now? That is my
understanding, yes. Okay, great.
Okay, so we're gonna track that separately and then make a note,
whether it's Terrence or Kimberly, that as we go through the budget process,
we call it out specifically. 'Cause I think what I don't wanna do is see
it sit there and not get used. So let's find a place to
just be thinking about where we can use it and put it to work.
Let's see, that was the— that was 12C,
right? Yep. Okay, 12D. I got
something here too, Mayor. Sorry.
Oh yeah, resolution. I'm, I'm going to just ask that, that, that be pulled
so that we can have a separate vote on it, please. Okay. 12D, the community
garden policy. Is there just a separate vote or is
there any questions or discussion that we need to work on during the vote?
No, I just think that I'm going to have a difference of opinion from the
council and want to make sure that I have a right or the opportunity to
vote differently should I Okay, is there any other questions
on that specific one, on the language, any updates?
Okay. Um,
I just gotta remember, you guys are keeping track, I'm sure.
Okay, so that's all of the consent
agenda. As far as scheduled items, uh, 13A is
a Resolution authorizing disposal of some
parcels of land. Do we need to hold off on this discussion? I'm really
just— I always do this, but I'm wondering, is there anything in the scheduled items
that we can work out right now that we need to discuss, or do you
guys want to wait? I think we have— we
do have some— a lot of closed session items that Is
there anything on Corrigan Farms that we need to ask questions on?
I think— go ahead. I was going to say, I think some of the questions
for some of those will be with the applicants, um,
when they come. So it might be useful to wait, and especially
since there's been some public interest in some of these, it'd be almost better
to hash it out in front of the public so that they
can see kind of the deliberative It's
going to be a long night.
Did you have anything besides that? No. Okay.
So any of the IFFP stuff?
Okay. If there's nothing else that
we need to discuss right now until the policy session,
I will take a motion. Mayor, I move to adjourn
to a closed session for the purpose of discussion of pending or reasonably imminent
litigation, the character, professional competence, or physical
or mental health of an individual, the purchase, lease,
sale, or exchange of real property, a proposed development agreement,
project proposal, or financing proposal related to
the development of land owned by the state or a political subdivision
and/or deployment of security personnel, devices, or systems
pursuant to Section 52-4-205 of the Utah
Code Annotated. Second. Okay, we have a motion by Councilmember
Hewish and a second by Councilmember Whiting,
and we'll start the vote with Councilmember Whiting. Yes. Councilmember Wood.
Yes. Councilmember Hewish. Yes. Councilmember Clark. Yes.
Councilmember Wright. Yes. Okay, it is 5:34
and we'll adjourn to closed session.
You guys good?
All right, welcome. October 6th, it is 7:04,
and before we get started, uh, Council Member Hughes is going to offer prayer.
Our dear, kind Father in heaven, we come before thee tonight grateful
for the opportunity we have to meet in this public setting to discuss various
policy decisions. Grateful for the great residents of
Eagle Mountain. Ask thy blessing to be upon them and their families.
Grateful for the police, fire, those that
keep, keep us safe. Ask thee to bless and protect
them. We're grateful for this good land in which we live. Grateful for the many
opportunities that it affords us. And pray that we may have
good discussions that will have positive outcomes tonight for all the residents of Eagle Mountain.
Amen. We pray for these things in the name of Jesus Christ. Amen.
Amen. All right, now it's 7:05.
We'll officially call this meeting to order,
and, um, Council Member Clark's going to lead us in
the Pledge of Allegiance. Please join me in the Pledge of Allegiance.
I pledge allegiance to the flag of the United States
of America and to the Republic for which it stands,
one nation under God, indivisible,
with liberty and justice for all.
Now, um, turn some time over to Ben for some information items,
upcoming events. Very good. Thank you, Mayor.
Um, we have a Touch-a-Trunk, um,
Thursday, October 8th, from 4:00 to 5:30 at Eagle Mountain Public Works
building. Um, last— the last farmers market
is this Saturday, October 10th, from 9 to 11. So we're—
again, thanks, uh, Jen Corrington for all her work this,
this past year, and encourage our community to come out and support our vendors
on this last, last day of the farmers market. Um,
Stocktoberfest hands-on community CPR and
AED training is Wednesday, October 14th. from 7 to 9 PM at City Hall.
Space is limited, so please register. Um,
Halloween Town will be Saturday, October 17th, from 11
AM to 2 PM at Cory Ride Memorial Park. Um,
Bag the Leaf program return— returns Tuesday,
October 20th, and will run through December 18th, with dumpsters available
at the 2 locations, Silver Lake Amphitheater and Pony Express Rodeo Grounds.
And the Eagle Mount Public Library has won the 2026 Quality
Library Award from the Utah State Library Division, an honor given
to libraries whose work exceeds the state standards for public library
service. So we want to give them a round of applause.
All right, perfect. Thank you. Um, next We will
start with our public comment period.
As a reminder, public comment is an opportunity for community members to address the City
Council, and each speaker is allowed up to 3 minutes.
If you wish to speak during the public comment period, please complete
a comment form located in the back of the room and return it to our
city recorder up here. Council members will listen but not engage in a discussion during
public comment. We ask that everyone remain respectful Disruptive
behavior, including cheering, booing, clapping, or comments directed at
individual city employees, is prohibited. If you have issues or questions
regarding staff or personnel, administrative staff will meet you in the foyer
for further discussion. Lastly, public comment
period is for items not associated with scheduled public hearings.
If your comment relates to a public hearing item, please wait until that
item is called. The public hearing items are 14A,
which is the ordinance of Eagle Mountain City rezoning certain lands
as Corrigan Farms. Just as a note,
14B is the development agreement
on Corrigan Farms. That is not a public hearing. If you wish to address item
14B, speak now, and 14A
will be during the public hearing. 15A is also a public hearing.
That is the culinary water impact fee facility. Facility Plan.
15B is the wastewater fee and facilities
plan impact fee. And then 15C,
which is an amendment to our code, Section 9.10 and 17.47,
regarding archery use within the city.
15D is an ordinance amending the Eagle
Mountain Code 1760-120, the fencing and screening
provisions. And then 15E is the,
uh, Eagle Mountain City, Utah, amending the Municipal Code 172540
residential standards table. And then 15F is
amending the Eagle Mountain Municipal Code 17140 master site
plans. So those items, we'll call those as public hearings when
we get to them. Any other items that you'd like to address,
now is the time. It is 7:09, and I'll open the public Public comment
period. The recorder's office received a public
comment form last month from Maddie Peterson. We did reach out but wasn't
sure if she was going to be here this evening. Maddie Peterson,
we'll get that in the record.
Ashton Steed filled
out a form. Ashton Steed, am I saying
that correctly? No. Brett Jones.
Hello, Council and Mayor. So my name is Brett Jones. Um,
so we have the widening project coming to the south end
of Pony Express coming soon, right? Um,
I'm just wondering what we could do to consider possibly a street lamp at the
corner of Pony Express and Shadow Drive.
Um, it's the first road you come to on the East side if you're heading
south, just right next to the fire station 252
for reference. So I know this route is used a lot by
kids, especially a lot of the more housing and stuff getting built further south
down there to get to you know elementary schools and stuff.
I know with winter coming, days are getting shorter with daylight,
and I know it's because I live down Shadow. It's pretty difficult with all the
data center traffic coming. in the evenings, um, to try to get into that intersection.
You know, you sit in the left turning lane and then you wait and you
wait and you wait, and then you have to double and triple check, make sure
there's no one in the crosswalk. Um, and the evenings with it starting to get
dark, I just, um, I actually submitted this, uh, issue last year,
um, to— in the Eagle Mountain,
um, app as something to, to possibly consider. So just
wondering if that's something that could be, um, worked into the widening project.
So if they're going to have to dig up stuff, you probably have access to
power if they can put a street lamp in there, or even sooner. So that's
all I got. Thanks. Hey, so I didn't hear what the ask was right at
the first. You talk about a street lamp,
just, just some more light to be able to see people in the crosswalk.
Sorry. Sorry. Yeah. So you're looking for a street lamp?
We heard it on this side. Okay. Thanks.
Jeff Lister.
And that's all I have.
Okay, that was everybody that's filled out a form. Is— okay,
you filled one out? Oh, you emailed
it in. So my next question is, is there anybody here that did not get
a chance to speak that would like to? Okay, come— you can come up now.
If— go ahead and come up now and make your comment and then turn your
form in after. State your name for the record, if you would.
Yeah, um, I'm Maverick Bochicchio, and I'm gonna do
my best to, uh, breathe through this. I struggle. So I'm
just here, um, I saw the air
quality permit for— I think it was like 2.3 million And
I think it's tons of like CO2 for what
you guys are planning to— and I want to know if this is like misinformation,
if, you know, because from my understanding right now, there's a 500-megawatt—
Is this on the— so I've seen the air quality
permit. It's 289 megawatts,
but— Okay. We don't normally engage during public comment. Can we wait till it's done?
So he can have his 3 minutes. I was asking because I thought it was
on the Corrigan Farms agreement. That's why I'm asking. Okay,
I'm just asking. I've seen really high numbers, you know,
like millions of tons of CO2 and formaldehyde
and, you know, these air quality permits that are going through.
And I moved out here to get away from the traffic congestion
and the smog, and prices were cheap and You
know, I felt like I was doing my family a favor by being in an
area that was filled with homes.
And I really took offense when the
mayor said they were going to build homes in this community because
I worked concrete and I loved building homes and
I love building communities, fields. I did Daybreak.
I did the model homes. And I did, you know, perfect job every
time. And I was so proud of
the community that we built. And then just to think that, well, we were
going to put homes here until I said, let's put all the data centers here.
Let's have all these rich people feel like they can pollute our
backyard so that they can get richer because it's just land.
And these gas power plants need water. And we—
I used to— the ground used to freeze when I'd
work construction so that it would be hard so I wouldn't get my feet all
muddy. It doesn't freeze in the valley anymore, so your feet
are always muddy. And we grew up with valley snow.
It wasn't mountain snow, valley rain.
It was valley snow. And it would pile up and it would be black
and nasty from all the tire marks. And we all remember that.
It was— I remember thinking I would freeze to death on Halloween.
30 seconds remaining.
And it's just so much warmer. I've heard 4 to 7 degree temperature
increase from, you know, if everything is approved and we
get those gas power plants running and they use all the water.
And I'm like, I remember you guys being so like,
it's all renewables. You know, we can be conscious, like we're
doing smart development, we're thinking of you guys, we don't want you to get cancer,
we don't want you to be sick, because it's just making these people
who are already rich and unhappy richer. Your time is up. I love all
of you.
My name is Amy Lawson, and I'm actually a resident of Tooele County, and I'm
here with Tooele Cares, and we're part of a coalition that is just asking
for a moratorium on any new data center across the
state. So I'm here for 14B right now, asking that you say
no for any new zoning that allows for a data center out here in Eagle
Mountain. Thank you.
That's all I have.
Okay. Would you like to speak?
State your name. And he emailed a form in, double-check. If not, we'll get
one filled out after. Yep. Uh, Jay Johnson.
Janelle Smith. Uh, we're residents on Lake Mountain.
I'm here tonight because Lake Mountain Road has transformed into a high-speed
commuter shortcut. Every single weekday between
5:00 AM and 7:00 AM, 4:00 PM and 6:00
PM, the street sees thousands of drivers cutting through
at high speeds directly past front yards and family homes.
This volume and speed creates a severe safety hazard
on a narrow residential road. that was never designed to handle
shift change commuter traffic. Most critically, it has made
the crossing of the street extremely dangerous. I'm asking the
city to take action through 3 steps.
Protect the children, the people that cross it, the animals.
Install a high visibility crosswalk at the 3 intersections.
Thank you. with flashing beacons if possible,
and then temporary speed cushions to force commuters
to slow down. Implement traffic
calming signage, temporary radar so
the speeders know how fast they're going, and possibly stop signs
at the multiple intersections. The other
is to target peak hour enforcement, which has
been happening, station traffic enforcement on Lake
Mountain Road during critical shift change windows. I've seen everything
from 40 to 80 miles an hour. The road was graded
today, which is great, but it increases traffic and
speed by exponential amount. So thank you.
Okay, is there anyone else here that did not get an opportunity to speak?
Okay. Please state your name and
fill out a form, give it to Lacey.
Hi, my name is Casey Jensen. I'm here
today to discuss my concern as a pedestrian of my safety.
And I live not too far from
Eagle Mountain Drive and Pony Express.
Geez, I've gone out during peak hours and I have
almost been hit by a car several times. I— all
I'm asking is to invest in just pedestrian
safety equipment, as multiple other residents here
have discussed. I think a streetlight
near Shadow Drive would be an excellent idea too. Also,
there's a discussion about another resident moving
here due to lower
volume of traffic. And I wholeheartedly believe
that investing in public transportation will relieve an
immense amount of that traffic.
And I believe
that high volume of traffic also deters new buyers and new
money coming into the city. I believe that's all. Thank you.
Is there anyone else that we missed? Gentleman here.
Okay.
My name is Jacinto Moreno, and I'm here
concerning the— oh, geez— the Corgan
Farms data center.
I'm just concerned with our current data center, the Meta,
and its power consumption being around 133
megawatts. The power consumption and
the heat from that, along with the CO2 emissions,
just kind of are worrying me as a citizen. I think that's a great question.
as well as the expansion of the metadata center, adding more
commuters and jobs for,
uh, people in Eagle Mountain.
I just think the concern should
be brought towards that. Um,
but that should do it.
Thanks.
Anyone else that I've missed? Okay,
seeing no one, we will close the public comment
period at 7:21 and bring it back to the council.
Time's been set aside for the council to make comments, and we'll
start with Councilmember Clark.
Thank you, Mayor. Um, it's good to see so many faces here,
uh, some new faces and some old friendly faces. And I see a
former council member sitting out there in the front row, and It's good to see
you. I am so—
I've
been thinking a lot about the concerns that people have about
the things that we're doing as a city. And I think it's really important
for you guys to feel like you can reach out and talk to us because
our packet this week for our city council meeting was 749
pages. which means that we get it on Thursday night,
and we need to prepare and read it, and try
to figure out what the residents of our community want us to do with the
decisions that are being proposed in that 749 pages.
Our community is growing,
and there's lots of things that are happening, and it makes it really difficult sometimes
to be able to reach out to all 80,000 residents. But that doesn't
mean that we're going to stop trying. We continuously work with our comms
team and our staff here at the city. We try to
make ourselves available on social media and via phone calls and
different things like that so that you guys have access to us.
And earlier this year, we were doing neighborhood
listening sessions where we'd come to different neighborhoods and
invite you to just come and share your concerns and your ideas and your hopes
and dreams. So I think the thing that I want to stress
more than anything is we work for
you, and we get that. We know that it's a sacrifice for us to do
that, and it's not meant to be something that we do forever.
We spend time away from our families doing this, but we do it because
we believe in the system where people elect people
that share their values and go and vote on their behalf.
So I just want to kind of reshape and reframe that.
I also want to thank our staff for all that they do. We're losing
a staff member next week, and, um,
he's a really incredible staff member, just like a lot of our staff
members. So I don't want to, like, outshine too much, but because he's leaving,
I just want to say, David, thank you. Thank you for the tenacity
And the excitement
that you brought to a really boring topic of engineering.
And we're really grateful for the things that we were able to accomplish as a
city with your help. So thank you for all that you do, and we wish
you the best in your next chapter of life.
Thanks, Mayor. Welcome, everyone. It's good to see you. It's always nice to see
some of— so many smiling faces and Eagle Mountain residents. and those who are outside
of our community. Ben, it's good to see you again. Thanks and welcome
for— welcome back to the chamber. That side's a little more comfortable
than this side, I think. I'll just
say it that way. I too just want to— I just want to express my
gratitude to David Salazar, recognize the contributions he's made to our city,
in particular as we have been working through transportation engineering plans with him.
And all of our staff members work as hard as he does.
The turkey thinks he needs to live in a warmer climate because that's what his
wife grew up in. And so I wish him and his family the
very best in their new adventures. And the mayor
gave me permission to share this, so I'm going to share it. We've— and I'm
excited about this. I don't know if the council members all know
this. I know some of them just heard me speaking about this earlier,
but we We've secured a gentleman who's agreed
to come work for the City of Eagle Mountain to do the job that Todd
Black was doing. His name is Justin Dodd,
and I'm really looking forward to him coming and serving our community. He's due to
arrive middle of November. He's a Wyoming Fish and
Game biologist and right now a conservation officer,
and he has some military background. And so I just think he's going to
be a really beautiful fit. And I was privileged to sit in
some of the interview processes. I was invited to do that by the mayor and
some of our staff members. And Brandon's shaking his head.
He sat in those meetings, he and Brad and Steve and myself
and others. And it was— he's
the right man for the job. And I couldn't be more excited for the gentleman
who's going to get to come try and fill some very, very big shoes in
Todd Black's. Thank you. Todd Black's former position. So I'm grateful
for that. Welcome, and I look forward to the dialogue that we'll
have this evening.
Welcome. It's happy for me to see as many of you as are here.
We love it when you reach out to us, and we can— we need your
eyes and ears to notify us of things that we might not be aware of.
Like, Jay, thanks for talking about Lake Mountain Road. That's— I know
we just We just concluded a speed study where numerous streets were
studied, and I don't think Lake Mountain Road was one of those. So, but that
would be one that we'd want to get, I think, on a future study for
sure. And I'm excited to have the review later
of the speed study results, and it's something the council is taking super seriously and
dedicating money towards solving these issues.
So thank you for bringing that to our attention. Thank you. I just
wanted to let people know about a teen trunk-or-treat that is being put on by
the Eagle Mountain Youth City Council. It's going to have horseback riding and
dancing. There will be a costume contest, a pumpkin carving
contest. It's free.
You would need to bring your own pre-carved pumpkin.
It's the 22nd of October from 6:30 PM to
8:30 PM at 2440 41 East Cedar Drive. And so it should
be a lot of fun. There's a lot of energy right now with the Youth
City Council, and they're doing a lot of great things, and this should be one
of those. So let your teens know about that, have them come, and it should
be a great, great time.
Thanks for being here. It's good to see so many people here.
I think— I don't know what you're all here for, but I'm
glad you're here. I hope that you have some input that you can share with
us when the opportunity comes.
I appreciate the people who have reached out to me one-on-one. I want
to make sure that I say that because I think we have
a real desire to tell the truth about everything.
It's really hard to do that on Facebook. I think that's
an avenue that's become pretty disappointing in dialogue.
I appreciate the people who have reached out, who I've had telephone calls with,
that have reached out to me through direct messaging, that have reached
out to me through texts. There isn't
anything to hide. I love being able to talk to you and be able to
tell you the reasons why I've come to the conclusions
that I've come to as a council member, why I voted the way that
I voted. And most of you who know me know that there really isn't anything
to hide with me. It's what you see is what you get with me.
Um, I appreciate you being here because I think we make way
better decisions when the people who live in the areas are telling
us what we can't see. It's a big city.
I mean, it's 54 square miles. We, we can't see everything,
and we don't know impacts of everything. Uh,
sometimes we are a little bit 2D, and we need you to kind of
bring the 3D world into our
city hall here and let us know what are the impacts, what are we missing,
how can we do better. So when you come and you share those things,
I take notes every single time so that there's some things we can talk about,
get some follow-up on those. Thank you for bringing that in
about the lamp. I think that safety is a big deal to me.
I care about the people who live here. That's why I'm doing this, and I'll
be very happy to be done with it at some point. Thank you. But I
want to make sure that when I'm done, that I left a mark with—
we did things to make it better for the people living here. We made it
safer for the people living here, and we made it possible for people to live
here and not hate the existence of being here
because of traffic or because of industries that are
not compatible with the lifestyle that we've all carved out here. So thanks for being
here. Thank you.
And I would just echo, Dave Salazar has been an awesome streets
engineer. I don't know any different. He's going to be very difficult to
replace. He's very adept and in tune with the traffic
within our city and the flow. And we're just working
hard to improve traffic because we all are dealing with that.
I wanted to— I also appreciate those who have reached out to me individually.
There's kind of this hierarchy of— I don't
know what you would call it— success. of getting something actually done,
like a streetlight is a great example. At the
very base level, you have like a Facebook complaint. You know, this road
sucks. Fix it, City Council. It's like,
I don't— okay. Then there
is like an email that's well-worded.
Then there's coming here, taking time out of your night to
make a public comment where I can actually see a face and somebody who's being
impacted. Thank you. And then there's maybe taking a city council member out
to where you're talking about and showing us and seeing those, those, those types of
activities. I know they require energy and effort, but it
makes such a big difference. On the Williams
Energy, the gentleman that, that brought that up, that's, uh,
I've been out there. I've been to the site. I've walked through where the 17
turbines are going to be going. It's a 289-megawatt
project that is intended to power 3 data centers.
Meta has kind of hit capacity with their
green energy initiative with Rocky Mountain Power. Rocky Mountain Power has basically
said we don't have any more solar credits or power to
sell you, and so Meta will be powering those 3 data centers
through nat gas. But I do have concerns about air quality.
I think we need to be careful about the message that we're sending to the
market of what kind of power will be okay within our city.
We've recently passed an alternative energy overlay zone that
will allow for geothermal, natural gas, nuclear.
I don't know that we only want to settle on natural gas as the
only option.
I struggle with that and trying to find the balance.
Cities cost money. The more homes that we add,
to the city, the more cars we add, the more streets engineers that we need,
and that increases taxes. How do we balance out commercial?
We're not on I-15. We're not on
the way to anywhere. And data centers happen
to be interested in coming here. There will be roughly
$3 million that will be generated from the Williams plant,
and that has a direct offset to costs in the city to
build roads. Thank you. So the thing that I'm always struggling
to balance is the quality of life in Eagle Mountain and at
the same time not having to go back and ask residents
for increased property taxes. How do you balance that in a city?
It's just, it's a struggle. It's something that we're working
through. But I appreciate those that came and made made
a comment. And Jay, I would love to, to come and sit out on Lake
Mountain Boulevard. I think those are great ideas, and you came with some
suggestions, so that, that's a positive. Appreciate everyone coming
tonight. Thank you.
Perfect. I had earlier— I'm going
to start at the top of this— I talked to Officer Gilstrap earlier
today, and I thought he was going to come, but I haven't seen him yet
because I think he was dropping his daughter off, but he sent me some numbers
and I'll bet he shows up in a minute. But I had asked
him about Lake Mountain Road specifically, and I don't
see Officer Knutson here either, but I asked him to go over there and do
some, uh, some enforcement.
Had 46 traffic stops in— Where?
Oh, there he is. I was just talking about some statistics that Officer
Gilstrap had given me, and now I'm going to ask him to come up here
and tell me what it's been like out there on the road.
So, um,
great timing. Did you have fun? As fun
as I'll ever have. So specifically on Lake Mountain Road,
I've asked you a couple weeks ago to spend some time out
there and I think you spent 3 or 4 shifts with a couple of different
guys. Give us some of the statistics. Yeah, we've done multiple shifts
on Lake Mountain Road since we were apprised of the issue 2 weeks ago.
In the 2-week time period, our CAD system shows that we've made 46
traffic stops on Lake Mountain Road. Most of those have been citable offenses
well over the posted speed limit. We've recognized that there's a lot
of traffic that overflows off of Pony Express onto Lake Mountain,
and we've been trying to address it appropriately as needs arise, which has
been needed just about every morning between 4 and 6 AM.
And the evenings as well, right? Oh yeah, oh yeah,
traffic's real fun in Eagle Mountain mornings and evenings. Keeps us
busy. So, and then the other thing that we had talked about a couple weeks
ago, and I don't remember which one of you had— we're going to move the,
uh, the sign over there? The speed trailer?
Yeah. Yes, we're going to be moving that off of Ira Hodges over onto Lake
Mountain Road. Do you know when? We've been hitting it pretty hard still, and we've
been having a lot of good enforcement there, so we were planning on hitting that
for probably about another week before we put the lighted sign out there. There's plenty
of signage on Lake Mountain Road. There shouldn't be any excuse for the speeds.
Okay. Yeah, just keep doing that for a minute, and then probably a week or
two we'll see the speed trailer over there. And then also
for the council, anybody up here, staff, as you're working with the—
maybe I'd ask you to work with Meta specifically, is that
they've designated routes and that's not a designated route. The problem
is, is the subs. Every day it's a different sub and they don't necessarily know.
But if we could get them to help us with their subs to use the
designated routes, that is not the best route to use in
a rural area. And the traffic Do you know the, like, car count? If you
stop 46 cars, it's— Well, the car count, as soon as we
clear a traffic stop, we're ready for the next one. So the— it's, it's pretty
consistent with the speeds. Uh, we've noticed that different vehicle makers
on their mapping system like to try to designate Lake Mountain Road as a 55-mile-an-hour
zone, so that way we've had a lot of speeds up in that range.
That's been swiftly corrected, and we've also provided some
updates to safety staff down at QTS
about their employees driving that speed. Perfect.
Well, thank you for the update. You're welcome. Appreciate you coming down.
So that was— I talked to him earlier and I thought it was
just going to be easier for him to tell us what he's been experiencing.
But we'll continue to help do what we can on Lake Mountain
Road and try if we can't correct the traffic
patterns. Also, I get to sit
on our MAG board and work on transportation and funding, and it's
an uphill battle and it's a heavy lift. And I'm telling you, we have
had some huge victories at MAG in Eagle Mountain in the last few
months, and I couldn't have done it myself. As much
as I get to go down there and take credit and kind of do the
final voting, that guy over there has set us up for some
huge success. And I just hope we can get somebody in here that
can continue to helped me be successful,
and I, and I couldn't do it without you. So thanks, David, for what you've
done, and we get to hear from you in a little while. We'll be— it'll
be late night, but I can't wait to hear the rest of your report and
wish you well in your new endeavors and just tell you that, you know,
you can always come back. The road goes both ways. Uh,
also our guys from UFA, and you guys
made it over here but you didn't hear Chief Perchette, just left. And, you know,
it's always fun working with those guys and kind of seeing what the actual numbers
are. And that just our partnership
with UFA in general has been over the last 15
years has been amazing. And we've had great, great medical care and
fire safety, and, and these guys are always here to help us. So,
you know, it's— I just want to make sure that everybody knows that I love
and respect UFA. And they're a great partner in our city,
and we appreciate them always being with us.
Also, as mentioned before, it's our last farmers market. I got to spend a lot
of time there this year. I've tried to be there as much as I can
and answer questions and bump into people. It's been a really good time.
So make sure you make it to the farmers market and our library
that was mentioned earlier in the meeting. They, they continue to get awards in
this little teeny tiny thing over here compared to some of the others. They're killing
it, knocking it out of the park. So good job to our library and everything
that they bring and do for us. And so I just wanted to add some
congratulations there and ditto to everything else that's been said. So appreciate
you guys all being here and we got a lot of work to do.
So let's get started. First of all, the consent agenda,
10A and 10B and then 12D,
I think. So, Mayor, I'll make the motion. Mayor, I move that the
City Council approve the consent agenda removing item 10A and 10B and
12D and placing them on the regularly scheduled
agenda. Second. Okay, we got a motion
by Council Member Wright and a second by Council Member Wood, and we'll start the
vote with Council Member Wright. Yes. Council Member Whiting. Yes. Council Member
Wood. Yes. Council Member Hughes. Yes. Council Member Clark. Yes.
Okay, that passes, and we can go right to item 10A.
Mayor, let me just make a declaration that I have a potential I have no
conflict of interest with anything related to Firefly. I am the owner of a residential
property in Firefly that I rent, and I will recuse myself
from voting on item 10A and 10B. Okay. I have a question.
Can we make a motion on both of them, or they got to be done
individually? Typically we vote
on agenda items individually. Okay.
Okay, so is there any questions on 10A, is Firefly MPA
8 Phase A going into warranty. If there's not any
discussion, the purpose of removing that is just so Brett could recuse himself,
and I'll entertain a motion. Mayor, I move that the City Council
approve the fire plat MPA 8 Phase A Plat 9 into
warranty as a bond release. Second. We have a motion
by Council Member Wood and a second by Council Member Clark, and we'll start the
vote with Council Member Whiting. Yes. Council Member Wood. Yes.
Council Member Hughes. Yes. Council Member Clark. Yes.
Okay, that passes 4-0.
Yep, 10B, uh, Firefly MPA 8 Phase B
Plat 1 into warranty. Mayor, will you accept a motion? Yes, sir.
I move that the city council issue a bond release for Firefly
MPA 8 Phase— It says into warranty. I don't know what it— Well, it's a
bond release. It'll, it'll say into warranty at the end of this. Okay.
Uh, I'll start over. Issue the bond release for Firefly
MPA 8 Phase B Plat 1 into warranty.
Second. Okay, got a motion from Council Member Wood and a second
from Council Member Clark, and we'll start the vote with Council Member Wood. Yeah.
Uh, Council Member Hirsch? Yes. Council Member Clark?
Yes. Council Member Whitey? Yes. Okay, now 12D.
It is the resolution of Eagle Mountain city approving the
community garden policy. I do know the community board is here,
both the garden and the board
members. If there's any questions, we can call them up for discussion
on the— go ahead. No, Mayor, I mean, I'm the one who asked
that this be pulled, and it's just because I think I'm going to have a
contrary vote probably to, uh, to, to the rest of the council. I'm making an
assumption about that. Maybe I'm wrong. And I just, I would
like to just at least explain my concerns with approving
this. And the concerns that I really have are
not that there's a community garden or community garden space. I'm concerned about dedicating our
employee resources to managing this, to managing the finances that come in,
to tracking all of that, to tracking the expenses, to making
sure that there's water at these spaces, even though there's a charge that's
been proposed to be charged to a number of residents. I'm also
concerned about the limited number of residents that will benefit from this.
And for me, it's just a principled— it's a principled discussion.
And for me, it just doesn't— this shouldn't be something
that the government should be involved in from my perspective. And I
recognize that there are those who are going to feel differently than I do about
this. Thank you.
If you don't have any questions, uh, any— no other discussion
or questions? I, I would, uh,
I appreciate Councilmember Wright's comments. Having sat
in the Community Services Board, we do have a subcommittee
committee for the gardens that will manage that.
Jen Corrington— or it's not— is it Corrington? Okay, sorry,
I've got Corrington in my brain tonight because of another agenda
item. Uh, she runs the farmers market, and I think it's a
great opportunity for residents who want to learn how to garden,
may not have the yard space. As we know,
there's— there is some density within Eagle Mountain. I think just
provides an opportunity for people to pay a nominal fee to come
learn a skill that maybe they otherwise wouldn't be able to. And I do
think we have a board that's very committed to see this project,
including Mr., Mr. Jay Johnson,
in developing, overseeing, and seeing that it will be a successful
endeavor. So I'm, I'm going to make a motion
that the City Council Well, do we want to have any more discussion?
Okay, before I make a motion, as long as you
want to— okay, okay, I'll go
ahead, Mayor, and make a motion that the City Council approve a
resolution of Eagle Mountain City, Utah, approving a community garden policy.
Second. Okay, we have a
motion by Councilmember Hughes and a second by Councilmember Clark.
And we will start the vote with Councilmember Wood.
Yes. Councilmember Herish. Yes.
Councilmember Clark. Yes. Councilmember Wright. No.
Councilmember Whiting. Yes. Okay, that passes 4-1.
And thank you very much. I sometimes let
you speak, but you already did, so we're good. Uh,
let's move on to 13.
13A, a resolution of Eagle Mountain City authorizing
land disposal application for—
who had— oh, this is— no.
13A, right? Yeah.
There you go, right at the bottom. Resolution of Eagle Mountain
City authorizing land disposal application to proceed and directing
staff to begin Again, notice the public hearing process for significant
real property in Eagle Mountain Code 3.30.060.
So this is Lacey. That's what I was looking for.
Good evening, Council. I have the map up here for your review. I do have
application in the packet that goes through the application, everything that the applicant
has as far as the property in question for disposal.
I also have Zach. Staff has reviewed this.
Zach has some updates on the— there's a sprinkler box
right there on the corner of the property. Like I said,
Eric is here to answer any questions that you may have.
And to clarify, this is under the new land disposal code, so you're not
approving the disposal, you're just approving that we can move forward with the disposal,
and we will do a public hearing in the future after we meet
all the requirements on that. Did I miss anything?
Good. Okay.
So I just want to point out how green that grass is right
up to the property line. When I was reviewing this application, I thought that's
exactly sometimes what you expect from government versus private
ownership. It looks awesome. So kudos
to you. And you saw that across all 3 yards. Where I struggle a little
bit, um, I don't love how this was all
laid out, however the development agreement was, was put together.
Um, I understand why developers have that little strip to
get to their, uh, needed parks requirement for the development.
Um, I, I think I would support this if it
were all 3, uh, of those properties together up to the
the sidewalk line. I think I could probably get there
if those 3 property owners would just take out that entire strip versus
having one, uh, because then the city has to kind of
maintain these other, uh, 2 areas. And I just
think it would be a lot cleaner if we could put together those other 3
property owners in this application. So I, I want to
just make a, make a suggestion for us to think about. I, I'm, I'm,
I'm opposed to liquidating this property. And let me tell you why.
As I've looked at this, I think there's an opportunity to provide
some parking for this park that doesn't exist on both ends,
both the south and the north section in the picture on the left.
I think that can be converted to parking, and there's an easy trailhead access
into the park from that area. So has it
been done yet? No. Has it been cared for in the way that we'd hope?
Probably not. But we have a lot of open space in the city that's
in this condition, and, and I think this is an area where we could actually
turn it into something that's beneficial for the entire community rather
than selling it off to 2 or 3 property owners. So for me, this one's—
I'm going to be a hard pass on this one. And something
that I've, you know, as I've been looking at this particular street, when you look
on the opposite side of where the proposed property
is, that there are trees on that other side. So there's almost
like this corridor entrance into this part of the neighborhood. And if these,
you know, if that, if we sell this property, it becomes asymmetrical with the other
side. I think it's, I could see those trees, you know, a handful of years
from now, I could see the trees on both sides, you know, growing and maturing
and being a beautiful entrance for numerous people to enjoy.
This particular subdivision, there's some really small lots. in some of the
areas there, and at least the people can enjoy their drive as they
go through the community with the open spaces there. So I likewise
hesitate to sell. I would be open to parking if
that becomes a beneficial use to the neighborhood,
but I hesitate to move forward with the
sale. I agree
with a lot of the stuff that's been said, but I also want to point
out that If this land was something that was a responsibility
of that developer to put in trees or grass
or whatever, they sure didn't do a very great job in that location.
So I think that it might be
useful for us as decision makers and the body
responsible for things like this to look at ways that we can
hold developers accountable for their requirements
that they're supposed to. to do. I know that we have warranty bond releases
and all of those things, but, um, I'd like to
make sure that we avoid situations like this so that residents
don't feel it's on them to take over park
space to make it look nice because it wasn't
installed to the best of its ability. So, um,
that's just something I, I'm calling on the body to make sure we
Anything
else?
I don't know how I feel about this one. On the
one hand, I sympathize with
the homeowners that are there having a piece of land that nobody's taking care of
because it looks bad.
To maybe a counterpoint, Brett, to the parking is basically
you're going to be bringing cars right up to the back end of that house,
uh, at different times of the day, morning and night. That would
put headlights in pretty close proximity to their back door and back
windows. Uh, that would be concerning for me. I, I think
you're not wrong on the assertion about the parking problems
there. But I think if that's really a concern that we have, there is opportunity
at that northeast corner of
the property. You might have to adjust the trail there, but you could do parking
inside the park there because it's not really usable space on that
east side other than the trail. So I think
there's some other solutions if parking is really what we're talking about.
To me, I view this in one of two things: either we need to
give them the opportunity to be able to improve this piece of property that makes
their property devalue in its appearance, or we
need to take care of it. One of those two things.
Well, I'm looking at an older photo on Google.
Earth, if I'm looking at the right spot, which I think I am, the grass
looks better in this photo. Still pretty patchy.
Yeah, I mean, it's, it's not, not perfect, but it looks— Are those trees
on our property? The trees are on the city's property.
And, and that's part of why I hesitate to remove this, because of the beneficial—
how those trees benefit the neighborhood, the look, the feel.
And if you look on the south side, there are
trees on the south side as well that sort of have
created little corridors people drive through there that everybody
benefits from. And that's what the benefit— the purpose of open space is to
benefit the public. And so I mean,
I know where I stand on this. And I mean, again, I actually would prefer
parking to be found elsewhere. I prefer that as opposed to this.
But I still— I'm against the disposition of this. Thank you.
I'm going to ask you a question, Zach, before you say something.
Would it be better for us to maybe do some decorative xeriscaping
there so we're not trying to mow right next to somebody
else's property, trying to figure out what part belongs to us and what part belongs
to them? I can send you guys a photo. That is not what it looks
like today. That, that is not a current
photo. It's, it's green. So I
just sent that photo to you.
Thanks.
Can I just add some additional context? I mean, this year was a rough year
for us. We all know that we had a lot of water issues and whatnot.
And so as I'm looking back through these aerials and whatnot, there's a
lot of them that reflect the condition of this year. And so that's
Where I would— yeah, I'm glad that we had the photo that was brought up
there and we can really look at it to see what it looks like.
Mayor, I'd like to make a motion.
I move the City Council deny 13A, a resolution of Eagle
Mountain City, Utah, authorizing the land disposal application for Utah County Parcel
668282978.
I'll second that. All right, we have a motion by Council Member
Whiting, seconded by Council Member Wood, and we'll start with Council Member Hewish.
Yes. Council Member Clark. Yes. Council Member Wright. Yes.
Council Member Whiting. Yes. And Council Member Wood. Yes. Okay,
we'll move on to item 13B, a resolution
of Eagle Mountain City authorizing the land disposal to
proceed and directing staff to begin the notice of public hearing process on
parcel 464910332
and 2 other parcels designated as significant real property pursuant
to Code 3.30060. Lacey?
Yes, so as mentioned in your packet, this one came to you before you in
April of 2021, and at that— or April 21st,
2026 of this year. And at that time it was denied 3
to 2 with the recommendation to come back with the neighboring— with
the neighbors. So this is that application in Meadow Ranch along the HOA.
It was previously maintained as an HOA corridor and no longer is getting maintained.
So Chelsea Lindsay has done a new application with the
neighboring— with the residents, the neighbors. And I believe that she
is here to answer any questions. Again, this is just to see if we can
move forward with the land use Okay.
And I, I don't remember. I just wanted to make one maybe
clarification, and they could speak to this.
When they went back after the first one, it was kind of a— they were
sent back with maybe an idea of it would be more open if it was
all, or if everybody participated.
Some neighbors were not able to be here, but they did reach out and say
they would like to participate. that they are adjacent to this property and they did
not want to see the disposal go through. Um,
just— I don't even remember which ones it was, but I just wanted to
make that clarification. I think they might have sent in an email.
I haven't received anything. I did receive documentation from the applicant
of the signatures who would like to move forward with it, but I have not
heard from anybody who has not. So there are some that did not,
correct? There are some that— let me look.
Looks like there are a couple that are moving, but I'm unsure. Is Chelsea
here? Yeah, she's here. Yeah. Can you come help clarify? Yeah, just the ones that
we didn't get. I know that you and I spoke a couple times about it.
Thank you. So in green
is a yes if they were interested. They need more information such
as, you know, what would the price be, what does it mean for me?
Um, so our first round, only one person had said no.
Uh, another neighbor— I don't know if I can say names, I don't know if
it matters— but another neighbor, uh, expressed some information
this week that he said he would not be interested in purchasing. Um, technically you
only need one neighbor on each side of it to purchase, and we have a
yes for all of that, so we can dispose of all of it in its
entirety. Okay. Yeah, that's— I
just want to make that clarification for the council as we discuss this,
and then I'll open it up for either discussion or any other questions for the
applicant. Is it one application or per— Correct,
it's one application with all the residents on one application.
Just a quick question. Remind me, was there a drainage issue
or utility easement access issue with
Brad, was that— do you know?
I don't think there's an existing easement for drainage.
I'm sure that there is some flow that goes down through there.
But in my recollection, I mean, I think
it was probably preserved for some kind of trail network or whatnot is
really what the intent was. The problem with the
trail network that runs through there is it's kind of a trail that goes to
nowhere. Yeah. It ties into the north, but it doesn't tie into the south.
And part of that's just because of the rural atmosphere that that
section of the city was built under with the swales and whatnot.
And so there's not curb and gutter, there's no sidewalks,
there's no trails on one side of the road.
I think the intent was for a trail corridor.
That would be correct. And then Nighthawk Lane does have swales along the
frontage of the property because all the properties drain towards Nighthawk
Lane on that side and then Sunset on the other. They're drained forward and
there are— there is a swale in the front on the Nighthawk Lane.
I have another question for Brad Mayer, if I may. My question is
this, Brad. I started looking around at the trails up in this area as I
reviewed this application, there's quite a few of them in Meadow Ranch.
And what I didn't get a chance to go back and do is compare them
to our trails and open space plan, the master plan that we have.
And so my question is, are any of these types
of areas, or this area specifically, contemplated in our master
trail plan? Do you know? I have reviewed the master plan.
You can speak to it as well. You guys wrote it. and reviewed it.
It's preserved open space is what it was classified as in
the original one before you did it last year. It was not in there at
all. Now it's open space. It's because in our new Parks,
Trails, and Open Space Master Plan, we really tried to break out
and identify the open space areas versus the areas that had
been developed or put
into use. And so with that, the concern
that I have is, yes, we could pave a trail in there and that wouldn't,
that wouldn't be a hard cost, but it's the other connecting
sidewalks and trails and things of that nature to add
that. And this came up years ago when
the school opened because there was students that were walking
right down the roadway And we had discussions about
this trail network being built behind there.
But it's one of those trails, if you build it, are they going to use
it? Because it doesn't really go anywhere. And so to
answer your question, yes, we can build a trail in that corridor.
But if we're going to build a trail in that corridor, it's bigger than just
the trail in that corridor. We're going to have a bigger project that we're going
to have to fund. To get the connectivity through that subdivision.
So I know part of this— I know you say it doesn't really go
anywhere, but it does go somewhere north because there are 46, almost 40—
no, I guess there are 18 acres on the north side of that. As that
continues to go up, and if there were a paved trail in there, I think
people would would use it if we're paved and and
it could be used. So I I know when this came before us the first
time, and I realized this might be a split vote among the council, which I'm
totally fine with. I'm going to hold my my original vote was
I was I was not in favor of it even if it were all combined
together. Now I'm just one of five, just because I feel like that that I
think I feel like a trail should be paved in there, and I think it.
you know, that those trails that connect up to the 18 acres should be
paved, and that becomes something that we— that the city can then use, that the
public can then use. And it provides an additional route for kids going close,
you know, down to Blackridge. And I realize people can walk on Sunset, but— Yes.
It's still another route that goes down to Blackridge Elementary. So that's
where at least I stand. And I realize we were split vote last time,
but my vote hasn't changed because back then I just I was always of the
opinion that I was not of the mind to dispose of the property, even if
it was all being sold at the same time. So at least that's where I
particularly stand on this. Yep, we remember
that because we thought it was silly. Sunset Drive has the asphalt that goes
straight up, so— but that's okay, we can all have our opinion.
Craig, I just wanted to ask, you mentioned
paved, and I'm going back to The original intent was
actually horse trails. And I'm fine with horse trails too,
because I think either way, I'm saying preserving that for whether it's
pedestrians or horses or— So that was what my
question was. I think the greater question that you're saying,
or I would say it differently, is you want it maintained whether it's paved.
There you go. That's a better way to say it. Okay. I just wanted to
make sure if you're asking for asphalt or if you're just asking that it remain
an open trail. If it were maintained and it was very visible that
it's a trail, then I think it would get used— foot traffic, horses.
Gravel. And I know that, yeah, gravel could work.
If— I know there are some lots up there. There's the equestrian overlay zone
that's up on that side as well. And for horse owners,
that's a real— it's much nicer to go on a trail like that than it
is to go on asphalt. Yeah, and I think currently
there's some encroachments on there, which is why this was originally brought
to us. But, and, and, and, and it's, again,
the encroachments are frustrating.
That, that's, that's— They're just gonna have to be mitigated is what it is.
So yeah, the encroachments should not be occurring,
and, uh, it's not legal for them to do that.
Okay, so real quick, I'm just going to ask, are there any other questions
for the applicant specifically. If you don't mind, I'll have you just sit right here
close for a second while we finish this conversation. If there's a specific question,
we'll ask you to address it. So, um,
anything else to— I
think I'm probably in alignment with Council Member Whiting. If this should
either be maintained as a— either a horse trail or pedestrian
trail right now, if I were walking along
that street and I were to see that, I'd probably think this
was private property and would not walk down it. And if you knew it was
a public trail that you could walk on, then you're more likely to walk
along it. And with encroachments, maybe that's why it's
just not being used. So I would say as a city, we probably need to
demarcate if we're going to retain it and actually maintain it,
make it a usable path through that, through that area.
That'd be my preference. So if we Keep it.
Let's use it. All right. Any other
discussion? Or if not, we've got a lot of work
to do. Go ahead. I'm going to change my opinion from the last time.
Okay. I mean, I just think, you know, one of the problems
when you have large lot properties, areas,
it's very difficult to connect pedestrian traffic
to other roads. Yeah, I'm not,
I don't love that people have just decided to make it their land. That,
I mean, it doesn't belong to them. So that
part I'm not super happy about, but I think that we haven't made it clear
that it is a path for whatever the reasons are. And I think that there's
probably some real benefit to having that be
an option away from Sunset, which is a pretty busy road. Thank you.
So I can find myself on the, the Craig Whiting team
on this one. I,
I think one thing that we need to do then to you guys is be
willing to put in the work. We have the plan
for trails and we should be looking at areas
like one neighborhood at a time and kind of collectively the
whole city, um, because Everyone said if
this is a trail, we should be maintaining it. So I think we need to
give direction and make sure we're having staff
know that this is the level of service that we want for certain trail areas.
If we don't have the funds to do it right now, then we need to
just say this is unimproved open space until we decide to
improve it or designate it or signage or something.
But I just think that we need to do the homework. as a body so
that we take it from being strips of weeds to
actual usable park space, if that's
what we're doing. So thanks.
Mayor, I'll make a motion. I, I move the city council
deny 13B, a resolution of Eagle Mountain City, Utah, authorizing the
land disposal of various parcels noted in the,
in the staff report. Second.
All right, we have a motion by Councilmember Whiting, a second by Councilmember
Wood, and we'll start the vote with Councilmember Hewish.
Yes. Councilmember Clark? Yes.
Councilmember Wright? Yes. Councilmember Whiting? Yes. Councilor Wood?
Yes. Okay, that passes, and we'll go
on to the next one. Uh, it's 14A. Mayor, can we ask
our Community Services Board to add that to their list of
trails that we need to take a look at and get it onto some sort
of a plan? Sure, sounds like she's willing. And let's do it. I lost
Jay, but he's— he— I know he likes those horse trails. So,
um, Steve's not here. You want to make sure that
he gets updated? I'm sure the one that's present will
make sure it gets added to an agenda. I have no worries about that at
all. Just so he knows, we got to work on it and direct staff because
we'll have— and also the parks and everybody, it's going to involve some people.
So, all right, 14A is a public hearing. This is our
first public hearing. It's an ordinance, Fiegel Mountain City rezoning
certain lands known as Corrigan Farms.
David is not here,
but— okay.
Hi, I'm his— You're the fill-in? Fill-in tonight.
So David and his wife have both had
a little rough day, so I'm going to fill in for him.
This is a property,
just a little over 40 acres And just a little south
and west of the current QTS site,
just on the very southern— close to the southern border of the city,
as you can see outlined in red.
And it is
very close to the main QTS property,
as I noted. So the request
here is for it to be rezoned to the RTI,
Regional Technology Overlay.
And it is
property that is surrounded
on 3 sides by the RTI overlay already.
Utah County is off to the west.
West. Um, there is, uh,
currently on the property— I'm going to— we don't— I'm
actually going to take you to another photo here, if that's okay.
Um, I'm going to take you to what's on our— this
is a pretty recent, uh, photo, aerial photo.
So the property is being used by,
uh, currently being used, uh, for kind
of ancillary, ancillary purposes, uh,
for data center, for, for QTS.
They— it's being used for, uh, their what they call Trailer City
for craft tents and so forth. Uh, it's also being used for parking,
as you can see, um, on, on the
property there. So, um, these two buildings
here are largely— well,
we issued the temporary occupancy,
temporary certificate of occupancy on these 2 buildings. And so there's
just a lot of construction going on in this area. And so the
request here is, again, just simply to rezone this to the RTI
overlay. Thank you. zone and
to allow it to be utilized for— which would open
it up for uses like electronic
and utility generation, data centers,
general storage facilities, and so forth. So that's
the request. It went to the Planning Commission and they recommended
approval of the proposal. Staff also
believes that's a good use for the property considering its proximity
to the other data centers in the area.
And so I'm just here if you have any questions on that one,
on this one. I didn't even notice
the applicant is here. I was wondering. So if there are any questions, the applicant
is here as well. I think it would be good to hear from the applicant
because there's a lot of clamor about what this land should be
and who's doing it, but I think hearing what
the applicant seeks to do with the land is important. Uh,
yeah, I'm gonna try to speak to you and to the participants,
if that's okay. So I don't want you to feel like I'm turning my back
on you, but just speak. My name is Reagan Peck. Um, me and
my best friend back here, his name is Corey Sosa, he owns the property.
Property with me. We bought it 15 years ago.
And in a discussion like this, there's never like a winning side and a losing
side. It's a tough discussion to have.
And so we enlisted a consulting firm who— he's
here today, Jeremiah. He— we wanted to see what would be best for this
particular property yesterday, today, and in
the future. And so Corey
Sosa and I We hired the consulting
firm and looked at what was going around us, what we believe the city may
do moving forward. You had mentioned the alternative energy
zone further south and a couple other items, and we felt
the best thing for the property right now is to be rezoned into the RTI.
If you notice, we aren't going to build any houses there.
We don't plan on having any residential buildings.
We don't think that it's a good use to have you know, a warehouse of
some sort or a body shop or a gas station. It— in this
area, we feel this was the best usage for the zoning, especially because it's already
there on all 3 sides. And to the west,
going into Fairfield, I even
spoke with a lot of those neighbors on what— and even Mayor Holly McKinney for
Fairfield and what they thought they might be doing. And not to speak
about Fairfield's business, but it's— I'm sorry. a very similar footprint, without saying
too much, as what you're seeing on our side.
And so this map, if you were to expand it, it would look
even more dense for stuff like this rather than just what
we have planned. I know that we— just so all
the people here can meet us, we are also 14B on
the agenda item and are public hearing, and I don't know
how to speak to that as well as to answer questions from you guys.
But I'd love to get your opinions. If you recall, we came here in April
without an agenda item just to talk with the council to say,
what do you guys recommend? What opinions do you have for this particular piece of
land? We would be interested in hearing from you and the city. We wanted to
hear from residents. We wanted to know what would be best because we are residents
I mentioned last time I live here, my family lives here, my full-time job
is a school counselor at the high school right up the road, and we
don't have any plans to go anywhere. So it wasn't supposed to just do this
and get out of town. And I hope anybody here
that was for this item sticks around for a little bit so we can talk
about 14B, because right now
there's not an end user. There's not a buyer. There's not a builder.
We don't— we're trying to put this together that
would be best for us, obviously, myself and my best friend,
and what's best for the city. So I can't sit here and lie and
say, oh, this is about, you know, trying to take the high road. I definitely
want to get the most money out of this property as possible, but I'm trying
to do it the right way by coming to City Council in April.
Prior to, you know, applying for anything, hiring a consulting
firm that has done this a thousand times more than me and my best friend
have done, and coming before you today of saying I would
love to answer any questions you might have, knowing that I may not have all
the answers, but I feel like we've done this the best way possible from a
resident's perspective, not some end user or a multi-billion
dollar company or.
You know, somebody that just is not in the area and gains the profit and
then leave, if that makes sense. Yeah, and we'll address
14B separately. This is just the rezone, right? So I don't
know if there's any other questions on that one. It is a public hearing.
You want me to start with the public hearing? Yeah. Okay, so if you'll take
a seat close by, we'll go ahead and start with the public hearing.
It's— this is the same rules apply that we talked about
earlier with the public comment. This is a public hearing on the rezone
portion, and, uh, it is 8:15,
and I will now open the public hearing. Casey Voles.
Did I say that right? Vokes? Yeah, Vokes.
Sorry, it's a K, not an E. Thank you.
Welcome back. Yeah, thank you. Uh, yeah, Casey Vokes.
Um, I moved out of Eagle Mountain 6 years ago to
Houston, Texas, and then we just moved back. It was a no-brainer
in spite of the traffic. So I just get up and go early. But I
will say I am surprised by how much opposing traffic there has
been. And so that has kind of brought about sort of a, you know,
a quick learning on my part. First of
all, I want to add my voice to the conversation on some of these issues.
I've just kind of sat back, watched on Facebook, took it in from the neighbors,
kind of seen what's been happening, chatted with some of you.
And my thoughts overall, of course,
I think, you know, if a resident wants to change a zone that
they've got and it's their property, like, yes. You know,
one of the things that Houston does right is it's not a big zoning place.
You can build and do with your property what you And
I think that's the right way it should be. Now, that said,
I think that we've kind of got ourselves in a weird situation
with too many, like, kind of agreements and, like, well, maybe if,
ultimately, some, in some cases with these data centers. And I don't
know all the backstory, I just got back.
But I'm definitely concerned. I mean, I've already talked to a law enforcement
officer who's expressed that a lot of the issues that they're running
into is because of the QTS traffic. That is creating a huge need.
Thank you. And there is a huge impact that seems to be happening in our
community. And, you know, $3 million, and we definitely,
when you dig into MAG, and I have, I've read a lot of the
minutes lately, mayor is definitely going to bat in there.
You're getting some wins. You're also getting voted down sometimes. We definitely got to get
in there and make sure we have your back too as residents because
it's a big problem. I mean, it's, it's, it's ridiculous when you see
certain projects getting approved across the county when they really don't need
it, but we have a huge need here. And so when I just look
at it, for me, it's the big picture. I think there's
got to be a laser focus on the basic functions of government— roads,
police, fire, you know, public safety.
Those are the things that I'm going to care about. I know that there's funding
buckets and there's going to be things that you're going fund because the money's
there and you got to spend it somewhere. But that— I do get concerned,
you know. I don't— for me, community garden, I didn't trust
them in Houston for sure. Maybe they're nicer here.
They probably will be. But yeah, that's about it. I just
think we got to go forward, especially with the data centers.
There's such a clamor and a demand. They want places to build,
I don't think we've got to give them crazy agreements. They need to pay for
real the impact of, of what they're doing if they want to build here.
Um, but that's kind of, you know, for sure residents should be able to change
zoning. Thank you.
Amy Lawson.
Your name is up. Thank you. Sorry,
I won't take that much time. I am Amy Lawson again. I'm here
with Tooele Cares on behalf of Utah Versus Tech Billionaires,
and we are asking for you to say no to
the rezoning for 14A and 14B. I was
just going to say that and say we are asking for a statewide
moratorium for any new data centers at all, but when it specifically to the
overlay. And then I feel really bad for this guy as I listen to him
speak. He has had this property for 15
or whatever years and now is feeling forced in what
he has to do with that property because of what has surrounded it that I'm
sure he didn't plan on 15 years ago when he bought that property.
I heard him talk about a shop, I heard him talk about a gas station,
and I'm sure that his family probably had a lot of different
visions for what they would do with this property as they continue to spend their
life here. And it's unfortunate for him that I'm asking now for
you to say no to him and to any other developer that wants to come
into this town or any other town across the state for data
centers. We don't have enough information. You guys are a good example of what we
don't want happening across the rest of the state. So I am
asking you to say no to 14A.
Maverick— I'm not sure if I can begin to say the last name.
It starts with a B.
Boccaccini? No?
Jacinto Manillo?
Moreno. Moreno. Sorry, I'm really bad at names.
I did have some other concerns that— Get close to the
mic, if you would. Terribly sorry. I did have some other concerns with the
data center power, whatnot. It is currently
consuming, I think, 133 megawatts at the
moment, which, for reference, 1 megawatt is
around 1,000 households.
So that is one thing that I am just
concerned about because I do not think our power grid can handle that right now,
especially with how, like, Rocky Mountain is.
Another side note, not dealing with the data centers off
of Pony Express heading Towards
the metadata center, I would like there to be some consideration
for more streetlights just outside there. As a
pedestrian who has to commute at night,
specifically on the bike paths, I have a hard time
seeing what's happening because there is no light from the
Holiday gas station onward. I believe
that should do it, though. Thank you.
That's everything I have.
Is there anyone else here that would like to speak on this item
that did not have the opportunity? Seeing no one, we'll close the
public hearing at 8:22 and bring
it back to the council.
I'll give an opinion on this. So here
you have a situation where the property is literally surrounded on every single
side with a particular right. Every single
one of the applicant's neighbors has a particular right that he does not have.
So if the city says no, because we have the power to say no,
the applicant then could very easily go
to court and say, I'm being discriminated against. All of my neighbors can do this
and I can't. As a council, we would have to have an exceptionally compelling reason
why this would not— to support not
rezoning this. We'd have to have a very compelling reason. Absent that, it has to
be rezoned.
All right, so my concerns are more policy.
Concerns. So in the RTI zone, it requires
that there's a development agreement. I've got a problem with the development
agreement because it's not really with anybody, and our
develop our master development agreements require benchmarks. And I kind of
brought this to your attention, Reagan, when you reached out to me.
We're not looking to give people the option of being able to be land
brokers in Eagle Mountain anymore. We want them to come and build.
It's not a no, it's come and get started.
So I don't know how to reconcile this because you don't have a
current buyer for it. I think you eventually will, but we want
the opportunity to be able to negotiate with the people who are coming where
it's best for the citizens. And if we do that all preemptively, we lost all
of the ability to negotiate anything. So I'm struggling a little
bit with where to land on this. I'm not a big
fan of the RTI overlay zone. I think I'm on record saying that multiple times
because I think it's way too broad. And we keep applying
it to situations that don't really fit it and allow
for broader uses than I'm comfortable with for each one of them. But to
Craig's point, what other option is there as
far as the rezone goes?
So I don't know where I'm at on this. The 2 were tied together,
the 14 or 15B with the development
agreement. I'm not comfortable with the development agreement.
So maybe, Marcus, you can give us a little bit of direction.
It requires it to have a development agreement. So the RTI doesn't require
a development agreement. It requires a development agreement if you want to take advantage
of the administrative approval process.
You know, obviously, and you know, I neglected to send
the draft that had the Corrigan Farms LLC as the other party,
so I apologize for that. But the rest
of the agreement, with one minor change that was added in response to Planning Commission
recommendations, is identical. So the issue
with the benchmarks, I think, is legitimate as far as
that goes, because it's impossible to have benchmarks that tell you how government buyer.
But as far as how you want to proceed,
obviously the rezone is not dependent on the approval of
the development agreement. That could always be tabled or brought back at
some future date when they have a buyer, when they have
the zoning entitlements. My recommendation is
to tie the two together because,
you know, at some future date, I think
we actually lose leverage once we rezone the property. So I
understand that, you know, as far as
benchmarks go, this is a shorter agreement than our typical data center
agreements because it's a smaller property. So it's a 20-year agreement rather
than a 40-year agreement. I want to direct you to our code because
I think that what you said is missing some elements there. So 17.48.020,
the special approval process dictates that the development agreement
is a requirement in order to qualify for the RTI zone. In order to qualify
for the special approval process. It says
that in order to qualify for it,
you have to go through a special approval process. That's literally
what it says. So you can— zoning is zoning, right?
So let's pull up the zone here.
If I'm reading it wrong, tell me I'm reading it wrong, but I'm— I don't
see— Councilmember Wood, are you referencing A in that section
where it says development agreement? I am. Yeah, so A says in order to qualify
for the RTI site plan approval process, so that's what it's referencing, a development agreement
approved by the City Council is required. So that's what I'm saying. In order to
qualify for that special approval process, you need a development agreement. But to rezone a
property, you can just rezone a property. Well,
once you give the RTI, that's the That's the method of the RTI,
is a special approval process. I mean, we're talking about the dominoes falling, right?
Correct. So once you go to the RTI, here's the process to do that.
No, so once you go to the RTI, then you have the rights to those
uses in the RTI, such as a data center, for example.
That would be an approved use in the RTI overlay. They could build the data
center. It would go through the normal approval process for building a data
center unless there was a development in place, in which case they would qualify for
the special approval process. They wouldn't be able to utilize any of their rights
on it without a development agreement because it's over the 50 acres?
It's 40.99. So it is actually under 50 acres.
They would be able to— again, they would have the data centers permitted
use in the RTI. They would go through the normal process for that. So they
would, you know, do plat. Go through the public process,
the site plan approval, all that.
We'd go through the normal processes that we would do for
any other type of development. The administrative approval process associated
with the RTI, which is I think the big carrot for a lot of these
companies, is only applicable
if they meet the requirements, one of which is a development agreement in place.
Last question. On the slides that Brandon showed,
it said that RTI zone gives— let me see
here— electric and utility generation, distribution, and transmission.
Brandon, if you would pull that specific code in RTI
up, I would appreciate that. I wasn't able to see it. That's not in the
RTI, but it is in the development agreement. This is— So
that's something that they're asking for as part of the development agreement. But it's not—
I agree with you, it's not in the RTI as an approved use. I just
want to make sure that that's clear. That's not an allowed use in there as
part of the zoning. Right. It would be— it's in the development agreement. It's not
part of the zoning. Okay. Sir, do you want that excluded as the zoning?
I mean, it doesn't belong in the zone, so yeah, it has to be.
It's going to get addressed in the next item, correct? Okay.
I think— did you have another comment,
Councilmember Wright? Maybe. Well,
I'll just say that there are several portions of the development agreement which we'll get
to next that I have some, some issues with, Councilmember Wood.
And I, I think there's wisdom in— if we're going to seek
an approval on this, or if we're going to consider an approval, then I think
there's wisdom in making sure that the two of them work together
as a unit, an A and a B. And so while I,
I don't— I support what you said, Councilmember Whiting. I, I think
that the request to, to entitle this property with the RTI overlay
zone makes sense to me. I mean,
it just, it fills in the, the green patch down there and,
and allows that RTI to then kind of thrive in that area with like
uses. So that's That's not my concern. My concern is
with the development agreement itself. And so
because of that, my suggestion would be that we consider tabling the
RTI approval until we can work through the details of the development
agreement and get that right. And once we feel like we have that right,
then, then we can consider them again together. But that's kind of my
thought process at this point. Thank you.
I agree with that assumption.
Anybody else have anything? So just to clarify,
if the rezone goes through tonight and the development
agreement doesn't, the development agreement is only important
specifically toward being able to do the special approval process, correct? Marcus?
I mean, I wouldn't quite phrase it that way, but it is, uh, it is
an essential element of getting the special approval process. I think there are other important
aspects to the development agreement, such as clarifying the expectations of
the parties. Yeah, and we do have the
ability to, to have any property having a master development
agreement. That is in our code. And I would say anything that falls in this
area would always have to have a master development agreement, in my opinion.
So, so, Council Member Wright, you're suggesting that, um,
you want an approvable development agreement in place before you
change the zone on this? My, my question is this,
and maybe it's for the applicant, maybe we can ask him a question. Mayor,
my question is simply this: is that going to hold you up from doing anything?
Because, because I have some significant concerns with the development agreement as
it's written. My understanding coming into this and speaking with you guys— this
is great communication because it's teaching me as well. I've, uh, like I said,
Rich knows I've come, texted back and forth to learn as much as I can.
We were under the impression that this was going to be essentially 2 items.
In theory, we were applying for a rezone and
that nothing would take place on that rezone property until
there was some development agreement. The reason that I wanted the development agreement
was I wanted to have a little bit
of say, if not a good amount of say, on who might
utilize the property because I didn't want to just throw
that to the wind and then I get cards taken away from me. Not trying
to be selfish, but I want to be strategic for the city's purposes as well.
And so So in the development agreement, are we okay to talk— we'll
talk about that in a minute, or do we want to just address it now,
or what do you think? Like, I don't— We'll get to it. I think we
need to talk about it now. At the same time. I agree. So I think
part of the reason with the development agreement, and he'll be able to explain more,
there is things in there that honestly, if you were
to look at the development agreement for QTS and the development agreement for Meta,
we took it almost verbatim because I said without knowing
what's going to happen. I'm going to take it from what's already been approved.
Therefore, when it comes, other than a couple things
might have been different, such as length, because I'm not a— I'm not a
400-acre site, I don't need 7 phases.
Does that make sense? Um, yeah, I think I could confidently
say this property will end up being for a data center. Now,
we've had plenty of data center buyers,
I guess you'd call them, end users come and talk to us. Um,
none of them do we have a contract with. Is it listed? Is it anything
like that? The development agreement is going to be catered
towards a data center. It's going to be catered towards power
generation behind the meter, to which we own our own water and
I have my own air permit, or to where I'm not going
to supersede anything that that 41 acres would be a
liability or a burden on the community in any way, shape, or form.
The water gets sold with it. We even paid engineers to look
at what a site might look like that would utilize the water we have so
we're not then coming to the city. And I'm not saying they wouldn't, but for
at least me, I can sleep well knowing everything in that development agreement is not
to hide, scare, pull the wool over your eyes. I may not be
good with the legal jargon. I may not know exactly Hey, you can't say this
or you can't do that. But I can stand here in full confidence saying the—
I was under the assumption I could rezone this property and then market
it to who I think would best benefit me and the property by
saying the city council has already approved the ability to do this.
You need to go file for building permits or whatever it might be
with you guys. I don't think— I'm not— I didn't think that this was a
congratulations, you now have a blank canvas to do whatever you want.
with whomever you want. I was fully under this— the assumption I
can do rezone today, the development agreement you guys either agree with or
don't, but the rezone was done. And then whoever did something
on the property still had steps even with an approved development
agreement. Does that make sense? So, so, so, Mayor, I mean, if I can suggest
a course of action, because we've got a lot on the agenda to get through,
my, my suggestion is this to the council, to consider There's
nothing that precludes us from immediately after taking that action and
going through the development agreement. If we can find some path forward with that,
I'd like to hear what the concerns with the development agreement are from my fellow
council members. I'd like to share mine. I'm going to pause
you for just a minute because, because this is really for us
to kind of decide. I'm thankful for your answer, but we need to talk through
this. So strategically, to me, it makes sense to table
it for the rezone, consider the development agreement,
see if we can hammer that out. There's nothing that precludes us from tabling the
development agreement and pulling the rezone back up.
If we're comfortable with where the development agreement goes, we could give an approval on
the zoning, and then we can take a look at the development
agreement. I think they have to be done in that order. Is that right,
Marcus? Yeah, I mean, we can always reconsider
any item on the agenda. So if you
wanted to even pass the item rather than tabling it—
Yeah, that's what I was going to suggest. You can come back to it after
considering the development agreement. If you determine to table the development agreement, then you bring
it back and table it. So if we pass it, we can reconsider it and
table it? Yeah. And so if, uh, we don't have to take
it. I would suggest just passing it for now and moving on to the next
agenda item and then bringing it back after you've considered developing it. If you say,
all right, with these tweaks we're okay approving the development agreement, you bring back the
rezone, rezone it, and approve the rezone. If you say, nope,
we need changes to the development agreement that are large enough
in scope that we're not comfortable doing it from the dais,
then table it, bring back the other one, table that one
too. If you're like, nope, no way, no how, we're never approving this, Then you
go that direction. So here's what we're going to do. Just hang tight
for just a minute. We're going to go on to item 15— or 14B.
And I think you have a separate presentation or— Marcus.
Okay. Marcus has a presentation. Yeah.
So this development agreement largely follows the template for our other
data center development agreements. I'll just highlight a few kind of
nuances to this. You know,
because of the— there's not a specific buyer in mind, some of the
precise needs are sort of left a little bit more flexible where modeling
may be performed. The city would have approval rights as to the outcome
of that and be able to say, this is how we want you to do
it. You know, using the sewer improvements as an example,
it highlights kind of the Expectations that what
the modeling will show, but leaves it flexible and gives the ultimate approval
of of how whether it's going to route to the lift station,
you know, on the Meta property or sorry
on the QTS property or adjacent to the QTS property or whether it's going to
go directly gravity flow to the treatment plant. It leaves that open
for the city's ultimate approval, but that they
would be bearing the cost of. those infrastructure needs,
regardless of how it's ultimately going to be accomplished. So that's
kind of one change. Another thing that I think actually was a Planning Commission
recommendation that I think is a very good one is in Article
7. So, you know, under— you
know, if you go back a number of years where I think the city had
less negotiating power on some of these things, it's just
sort of the language was we can develop it whether or not we want,
if we want, and if not, we won't. Here it says once they be— you
know, it kind of locks them in once they begin the development
that they don't want— they no longer can terminate the agreement.
They're bound by it. Clarifies that. And I think that's stronger
language that was added to the benefit of the city.
But again, it just kind of walks through the specifics.
infrastructure needs in Article 5 of the agreement.
And otherwise, I think it is largely consistent with other
data center agreements. So, yeah. So we
can talk whatever questions you have.
Okay. So first of all, before you speak, we'll make sure there aren't
any questions for staff specifically. And if there is, then next we'll
I think there's a little bit of confusion, Marcus, because some people just received
the email and not everything came through. Yeah, I'm working on what came in the
packet, so if there's a difference, I need to know exactly what it is.
Yeah, so the only thing added was a second sentence to Article VII and
the name of the company. Should be the only differences. So— Article
VII is term? Yes. So there was a second sentence added
on there specifying that once they begin operating,
Once they start on the project and actually begin construction,
then they no longer have authority to terminate it at will, which is what the
original language, I think, said. I'm looking at the one that you just barely sent
us, and it doesn't have that second sentence that you're talking about. Like, it doesn't—
oh, it says the company? Did you add the name of something, or no?
So company is— so at the beginning of the agreement, it identifies who the company
is, and then it just uses company throughout the rest. Got it. Thank you.
Got it? Yeah. Okay. Thanks for your patience
with us, everyone. We wanna make sure we get things right. And so
that's where I was saying prior to the commencement they can cancel, but basically once
commencement's happened, then— Then they're committed to,
they're bound by the agreement. They can no longer, they no longer have
cancellation rights. They're still required to start within 3 years or renegotiate
that, right? Let me
So, I mean, so yes. So the language in 4.9,
timing and rate of development, is there that,
again, that they're committed to begin horizontal construction
within 3 years. And if they are unable
to do that for whatever reason due to change in circumstances as they are now,
then we would meet and in good faith to try to figure out how to
move forward. And it could be we're going to terminate the agreement because you haven't
started. It could be, um, this is what we're going to— this is how we're
going to adjust. That's consistent with language again in other development
agreements we've done. Marcus, what happens if the future owner
doesn't necessarily want to build a data center on it but wants to use it
as like, what, trailer city? Is that what you called it?
Like, I mean, it's only 41 acres, so it's not going to be like a
Sure. Like, what happens if that's the case? So this development—
these development rights are specific to data center and those other
associated uses related to it. It also includes rights for onsite
power generation, to be clear. So anything outside
of that, they wouldn't have any rights under the development agreement to build. But parking
for construction of a data center is an ancillary use, isn't it?
I mean, during construction, sure.
But I mean, we're not talking about parking. In this case, we're talking about what's
existing now is, you know, parking for the QTS construction on a neighboring property.
That's not a use for the property, you know,
for its permanent use. Okay. Thank you.
Well, let's go through the agreement. Oh, you have something?
Just one comment. The timing,
the reason the 3 years are going out longer is it is currently— Layton is
using part of that property. And so in— with
respect to them, we tried to push it out as much as possible if I
were to sell it so that they don't get screwed and have nowhere to go.
It wasn't anything on my end. Like I said, no one's pushing
us to do something right now or whatnot. But he had mentioned like within the
3 years or however long the duration of the development agreement is 100%
the reason for that is they are— I've committed to them to
let them use a lot of our space for another year and a half.
And so my concern was if this—
we sell it in a year and a half, does, does that 1.5 years post-Layton's
moving out, if they do, does that give enough time to start
moving horizontally? Does that make sense? I know that's in there and I don't mind—
don't change the language. The point being is there's It wasn't
just me throwing numbers and durations at the wall. It was trying to help Layton.
They think they employ— just on our property, there's— I know
the citizens don't like it, but there's 2,300 cars that go there a day that
are working on site. And I don't want them to have to park in Saratoga
and take a bus to their job site. They were good to us. I want
to be good to them and try to help them out as well. And so
in doing so, I'm trying to keep the durations as long as possible. Thank you.
It's not for me. I'm not building anything. So 1 year or 10
years for me doesn't change. It's more so to make sure Layton has time to
get their ducks in a row with what they might need to do— Layton Construction,
that is— and then anybody from there,
if that makes sense.
Jump in with some questions. So it's zoned today as agriculture?
That's correct. Okay, that wouldn't change. This is an overlay. So the use
today, it's not being used? No, we have access. Or there
is some? Yeah, they didn't take all the property. I only gave them a portion.
I still have— we also have cows and horses and chickens and pigs, and they're
still— it's still agriculture, and the underlying usage will remain ag.
So what a question I have is,
I, I— my concern is more just around the
trend that we're going to start setting here where
Meta is setting up Williams.
They've got 289 megawatt. Williams is going in, 17 turbines.
And then QTS, I think they're maxing out Rocky Mountain Power.
In this development agreement, it just references natural gas only,
no other energy sources. And so my concern is if we
kind of continue down this path with nat gas, what is the south
end of our city going to look like?
Um, I think with your— That, that's probably my biggest concern is just the energy,
whether it's a data center. To me,
they're, they're buildings, they're processing information.
Um, it's obviously useful. Everybody uses social media,
right? I think Meta, when I met with them, they said 90%
of the traffic that flows through there is from Instagram.
Geez. 10% is from inference. So data centers
are not going away, but I think we need to be careful around the responsible
use of how is the energy produced, where's that coming from. And as I was
reading through the agreement, I just saw nat gas, and it just makes
me wonder if that's the right path
within the development agreement. Obviously, it's going to have to be behind the wall 'Cause
Rocky Mountain Power is at capacity, is my understanding.
And then my second question, maybe with 40 acres it
doesn't matter, but we've got major traffic issues flowing through the city,
and we're just kind of
adding to a problem that we have not solved yet for residents.
If I may speak to some of those questions, I don't have all the answers,
but we had a— we pay a significant amount of money to have
a geothermal thermal study done on the land to see if geothermal energy would be
better with our water and whatnot. And this area in Eagle Mountain is
actually a really good area, same with Utah, for having a lot of faults.
And you need a lot of faults to have geothermal energy.
And we come to the conclusion that further south in the valley is actually
better for geothermal energy. You guys can look up the studies that they've done.
And so for us on our 41 acres, it wouldn't be really beneficial for
any data center to come in and build and try to use geothermal energy for
such a small site. For that site, you actually don't
need an air permit, pending how many megawatts you produce. But to be safe
and to try to do what's best for the city, we went and
spent a lot of money and research and are obtaining
our air permit that may never even have to be used, but it can go
with the property. The reason— Sorry.
I think that I can ask this question. Are you not
wanting to only limit to that? Would you rather change
that language to our new code and say that— Yes.
So, Marcus, I think the real ask is, could we change
that language to state the energy
overlay zone would
be applicable? Because that is one of the uses and it's within that
zone. Yeah.
We could adjust the language in 5.4 to basically
anticipate, you know, anticipate that they would be asking for a rezoned alternative energy
overlay to overlay in addition to the RTI.
And,
you know, under that zone, there would be a separate development
agreement that would be required to specify the type of energy and go through some
of the details of the energy. And if that's what's wanted, that's certainly something
we can do. I think that was the purpose of the zone, right? Exactly.
Just to give the developer and the council, quite honestly, some flexibility
in the path going forward. That's why it exists. Is there anything
that I need to do on my end for that, or is that just language?
I'm not advocating for one or the other. I'm trying to just make it— As
far as the language in 5.4, I mean,
yeah, well, there's enough, I guess, because there's a lot in
the recitals as well that references energy, and there's some of the other things in
there that reference energy. And so it probably— there's enough
changes that it probably warrants bringing it back for another date rather
than trying to do it here in the middle of the meeting.
So I don't think it's super complicated, but there's enough of it that
I wouldn't feel comfortable just trying to do it on the fly. So if that's
the case, then to help this move along, we can identify that we
need changes from natural gas specifically to the overlay zone, the power energy
overlay.
And what were some of your other questions, Councilman Wright? Let me get to my
first page. Let me just,
I'll ask a couple of quick questions, Mayor.
I've got some notes that I need to— And, and just real quick,
while you're looking at those notes, is that a consensus with the council? Because I
don't want to go make that change and have everybody say, I don't want that
overlay. So is, is that— I think they've already
approved that overlay zone, so I think— But do you want that in this development?
Probably not. So, so are you saying that it would
be a— that would go into place immediately, or that it would just
be It would be approved in the development agreement that the overlay
existed. It doesn't approve what is used. It's overlaying the
zone as an option. Rather than limiting it to nat gas, you would
be allowed whatever's in that zone, which includes all of the power
generation sources that we outlined. So I
just ask that we change that, and then I don't want to come back and
have everybody say, I just want natural gas. So I'm wanting to know, is that
acceptable? No, I think the problem— I mean, I'll just maybe say some of
my issues. I think that we've said yes, and one of the issues
are how many natural gas plants is too many. Thank you.
I'm not asking you the question. I'm just saying to us,
for us as we see them, as they are
operating, their noise and all the things that go along with them, how many is
too many of those things? We haven't contemplated any of
those things. That was one of my issues with the overlay zone, is that it
was broad and generic. It wasn't as specific as I think
it needs to be. And I think that if we just keep saying, oh yeah,
well, let's just throw another natural gas plant there so they can do it so
it doesn't impact, you know, the, the, the grid—
what are the consequences of those decisions? So I'm
in favor of broadening that so it's not specific
to that's the only way that it can be generated.
But I mean, I've been pretty open about doing a development agreement with
a non-user. Okay, so yes.
Well, Marcus, if this comes back, if that's the
action of this body, in the 1748-040,
it talks about prohibited uses, and it says any use that produces gas, smoke,
odor, dust, vibration of earth, or soot that in the opinion
of the city council will negatively impact commercial or residential areas that
are currently existing, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah. Um, are there certain
types of energy generation that are prohibited
based off of that definition that's in that part of code?
Yeah, so if the alternative energy overlay zone was, uh,
applied as well, then Those specific—
that general clause in 1748-040 would give
way to the more specific clauses of the alternative energy overlay
zone. So you can say it's in 040 that,
you know, it says that generally speaking, you know, if something produces gas,
smoke, odor, dust, vibration that the council determines
would negatively impact commercial residential areas that are currently existing,
Then, and thus therefore it's prohibited,
then if you then approve an alternative energy overlay zone
and specify in the development agreement that you can do a natural gas power
plant, since that's what we've been talking about in this meeting, for example, or geothermal,
and you specify that in the development agreement, that's gonna control, 'cause that's more specific.
Right, I guess going back to the discussion of whether
or not we rezone or development agreement, The rezone for me
is less of an issue because there are such strict
prohibited uses. We could rezone and that would
take care of this. It would give more time to
find better verbiage in the development agreement and figure
out exactly what power generation everyone's okay
with, especially if geothermal is an option and there are no negative
impacts of geothermal. Um, I just— I think the rezone
is more protected than what I think people are looking
at it to be. So,
Mayor, I'm just going to make this suggestion. I don't think that this is ready
for an approval. I just feel like there's still some
stuff that needs to be ironed out. I'm not saying no,
I'm just simply saying I don't think it's ready for us to
say yes. And from, from where
I'm seated, there's enough discussion and disagreement perhaps among
the members of the council that I would love to see this come back in
a work session and work through the development agreement portion of it and then
bring it back in conjunction with the
rezone. I don't think we should do either one at this point in time.
I think we should table them both and, and move on. Thank you. And bring
it back for discussion in a work session, the agreement itself.
Uh, if, if that's the case and we decide to do that, I'd love for
Marcus and Evan to bring back to us what are the
consequences of doing a development agreement with somebody who is
not a data center and what opportunities we may be missing
out in negotiation process, particularly in
MET tax incentives and all that type of I think we need to know what
the outcome of that is if we go forward with this portion of it without
the other part of it in the negotiation process.
So I actually was agreeing with that, which is why I was trying to find
out if there's specific changes, just bullet points that we know are the issues,
sticking points, because then it's going to be a really long conversation again
that still won't be there. So if there's a consensus that,
that 5.4, the natural gas, could be The energy overlay,
okay, they can go work that out. Is there any others that they need to
specifically work out? And I don't disagree with you, I'm just wondering what
are we going to— bullet points, what do they need to work
on? Well, let me just share my concerns and I'll just quickly try to go
through it just from my notes. So under the accessory uses, I'm wondering
why there's general storage facilities in there. Why does that exist as a use that
they're looking to add as an accessory use that doesn't exist in
the RTI? And maybe Reagan— Regan or Reagan can answer that,
or Mr. Peck. And they have water and sewer facilities.
What water and sewer facilities do you want to build as accessory uses to a
data center on this 41 acres? What are they?
I mean, what's the purpose of putting that in the development agreement? I don't know
the answer to that, but I'd like to know. Changes to the applicable
rules in 4.4. 4, at the end of the paragraph, it talks about
that. And I, I actually worked through that one. I think we're okay. In 5.1,
the sewer lift station, I have some major concerns about the sewer lift station and
about just the data center or the developer of this property
only putting in the infrastructure. I want to have a conversation about them owning
the, the M&O on their portion of the lift station because I don't want
them connected to a lift station at all. So I just think there's a
lot of things that we still need to hammer through. Not saying we can't find
an agreement. I'm just saying there's some portions of this that I'm uncomfortable with,
and the way it sits today, I would say no.
5.2 road improvements.
I'm curious about the road that's on the west side of the property. It's not
mentioned at all in the road improvements, just the north, just the north access
road. What's the plan to develop the west side of the property?
Property, and what are— what's the— what are you going to commit to? The property
is another municipality. They don't have to build a half
road on that, half road width? We don't have anything.
It dead ends and one goes to Fairfield. OK, that's— that answers that question for
me. That was the question that I— that I had as I looked at that.
And 5.5, let me look at what
5.5 says. Due to the temporary nature I'm
gonna have to— so where's 5.5? Can you pull that up, Marcus, where I can
see 5.5? That's the power.
Yeah, so it says— All right,
5.5 is, I think, kind of, you know,
it's regarding allowing overhead power lines. I don't know if that—
on the property itself, which is consistent. Yeah, but I'm curious. So are any
power lines gonna be temporary in nature? That's my question, because it says
Where does it say this temporary? Oh yeah, right there. So in the middle of
the paragraph it says the city acknowledges and agrees that no variance is required for
the overhead power lines because the overhead power lines are permitted under the applicable
rules due to the temporary nature of the overhead power lines.
On what planet are these going to be temporary power lines? That's my question.
I mean, that doesn't make sense. I think that was pulled
from the Meta agreement. So I just think there's some cleanup that we need to
do on this and some discussion that we need to have as council. So,
so far the power, the overlay, um,
I thought I had it in my head. The, the one that you just brought
up, the, uh, sewer lift station needs to be worked out.
So the, the ongoing expense of the sewer lift station.
Yeah, the maintenance and operation. Yep. And, uh,
The road we solved. So just for clarification, we're talking about upsizing
an existing lift station? Yes,
Marcus, but my concern is this: if we're, if we're going to entitle a data
center to connect to a lift station, I don't want the citizens on hook— on
the hook for having to make improvements to that, or not even improvements, to maintain
it and operate it. So it would be a city-owned lift station,
and the, and the user fees would own— and those connecting
to that are paying the user fees associated with the M&O of that.
And that's— so that would be— But if you're telling me
we can't do that, then we don't do it. But that's a question that I
want to work through. Yeah, sure. Again, we don't— yeah,
I mean, that is— those are captured through user fees typically, I guess, is what
I would say. The maintenance and operation of our lift stations.
Then I may be a no on a lift station connection for
a for a data center. That's what I'm saying. I don't want to maintain another
lift center, another lift station that the citizens are maintaining,
even though there's user fees associated with it, because the citizens are
going to bear a portion of that cost. And it's going to last longer
without the data center connected to it and utilizing the capacity, even if they
upsize the capacity, wearing it out sooner. So those are concerns that I
have, and they may not be able to be mitigated But I'm unwilling to say
yes until we have that conversation. Okay. I just want, again, for clarification,
we're talking about a lift station on the— that is— was dedicated to the city
by another data center that built it, and they would be upsizing
that existing lift station that is currently only handling data center flow.
So if I could maybe clarify, if it's only used
by multiple data centers, there aren't any residents,
can we restrict that That if there's ever any maintenance,
that they would also take care of some of the M&O because the city— Again,
in the event that— again, the way it's put,
um, that, that is an option. If you want to restrict it so
you have to gravity flow directly to the sewer treatment plant, then we can change
that language if that makes you feel more comfortable. Um,
I don't know what— how they feel about that. Um, again, we were
going to let the modeling kind of determine what is actually needed from the project,
what was the best, what makes the most sense.
You know, again, if they had to upsize the lift station, they would be responsible.
Those are project improvements. They are responsible for that cost.
So— You may be able to— If you want to add language saying that there
is some sort of— again, they pay user fees to that.
So I'm not sure what else there is as as cost recovery
for their actual impact, uh, because they're going to pay a higher user fee due
to the— based on the impact they're having on the sewer system.
I think too, when we look at lift stations
and the nightmares that have happened in certain parts of the city,
they're privately owned ones that were put in at different standards
than what the city requires. And having one that's
very specific and it was installed for this use,
and it was installed at city standards with SCADA and all
of those other things. I feel like they're two different things. And I
totally get where you're coming from, because I don't want residents to
have to bear the brunt of that. But from what I understand,
Marcus is saying is that— Thank you. Any improvements are done by
the actual users of it. And that particular lift station isn't a
resident lift station. It's just the one that was built for the
data centers. So I think if we could put something into the
agreement that clarifies the responsibility of that and a
little bit more to do with that, it would help to address some of the
concerns that are being brought up. Is that the only way to service this
area, Brad, is through a lift station?
I mean, we haven't looked at it You know,
model-wise, to a model level, but there's a high likelihood based
on everything else that we're seeing there that it's probably a lift to
a lift station. There's a good potential for it.
And so just walk me through the scenario. So we entitle it,
we say yes, put it in, you're going to pay for it, we take ownership
of it, we start to collect user fees for it, and it fails, which they
always fail. Who's going to pay for that repair or
the maintenance and operation of that? The data center is
going to pay for that, or is the city going to pay for that?
So right now it depends. So if they have to build a
secondary independent lift station, then there's
probably some onus that we could probably get that arrangement to work through
with the entity. But the existing QTS,
the lift station that's there in that region, is actually
slated over to the city And they're trying to get that turned over to us
per that original agreement.
So I think just to add some context, there's— when
I say it could be a lift to a lift, we don't know that
yet. But just knowing the, the grades and everything that are there,
it's a high likelihood that it will be that scenario. The next scenario
would be that that land— this landowner would have to tie in
potentially the sewer system on the QTS site to
flow through their site, potentially to get to their
lift station to flow. So it's— without looking
at it and knowing exactly what it is and working with the
project, it's hard to say today. Brad,
really quick, if there's no lift station involved and
it's just sewer, who ends up paying for the sewer
repairs and operations The city.
What? The city. And if it's a gravity— like,
if it's a gravity sewer line on a right-of-way, it's the city. Right. So,
like, either way, we bear some responsibility for
it, but we also are able to recoup those costs through
user fees for that particular area, right? But I think the
biggest concern— we ran into this in the past— is that we're trying to get
to a regional aspect of a lift station and not individual lift stations.
Because if we're going to go individual lift stations, we need to put that burden
back onto the people that are building them.
Got it. And that could be something that's written into a development agreement,
right? Where the responsibility lies?
Yeah, as far as the response, again, right now it's written
that if they would have to connect, if they're going to connect to a lift
station, it would have to be one that already exists. And then they would be
responsible for upgrading it. As far— again, they're going to pay
the user fees. That's how you pay the M&O, and that's how it is for
every— again, for everything we have in our sewer system. Yes, Marcus,
but what we say— I want to make sure this is crystal clear and make
sure that I'm understanding it correctly— but what we're saying is we're okay allowing
you to put in another lift station that we're going to then own and
be responsible to maintain As long as you're paying user fees,
which would be the same if they were just flowing into
a into a sewer line period without a lift station
in line, right? They would pay the same user
fees based on that. They're not paying a higher user fee because there's a lift
station. It's correct. It's based on the volume of they have water. They have
a higher infrastructure cost to put it in, and I get that. But they turn
it over to the city, and now the city owns this higher piece. I think
part of the problem
though too is that our code prohibits private lift stations. So we created
the problem of us taking it on. So if we don't want any
lift stations, then we should ban lift stations altogether, which would mean
that certain areas of the city couldn't be developed, right? I think
it's something to consider with regard to this agreement. Is there a way to
have a private lift station? to protect the citizens from having to bear the cost
of the maintenance and operation of an additional lift station that they
don't need. Could it be like a special service district? It's not an
additional lift station. That's, I think, where we're at, where I guess I'm not understanding.
It is if Brad's report comes back and they have to build a new
station to service his property. That's not what the agreement contemplates. The agreement
says existing lift station. It would just be an
upsize of an They're upgrading an existing lift station. So it's— we
already have a lift station that we're responsible for on the— Who's going to maintain
the one that they have to build if they have to put one behind that
lift station? They're upgrading an existing lift station. If they
have to tie into another lift station, then they would have to tie into another
existing lift station. So if it was lift station to lift station,
there's nothing in this agreement that would authorize them to build a new lift station
that's not already existing. So basically what you're saying,
Marcus, is they would have to be able to gravity feed to
that existing lift station or else they
can't connect? Yeah, or they're going to have to come back and ask for permission
to do something different.
That might solve my concern. We were under the impression of
that. We were never planning to— I mean, there's sewer already to our property.
through the additional stuff with QTS that was to a lift station.
And so it was never even a consideration on our end to
do something like that. Can you tell we love lift stations? I love lift stations.
No, I— this— I really wanted to say to everyone, I know— I love them.
I love them so much I want to get rid of them all. That I'm
taking a lot of your time, but this is almost more beneficial as a conversation
for me than it might even be for you guys, which I appreciate. That's how
much I'm invested in this going the right way for the city. I I'm
grateful for Marcus too. He's been really good to sit with us and do it
the right way. Okay, so, uh, Councilmember Wood,
I appreciate you being patient. I know you wanted to jump in a while ago.
It's kind of been on this end. Did you still— Yeah,
so the other question is, why are we giving them 20 years when we don't
have a TIF that we're looking at? We don't have a CRA. Why do they
need 20 years for a development agreement? Um, we— I don't
think— I'm not wedded to 20 years. 20 years. I just want to make sure
it has time to develop. If they think they can develop it faster than that,
then I'll let them decide how long the agreement needs to be. As I look
at this, it's 40 acres. I mean, it's a pretty small facility.
Yeah, I mean, if they can do it in 10 years, great.
Why not? Let's change it to 10. Why not do benchmark chunks, then make them
come back and ask for more time? I would rather do that than have them
do nothing for 15 years. So they already have to start Vertical in 3.
Why would we go more than— They don't lose their development rights.
So 20 years just has it sit there for 20 years. Again,
I'm not wedded to 20 years. That was just the number we picked. I would
say I'm not comfortable with 20 years. There's no reason to give it to them.
There's no benefit to the city for 20 years. So I think that needs to
be amended, but I don't know what that timeframe should be.
With the user, I mean, they're building data centers You know, less than
5 right now. Yeah, so if they have to start in 3, wouldn't at
least 10 be plenty? That's what I'm getting at. So I mean, just— I'm trying
to find— I'm saying why not set it at 6, and if they need more,
let them come ask for it? That only gives them 3
to build. Isn't the point that we want them to get started and build it?
I agree with you. I'm just saying that gives them 3. If they start in
3, is 3 enough? Depending on who it is, right? I've said 6.
Give them 6 and make them come back and say we're wrong. Is there a
consensus there? I just want to know, because if that's— when it comes back— That's
my opinion. We haven't made a motion on this yet anyway. So you're
talking about 6 years total for construction from the moment of start? Yeah. From the
moment of starting. And if they need more time, they can come back and ask
for an amendment. That's within the Master Development Agreement code anyway. So I
would be curious for you to gather— maybe you have data on this—
like how many megawatts would be needed to support the data center that would
go there, because it might be a lot smaller than all of us are thinking.
And we're getting our minds wrapped around, like, the energy source
and maybe the— like, how many turbines would you need for natural gas?
And should we go that direction? That's a great question, and I'd love to address
it. We're looking at a lot of different options, and there are many options.
On that site, you're not going to get anything— even with the greatest of everything
on the planet to date, you're probably not getting more than 200 megawatts.
on the lower end is kind of what maybe you're going to be looking at.
To answer your question specifically, because it's a great question, I'm only concerned,
only concerned about Layton. I'm honestly trying to do my best for them.
I said 20 because I thought, what if this buyer
comes and they're like, we're not ready yet, and we'll just let Layton stay there
till they finish out QTS, which they're projected 8 or 9 years. So I thought,
okay, worst case they go 10 years. then they start
doing their stuff, they have 10 years. For me,
it's not to have this sit for that. I mean, it's a fantastic concern,
which I agree with. If Layton wasn't in the picture, and we're all agreeing it's
Layton Construction, I can say, right? If Layton Construction wasn't in the picture using the
land, which I told them, and I'm not going to go back on my word,
I gave them my word, they have a year and a half left.
So we're looking at about March of '28.
My concern is if you say the development agreement was good for 4 years,
a year and a half has already gone for anything that they may look to
do. And I don't even know what that might look like. Just blanket statement
of saying, I, I want to take care of anybody that I said can use
that land, and I'd hate to come back and tell a buyer sorry,
or tell Layton get out of here because I only have so long with
the city. So I do Completely understand your concern,
and I don't— I think it's very valid. Maybe 20 years isn't
the mark. The only reason I said that was if in case they needed it.
I would say to that, Regan, that then you're probably not ready for a development
agreement. If you're coming in and asking for a start time and you're not ready
to execute that, why ask now? Because you have obligations
to the current user that you want to keep. You're a year and a half
too early. Per se, I agree, but not— and I'd also disagree
because let's say I sold it tomorrow. You're going to
be 6 to 8 months of due diligence on that buyer. So that puts
me now, I'm only essentially 7 months away from,
if they wanted to start, right? 7 months away from Layton being done.
The reason we brought it to City Council now is because we think we're at
the exact right time. Some of these companies are going out a year for due
diligence, and I don't blame them. They're looking at spending a lot of money and
a lot of time and a lot of resources. So even
if I sold it in an hour, I will promise you I'm
6 to 8 months on the company's due diligence based on conversations I've had
months prior to coming here. And so I didn't do it in
the spring when we first came because I agreed with you, we were 2 years
too early. But your ability to hit that 3-year mark that's in your development agreement
is pretty low. I think that I would hope for you
to— I don't know what goes in with the amendment. I don't think that's a
bad idea, because I think if a developer or a builder came to you and
said, hey, these were the parameters, I think you guys are upstanding
men that would say, yeah, you're not trying to pull the wool over our eyes.
I would agree. That's why I'm saying I would— starting in
3 years is— that doesn't bother me. I just want to give them time to
do what they needed to do. And if there is a provision where they can
come back and say, these are the legitimate reasons why,
I would agree with you. I wouldn't want somebody to come in there and be
like, guess what, we can do whatever we want for 30 years. I agree.
I would just hope that there's some clear language for the end user to say,
yeah, if you need more time, come to the city and explain why. And one
of those reasons might be— So on that one, Marcus,
it looks like if we can— I didn't get an exact consensus, but I
want to keep moving forward. But we need to tighten up the timing somewhere.
I've heard 6, 10-ish. Would you consider 6
after the 3-year or whatever that trigger is?
So then it gets them closer to 10, which I think is where I
would be. But I'm also sensitive to like the
reasons that you're giving. But would you consider 6 after the 3?
To Rich's point, I'm after a year and a half. That's to whatever, you know
what I mean? If you said, hey, 3 years after the year and a half
to start and then give them time, that's fine.
I'm not worried for how— because they, like you said, I think it's
a great point, they can come back to you and say we need more time.
I just— I want— So based on the comments that
we've had, just clean up the timing that we've heard.
I think that Brett made the point that I agree with. I think it needs
to come back to a work session. I think we've talked We've talked about a
number of the things. I think Marcus has at least some parameters of things that
need to be talked about, but we're not
there on this. Well, and that's why I'm trying to just say clean up the
timing and move on. So is there any other points that need to be cleaned
up specifically? Not really? So the ones
we've talked about, if we can clean those up, then we can go to the
negotiation of the fine details if we need to. Is that where
we're at, you think? Yeah. Okay,
so if that's where we're at on this one, then let's jump back to 14—
Hold on, let's make a vote before we pass this and then have to come
back to it again and make another vote. If we're gonna table it, let's table
it and then go on to the other one. We're going back to 14A,
the rezone. That's what I'm saying. We haven't tabled— there's no vote that's taken place
on 14B. There's no vote on 14A. Right. So does
it matter what order? We moved our discussion to 14B.
So he's saying we moved it, we moved on to 14B, so resolve that before
going back to— It is resolved. Well, but he said, he said take a vote
on 14B. Yes, let's do a motion
and then go back to 14A. So, uh,
Mayor, I, I move that City Council table, uh,
agenda item 14B. Second.
Okay, we have a motion by Councilmember Whiting and a second by Councilmember
Wright. We'll start the roll with Councilmember Clark. Yes. Councilmember Wright. Yes.
Councilmember Whiting. Yes. Councilmember Wood. No.
Councilmember Huish. No.
That passes 3-2. All right, now go back to
14A.
Mayor, I make a motion that we table item 14A.
Second.
All right, we have a motion by Councilmember Wright and second by Councilmember Whiting.
We'll start the vote with Councilmember Wright. Yes. Councilmember Whiting.
Yes. Councilmember Wood. Yes. Councilmember Hewish.
Yes. Councilmember Clark. Yes. Okay, and that
passes. Can I just make a comment? This is all moving in a
forward direction. No, this is great. Like, even though it feels like nothing
happened. Hey, this is great. I think a lot went in the
direction you really wanted it to go. And it helped me understand a lot.
I appreciate you guys taking the time and talking me through a lot of things.
Anything needed from me based on tonight, or will they— will work
just behind the scenes, correct? Okay, have a great night. Thank you.
All right, 15A is also a public hearing. It's Ordinance of Eagle
Mountain City, Utah, updating the Culinary Water Impact Fee Facilities Plan.
And we have our city engineer here to give the presentation.
Good evening, Mayor and Council. Good to be with you tonight.
Get this pulled up real quick and then we can move ahead.
All right. Discussion tonight is on the culinary water IFFP
update. As you guys know, this came before you approximately
a year ago as a new IFFP.
At that point,
as you know, the city is growing fast. I don't have
to tell you guys that. And it's changing a lot. And so to keep
up with that, we're bringing it back to you a year after it was approved.
And there are reasons for that. And we'll go through those reasons in just a
One of the biggest reasons is new development,
the Spring Run area, Talons Cove area. You guys have seen this concept
plan come before you. As you know, there's actually
been just east of the Walmart area developments
that have come in already, ready to develop right now. It was originally assumed that
this piece of property or this big chunk of land in our city was going
to be out in the future, you know, 20, 30 years. But as we can
see, it's, it's moving ahead faster than we originally anticipated. And so we
wanted to add this section of land to our culinary water IFFP
at this time. Um, just, just a note on
the IFFP, uh, for the public mostly, but it, it's a plan
that is really focused on the next 5 years
of projects that we have going on. And And what
it is is trying to nail down what those costs are going to be so
that we can get impact fees, um, as development comes
in. We don't want to put the cost of that new growth on the existing,
uh, members of the community. We want to put that on
the members who are moving into the community, in the— into the community.
So the point of the IFFP is to nail down a cost of
what that impact is going to be in the next 5 years and then move
ahead with it. So, um,
another thing that we kind of nailed down— we, we got a
lot more information. We've completed a 30% design on
our, uh, Central Utah Waterline
that's going to parallel SR 73.
Um, as you can see from this map, it's just— it's on the
north side. We haven't nailed down the alignment exactly, but what we did nail down
was the cost. Um, and we were trying to more than anything
get the cost nailed down so that we can figure out bonding and funding and
things moving forward. And so as we got that nailed down, we actually went
back and compared it. Uh, it was very different from what was in
the original IFFP, so we needed to update that cost.
And then the cost of diesel is up,
the cost of construction is up. As you know, costs are
rising daily, and because of that,
we went through all of the cost estimates in the IFFP
from last year and just made sure that we're actually covering all the costs that
the— that is— that these capital projects are going
to take.
So bottom line, um, our cost from the 2025
plan for the next 5 years for all of our capital projects
for culinary water, uh, was $73.2 million. We had
to bump that up to $109.1 million.
So big jump. Uh, part of that— and
I should go back to the SR-73 project to explain— that project
went up quite a bit in the cost, and that's kind of the majority of
the, the cost difference that you're seeing. Part of that is because
through the 30% design process, we were looking at it going,
this will cover our water needs for maybe the next
10 years, but we want to look further than that. We want to upsize this
pipe and make sure it covers the needs of the city,
not just for 10 years, but for the long term, so we're not having to
run a parallel pipe in the future. And so that, that was kind of the
main piece of this puzzle that bumped up this cost.
And with that, I'll entertain any questions you have.
Nope. Nothing. Thank you.
I think it's— I, you know, I appreciate
seeing forward thinking and forward planning. I think that's a reality
that we can't hide from. We got to have that pipeline
in the north area, particularly what's going to be coming in that area
in the future. So thank you for putting
the time and effort into that, thinking forward.
I echo that. I think it's interesting because we— one of the things we get
raked across the coals the most is when there's fee increases or user
fees, just different things like that. And people ask the question,
why aren't you guys— why isn't growth paying for growth?
And I think that this administration
and this engineering team is setting us up for success,
and I hope that the residents see that this is us
as a city making sure that those costs are borne by the people that create
them. So thank you for being here.
Okay, thank you. We will— this is a public hearing,
so at 9:24 I will open
the public hearing. Brett Simpson.
Mayor and City Council, thank you for the opportunity. Thank you for all you do
staying late tonight, and quite an agenda. So, um,
finally got to this, uh, topic, so appreciate that.
My question is, uh, so Brett Simpson, I'm with Pony Express Land Development.
I'm a developer. We own, uh, some land to build homes,
some that's zoned for residential. We also own some land
for commercial as well. And so with
the plan, $109 million, the increases,
the 5-year plan, the Table 6 in
the plan that talks about the population and the
growth, I'm wondering if council or if Vince
has any idea or any guidance they could give me about
when I'll be able to buy water from the city for
my residential developments. I've got 20 acres I'm sitting on that
I can't do anything with because it's zoned for residential
and there's no water. I don't have any water to dedicate to the
city. There is obviously scarce—
scarcity in water in this particular area
is As you all know. And so my question
is, if with this plan, if there's any projection
about when the improvements
will be completed enough that the city would be able
to start selling water for residential developments again.
And if anyone has any thoughts, I'd be interested in hearing them. I'll venture.
I don't know that the two are tied together. We made a decision
about selling residential water because of the lack of the resource and the need
to be able to reserve that for commercial and institutional
use. So as far as running the lines and all that up to
that area, I don't think the two are necessarily connected,
my opinion. Okay, we're still in the public hearing portion,
so we can address that in a minute. I don't know where we're at with
time, but Thank you for that. I paused it so I can resume. Are you
doing— Yes, I'm, I'm finished. Thank you.
Okay, was there anyone else? I have nobody else.
Yeah, what, uh,
who did you— did you say someone— no one else? No one else. Okay,
sorry, I didn't hear you. Sorry about that. Okay, if there—
is there anyone still— anyone else here that would like to speak on this item
that did not have a Seeing no one, I will close the
public hearing at 9:27 and bring it back to the council. Did you have a—
Yes, I take issue when people say there's no water because there's
like 16,000 acre-feet that are just out there.
It's just they're in different hands. The city only has a finite
amount of shares that we have, and as a body, we've decided
to dedicate those shares to industrial and commercial uses. There are
plenty of private entities out there that are selling water, and it's a market-driven
price. So I would encourage you to look to
that as an option, because I don't think the city is going to change
what we're doing anytime soon, because we have a responsibility to
future generations to make sure that we preserve the
water for things like city infrastructure
and commercial entities so that the people growing up here can ultimately
have jobs and, you know, those pieces. So like,
I, I would encourage you and your group
to go around and look at the private market.
There's, there's people out there that are helping people purchase
these things. It exists. And the city and this
valley has tons of water, um,
collectively but you're going to have to do the work to go find it individually.
All right, is there any other questions for staff on this, or nothing?
Then if there's no other comments or questions, discussions,
I'll entertain a motion. I move we approve item 15A,
Mayor. Second. Okay, we have a motion by Councilman
Second by Councilmember Clark. And we'll start the vote with Councilmember Wright. Yes. Councilmember Whiting.
Yes. Councilmember Wood. Yes. Councilmember Hewish. Yes. Councilmember Clark.
Yes. All right, we'll move on to item 15B,
an ordinance. Uh, this one is also a public hearing, an ordinance of Eagle Mountain
City, Utah, updating the wastewater master plan and the wastewater
impact fee plan.
So this is going to feel like a little bit of a repeat, so I
won't repeat a lot of it, but pretty
much very, very similar reasons why we're coming
back for an update on this one. Rising costs and
adding that spring run area in the north end of the city.
The adding this part of the city actually necessitated
additional Piping or upsize of piping
in the Ranches Parkway area.
All of that flow will come south and then goes east
towards Timpanoga Special Service District,
and we couldn't facilitate this area without upsizing that Ranches
Parkway pipe. And so that was something that was that was new.
It wasn't an upsize or anything like that. That's it's.
It's one that's— it wasn't in the 2025
plan is what I'm trying to say, and it is in the 2026 plan.
The other part is we did finish our 30% design on our East Trunkline project,
similar to the Central Utah Waterline. But this East Trunkline
project, it comes down the east side of the city.
As you know, our Pony Express sewer line is nearing
capacity, and so we need to run a parallel line to
get the waste down to the sewer treatment plant on the south side
And then just the construction costs, as I mentioned before,
in all aspects are going up, and so we updated
our cost to reflect them.
This one, uh, went from $193.7
million in 2025 and is going to $259.4
million in 2026. Uh, the majority of
this one was actually in the wastewater treatment
plant upgrade itself. Um, costs there have
risen quite a bit over what was originally anticipated.
And, and so, uh, almost 90% of this
increase is in that one project as we take our sewer treatment
plant from, uh, 2.6 million gallons today,
uh, per day up to over 8 million gallons per day.
Any questions on this one?
All right. No questions? This is also a public
hearing, so if there aren't any questions, at 9:31 I
will open the public hearing. Nothing? Not a soul?
Ah, man. Is there anyone here that did not have a chance to speak on
this item? Seeing no one, at 9:32
we will close the public hearing and bring it back to council for any discussion.
If there's none, a motion? So moved. Mayor, I move that the City Council
approve, um, Item 15B,
an ordinance of Eagle Mountain City updating the wastewater master plan and
wastewater impact facility fee facility plan,
IFFP. Second. Okay, we have a motion by Councilmember Clark,
a second by Councilmember Wright, and we'll start the vote with Councilmember
Whiting. Yes. Councilmember Wood. Yes. Councilmember Hewish.
Yes. Council Member Clark? Yes.
Council Member Wright? Yes. Okay, that passes.
We'll go on to item 15C. This is also a public hearing.
It is an ordinance of Eagle Mountain, Utah— Eagle Mountain City to
amend— what'd I say?
Uh, the Municipal Code 9.10 and 1747
regarding archery use. within the city, and we have Natalie
with us. Good evening, Mayor and
Council. Just a quick overview of this item
for the public. We've had— or the City
Council requested that we look into incorporating archery
zones into our city, into our city code, so that it would be allowed,
first of all, and then second of all, that we could make sure that we're
doing so in a way that is safe for all parties.
Um, our summer interns Addison Cragin
and Ethan Jacobson researched this code and
put it together. Um, they came and presented it to you guys in August,
um, took your feedback and your thoughts,
incorporated it. We went to Planning Commission and
they gave it a favorable review. And now it's just
back to the City Council.
All right, any questions for Natalie?
All right, then we will move on to the public hearing.
It is 9:34, and I will open the public hearing on this item.
Nobody wants to talk about archery? I love archery.
Anybody here that didn't get a chance to speak? All right,
at 9:34, we will close the public hearing and
bring it back to the council for any discussion or motion. I think we've seen
it all, so— All right, you can go for it.
Mayor, I move the city council approve agenda item 15C,
an ordinance of Eagle Mountain City, Utah, amending the Eagle Mountain Municipal Code Section
9.10 and 17.47 regarding archery use within
the city. Second. All right, we have a motion by Councilmember Whiting
and a second by Councilmember Hewish. And we'll start the vote with
Councilmember Wood. Yes. Councilmember Hughes.
Yes. Councilmember Clark. Yes. Councilmember Wright. Yes.
Councilmember Whiting. Yes. Okay, that passes. And we
will go on to 15D, which is an ordinance of Eagle Mountain City, Utah,
amending the Municipal Code Section 1760-120,
General Fencing and Screening Provisions. And this is also a public hearing.
I have a picture on this one.
Mayor and Council, some time ago, not that long ago,
had an industrial business that came to you and they asked through
development agreement or one of their development agreement conditions to be allowed to
have barbed wire fencing atop their external— I think
it was chain link fencing— as a security protocol or measure. And it
required, as I understand, a new development agreement or at least be added onto
a development agreement to allow for that possibility. This code
would offer the opportunity for security
fencing to be mounted at the top, chain link, et cetera,
were allowed. And this would be only in the RTI zone, and one
of the questions to ask would be, if even agreeable, do you want staff to
have some kind of standard for the fencing?
Height, et cetera. Just a quick question. So specific security
fencing for a specific use or just for all RTI?
RTI. So it was targeted towards one particular kind
of use. Yeah, I— so I'm looking through this and I
had a short conversation with Councilmember Wright about this.
I can see where there's some applicable uses to that.
Perhaps data centers might be part of that conversation.
We talked about even energy production facilities, but I
think we want those screened anyway. But I obviously, I'm not opposed to
having razor wire on top of it to protect the facility as well. But having
it broadly available, I'm less interested in. So I
would like to see some specificity to it for
security measures for perhaps those 2 uses. I don't know how anybody else
feels about that. Thank you, Councilor, for the good comments. Then staff would
request tabling of this for that, as well as any instructions
on the build-out of that wiring if you have any concerns.
You know, would it be 3 strands on 2 extended poles? Would it be rolled?
What would it be? And there is a correction as part of this that I
should have pointed out that we'd like to have
left in there. It's just clarification.
I guess I'm just wondering, Councilmember Wood, about— I
mean, the 2 uses that you spell out make sense to me to allow that
in some ways, but are there other uses in that RTI that we might want
to consider? And that's where I'm wrestling a little bit with this,
is if we're going to do it, do we want it to be very limited
in scope? That's what it sounds like you're advocating for, and I understand the reasons
for that. I'm just— Could you make it a
special use and then— I mean,
I guess if you did a special use, then you got to state what it
is. I mean, what else besides those 2 would you consider it
for? Well, what if you have a drone manufacturer that wants to secure his facility
or her facility and they want to use some sort
of a barbed wire top of the fence to keep I think that everybody
could apply it in that sense and say for their own protection of their property,
right? Well, and so that's
what I'm wrestling through in my mind is, are we being too narrow or
are we being too broad if we go the other way? And I'm not sure
what the right answer is. I'm just asking the question
'cause I'm thinking about those things.
Right now it's prohibited. You can't do it at all. Yeah, and Mayor, one other
quick comment. My apologies. Maybe one of the other considerations
council should have with this in thinking through it a little past the staff report
is right now the opportunity to have that is ascribed to the
DRC to decide upon. Maybe that ought to be better
in city council's hands as part of site plan review.
But the RTI overlay zone requires a development agreement. We just went through
that. I mean, it does require a development agreement, so why not
require— why not include that as a condition of the development agreement if
the end user wants it? My thought was that would be something
you'd have to keep adding every time. Besides, the development agreement was based on processing,
that you can expedite a process.
That would give you the ability to be discerning in when
that should exist and when it shouldn't. shouldn't exist, though. And I think
the number of development agreements that we're actually looking at are probably pretty minimal.
What I'm just wondering, rather than putting it in the general code,
to put it in the RTI anyway, because that's an area that I don't know
that you'd ever deny it. Is that what you're suggesting, or? Well, why don't we
just, even if we just write it into the RTI overlay zone at the
time of a development agreement, that they request that
as— yeah, that, that, that they request that entitlement and that, that it's a may.
May request it by the council. Yeah, great. Okay, so, so change
that line into the RTI overlay as a may,
and then it become— it comes in the— then the burden kind of goes back
to the applicant when they're looking at the use, and they have to make that
decision on the front end instead of on the tail end of everything.
Okay, was there anything Anyone
else on this one? Are you clear
on the change?
Yes. Okay, then this is also a public hearing,
so if there's no other comments, I will open the public hearing
at 9:40. And Lacey
has nothing. So is there anyone here that would like to speak on this
item? Seeing no one, I'll close the public hearing
at 9:40 and bring it back to the council.
So my question is, does it make the most sense to just deny this and
have it come back in the RTI overlay zone as a, as a May?
Is there any other changes?
Rob, how do you feel about that?
6 is with me. Deny and I'll bring it back, or table.
What would you prefer? Because I'm going to just
I'm going to make a motion according to what you tell me. I would just
say table this one, have to readvertise it. Okay, then,
then, Mayor, I will make a motion if you're open to that. Go ahead.
What number is this one? Somebody tell me. 15E.
15E? E. So, Mayor, I move that we— I move that we table
item 15— D as in David. D as in David.
Second. Okay, we have a motion by
Councilmember Me, Wright. Wright. And a second
by Council Member Wood, right? And we will start the vote with
Council Member Hewish. Yes. Council Member Clark. Yes. Council Member
Wright. Yes. Council Member Whiting. Yes. And Council
Member Wood. Yes. Okay, that passes.
That's, that's why I was confused where I was at. I was waiting. All right,
so, uh, public hearing, uh, Eagle Mountain City amending the
municipal Code 1725.040 residential
standards table. Mayor, council, we talked about
this before. Scenic Mountain, remember, was just recently rezoned. We had about 223
lots out there that were part of that action. This is one of the exhibits
from that, that effort. In so doing, we talked
about the concern that staff had, which was that in trying to assign
a zone on our books to the properties out there that best matched
the configurations, the sizes, etc., existing conditions of
those properties, it was revealed that a number of them were below even our
RC zone in sizing, which bottoms out at 4,500 square feet. So a lot
of those were about 3,800 and change. To further the
effort of trying to keep from having issues with those properties
questioned down the road by the private sector as to whether they were legally
conforming or not, et cetera, and then force us into generating zoning
verification letters, potentially rebuild letters at the time of a financial transaction by
any of the parties in that Scenic Mountain project.
We discussed and it seemed agreeable to have the proposed zoning
code amendment, which is before you right now in red underneath
the chart. And it simply says that for not new
properties, Nothing newly developed, but for those existing properties, if they happen
to be under 4,500 square feet and/or have a setback configuration that was substandard per
our code in some fashion, that we would recognize those as legally conforming,
not nonconforming, but conforming. So in other words, we're giving them a buy.
And this same approach you may see, if you're agreeable with it,
down the road, but it's again to try and unobstruct people's
financial transactions with properties. properties that are already built out.
Any questions? Seeing none, this is also
a public hearing. At 9:44, we will open the public hearing and
find out if anyone came for this. Not a soul. All right,
is there anyone here that would like to speak on this item that has not
had the opportunity? Seeing no one, I will close the public
hearing at 9:44. And come back to Councilmember Whiting.
I'd like to make a motion. I move
that the City Council approve Agenda Item 15E, an ordinance of
Eagle Mountain City, Utah, amending the Eagle Mountain Municipal Code Section 17.25.040
Residential Standards Table. Second. Okay, we have a motion
by Councilmember Whiting, a second by Councilmember Hewish, and we
will start the vote with Councilmember Clark. Yes. Councilmember Wright. Yes.
Council Member Whiting? Yes. Council Member Wood? Yes. And Council Member
Hirsch? Yes. Okay,
moving on to item 15F, an ordinance of Eagle
Mountain City amending the Eagle Mountain Municipal Code 17100-040,
master site plans. Back to Rob. Thank you, Mayor.
Excuse me, my apologies for the formatting error I just observed
with the auto reformat that did with my paragraphs and didn't catch it.
My only consolation is that you see even in national news stories sometimes errors
that the editors miss. This is an attempt to do a couple of things.
One is clarify or make, you know, a little easier
to read perhaps some of the content, but mainly it's to get away from
the question like we had with the charter school not that long ago as to
what to do when your code now says, well, you need a master site plan
for that project, because you've got more than 5 acres you're dealing with.
And then, oh, by the way, you need a regular site plan approval thereafter.
That makes sense for when you've got a configuration of multi-pad sites or lots
or maybe a multi-tenant building setup. But in that particular
instance, it created a little bit of confusion if we're trying to go right by
the letter of the law. So this attempts to make that clear that it's one
or the other, and there are some set conditions which follow what's basically in the
code now. Thank you. Maybe reword it a little bit. The other one though,
that's more of a policy shift, which I try to draw your attention to in
the staff report, is what you see in D and E on this slide.
And this is a little bit of a different take on how we process
our site plans and plats together. Current code basically says, well,
where they're required, you got to bring in your site plan before you do your
plat. Just today and previously, which is
what raised the question in my We had parties
that were saying, well, what if we just want to divide a big property we
have? We'll follow the platting standards, we'll take care of
the road planning, offsite and on, the utilities, et cetera, but we
don't have a user yet. When we get one, then sure,
they can come in and apply for your site design approval
and get their architectural stuff pinned down, the parking and
landscaping, et cetera, at that time. For each of the properties that they're
trying to work with.
And so that's not an unusual request. It's actually pretty common
from experience in other jurisdictions that, yeah, someone could, with residential
or commercial or industrial and so forth, ask for that. The idea though would be
that we would not offer that opportunity for residential. It'd only be for commercial and
industrial if you're agreeable with what's written
there in particularly E.
Questions? So just a
couple questions about this. Uh, preliminary plat
approval vests in, uh, uses,
correct? Once a preliminary plat has been approved?
I'm sorry, let's— to Marcus.
So, um, Site plans are often
after preliminary plat approval, but a site plan can act as the
preliminary plat. So I guess it varies.
But the preliminary plat is the binding document? They're both
binding land use approvals. Now,
they vest different things. The preliminary plat
typically will vest certain things like lot layouts and road widths and
all that. A site plan will vest additional things.
But again, the site plan can be the preliminary plat.
So— Yeah.
Mayor, apologies. I wanted to point— The site plan is generally
more specific than a preliminary plat. With our OpenGov system,
staff agreed anyway, with that new program, it would be cleaner for
us to have— even though you can combine the two,
paperwork-wise, registry-wise, et cetera, if you will, to have
the 2 applications be separate. They can still come in, be reviewed together
like they are now, but the record would show this
is the application for the site plan, this is the one for the plat.
They can be linked, associated with each other, but then you don't have the
confusion issue that goes with having them combined in that system. Plus,
sometimes we'll get— we've gotten documents
that are supposed to be part of— I remember this happening, happening, but I
can't remember the project. But the documents for the plat came in with the site
plan. But there was such a mix there that it was hard to tell,
well, this is— we've got enough for the plat without a lot of extra work
to sort through it all, and this is for the site plan. It's much cleaner
just to have this is that and this is this. So my concern is
this enables the developers to play the game. With us.
And I, I think we've already had this discussion a number of times in the
last year about what does the rest of the plan look like,
what is the road flow, what does all those things look like. But if we,
if we give them the preliminary plat, that requirement is
no longer required. They now can, can do their
particular plat without having to contemplate how,
how the road flows. And for me, I would prefer have master site
plan Every time, because that requires them to show the full layout,
phasing, all of those types of things, and then we can come back and have
a chat about your plat. That's my opinion.
I'm going to let that marinate for a minute while I see if anyone came
to speak up. Okay, all right then. In that case,
at 9:50, I will open the public hearing.
Not a chance, no one. All right,
anyone here that came to speak on this item? Seeing no
one, I'll close the public hearing at 9:50 and bring it
back to council and see if they had enough time to, uh— go ahead.
So, Councilmember Wood, I just want to ask you a couple questions. I mean,
Help me understand. I think I understand
what you're saying, but can you just kind of give me maybe a broader
picture view of that? And how would you—
how does it relate to this application? How would you solve this application?
Are you looking at this as something that needs to be denied?
I don't like putting the preliminary plat first or
separating them. I think the two have to be contemplate, especially with the
decisions we've been making lately, we're still asking for them to come and show
us. So rather than changing the language where they can put
one or the other first, where it's not really clear which one has to go
first, they're always going to do the preliminary plat first because they
want to build a drive-through. They don't want
to come and talk to you about how that traffic plan is going to contemplate
through their entire development. How it's going to connect to the other developments adjacent to
it. They want to build their drive-through property.
And I think that there's a lot of negative that ends up happening with that
where we didn't have an opportunity to go,
that's going to cause these other problems.
To me, good planning means let's see the whole picture, then we'll
come back and say, yeah, we're okay with that use for that particular thing.
But the master site plan, you have If they don't know that in advance,
then they aren't really planning out the site. They're just trying to make a buck
on a piece of land. I'm not okay with that. Okay. So you're
just— you don't like paragraph E? Correct. You're okay with
paragraph D?
Being concurrently submitted, sure, because you got to still evaluate
the master, but Yeah, the preliminary plat preceding the master site plan.
I've been no on that for since I was
on the Planning Commission, 'cause it's created additional problems. And we've had many
developers come and do that very, very thing to us. And they do it
whether you're talking about commercial or residential, which they're smart,
by the way. I would do the same thing. But it's not in the best
interest of the city to let them do that, 'cause it's exactly what Brett said.
It piecemeals it.
Okay, so you don't like paragraph D either, either of those paragraphs?
They can be— I mean, they can be reviewed together anyway. We were doing
that before. I don't like putting preliminary plat before master site
plan or allowing the preliminary plat to be approved without the master site
plan. So not a big fan of the language.
All right. If there's no other questions or comments— oh,
go ahead. Yeah,
I'll tell you what I've seen in my career is I've seen plats come
first, honestly, and that the development community actually appreciates
the ability to create lots of land because Because that's what— all
you're doing is creating lots and laying out roads. You're not—
they still have to come in for a site plan.
If you look at the requirements for—
if you look at the requirements in '16 for a preliminary plat, it requires a
traffic plan. It's a traffic report that shows anticipating
trip generation and levels of service. But then you get into the site
site plan, then you have to do a traffic impact study, which is a— and
correct me if I'm wrong, but it's a higher-level study. So they
build on each other. You create the lots,
and then you come back with the site plan and give
more detail. And you can ask Rob, he's talked
to developers, and developers will tell you that they
appreciate the ability late, just simply lay out lots and then be
able to come in and give you some specificity when— after
they've been able to at least lay out the lots.
That doesn't give them the ability to come in and start laying
out shopping centers. They can't do that without a
site plan. So I just want to give you a little context from what I've
seen throughout my career. Thank you.
And then the other issue, again today,
200-acre or so parcel, property owners
are interested in trying to rezone it. The way our
rezone and MDP codes work, you know, that pushes them into an MDP.
But they right now are wanting to leave it as a blank slate.
And then at some juncture when it's ready to plat and/or get a site plan
approval, et cetera, then whoever comes to buy it, speculative will
take care of those details, whether it's one party or multiple parties.
That's— they want that freedom, and it's been— That's by design, though,
Rob. I mean, you're literally talking to the people who wrote that code. We changed
it from how it used to be because all people were doing was coming in,
titling land, and then sitting on it for 8 to 10 years.
And then 8 to 10 years from then, we're going to go take a look
at code that nobody's okay with. So I think,
yes, by design, these things were written the way they were,
and you're right. Brandon, they are opposite to what the development community
is used to on purpose because we were taken advantage of.
In that context, it's good to know. So yeah,
thank you. I'll make a motion.
Is there anybody else had any comments? If not, we'll entertain a motion.
Let me get to the name of this. It's 15F.
Yeah, I move that we deny Item 15F.
Okay, we have a motion. Is there a second?
I'll second it for the sake of discussion. I'll second it.
Okay, uh, we have a motion by Council Member Wood and a second by Council
Member Wright. And, uh, is there questions specific to the motion to
No. Has, has your opinion changed on this? I mean, we spent
quite a bit of time on this particular area. For, for, for For me,
Councilmember Wood, it's about trying to listen to what staff's needs
are on some level. I mean, I want to make that clear.
And finding that balance. My opinion about this has not
changed. I mean, for you, and so that everyone can kind
of hear that. But I think what I need to
understand more clearly, and I think it's going to necessitate probably some broader and
deeper discussions with you, Rob, and perhaps with you, Brandon, is to understand what are
the challenges that you're facing that I'm not aware of. Um,
because by saying no to this, we're telling you we don't want to give you
the tools that you're asking us to give you to be able to process the
applications. And, and I, and, and I, I, I hesitate to
do that to our staff without a firmer understanding
of what the impacts of that are. And Council, point of order,
if I might interject. Maybe you would find agreeable to
pass it minus the wording Offered up as a possibility
with paragraph E, because again, we're trying to separate out master
from standard site plans, and just to put a little cleanup stuff in there too.
Or if there's some wordsmithing that needs to happen, it could come back with the
table. But we do have a motion on the table,
and if we can at least vote on that, if it requires further discussion,
we can. But I think I want to move to—
let's see. So if we deny it, and then the
staff has a revision they'd like to bring back, is that possible?
Yeah. It's definitely possible. I think it's easier to table to
bring back, because of its notice. So— Yeah,
there are obviously costs associated with noticing it again.
So tabling's preferred if you still want to consider something, even if it's
different than what's presented. Okay, were we
here? I think so. Council Member Wright?
I'm gonna vote no on the motion because I want to give staff a
chance to work through this. So I'm gonna vote no and hope that we can
get to a table. Council Member Whitey? No. Council Member
Wood? Yes. Council Member Hewish? No.
Council Member Clark? No. Okay.
Motion fails. And I'll make a
motion, Mayor. It's item 15F as in Frank, right?
Mayor, I move that we table
item 15F, an ordinance of Eagle Mountain City amending the Eagle
Mountain Municipal Code 17.100.040 master site
plans and ask staff
to work with individual council members to,
address the concerns that have been addressed. Second.
Okay, we have a motion by Councilmember Wright and a second by Councilmember Whiting,
and we'll start the vote with Councilmember Whiting. Yes. Councilmember Wood.
No. Councilmember Hewish. Yes. Councilmember Clark. Yes.
Councilmember Wright. Yes. Okay, that motion
passes. We've kind of had a long night here,
going for 3 or 4 hours, so if you guys are all right, we could
take a 5-minute break and then come back for this last item that we
can have David set up. Is that all right? That's good.
Good. Okay.
All right, guys, we'll call it to order and get started.
Okay.
We are moving on to item 16.
And this is a discussion of the speed study results. We've been working on this
for a couple of months, and it's a big document,
a lot to talk about, but one of the last things you get to present.
So, David, it's all you. Thank you, Mayor, Council.
Appreciate your time. Uh, before we start, I just want to say thank you everyone
for the kind words earlier. I really appreciate it. I've been very grateful to
have served in this position as the Assistant City Engineer, and it's
been a privilege, and I wish everyone the best in the future. Um,
quick sidebar, I wanted to make a note about Mayor's comment with our MAG
work. We've been working hard to get Corey Ride kind of pushed up in
the phasing, so that's been huge. The other thing we've been pushing on is,
uh, Lake Mountain Corridor, which was pretty far down the list.
It was a Phase 2 plan when I was at MAG 2 weeks
ago at the RTP workshop. Um, this is still
a draft, but right now Lake Mountain got pulled up.
It's now a Phase 2 plan. Which means it should
be funded in 2037-46.
'37-'46 funded. We're gonna have a bake sale,
move that right on up. So it's still a draft.
Um, we have one more workshop on my last day that I will be attending,
and then it goes for, um, TAC approval and then MPO approval
in November. So this was one, just so you guys understand, is this— there's a
big thread on Facebook. It was some Senator Buss
was talking about how she saw that some funding had moved up.
This wasn't even— the state took this over last year in the session as a
road that will do never, right? It had nothing on
it. Through this work, it wasn't even planned to be funded
past 2055. It has now moved all the way up
to 2036, '37. Now with
that And some of you guys heard, we had that meeting with Representative
Schultz. I think if they
can approve it in this next session as a future funding,
we could pre-build it. So that literally moved it from not
even a, just a wish, to we're gonna build it in
the next couple years because of some of the things that we did. Well done.
It was, that's pretty cool. It's really cool. We've had great
support. UDOT's been very receptive. MAG has been hearing our concerns when we've
been talking to them about that. The state representative's been wonderful.
Also on that list is also Mountain View South as well, because we know we
can't build that to go to nowhere. So that's also important that that happens.
So, so it's a big win for the city. So glad to see that happen.
Moving on to the speed study. So tonight we have Hales Engineering to present
the results of the city citywide speed study. This came about— we
evaluated 35 locations that were identified by the mayor and council
members and residents, and Hales has gone out, collected data,
assessed road conditions, and developed recommendations for speed limits
and potential traffic calming measures. Our goal tonight is for
Hales to present their data, review their recommendations,
and then receive direction from you guys on how to proceed. Now,
we see this as an ongoing process rather than just a one-time study.
Since the study, we've been collecting more information from residents,
Utah County sheriffs as well, and this is something we want to continue on a
regular basis. In addition, we also want to revisit
the locations where we implement traffic calming measures to see,
are they effective and how effective are they? So with that time,
I'm going to turn it over to Hales Engineering to walk through the results.
Thank you, David. My name is Joseph Browning.
And I'm Sean Elliott. And I don't know if you heard this,
but we're looking for a traffic engineer.
I'm a planner, though.
Notice. Okay. You probably know what we're
working on. Yeah. So, so I have to tell you, I came to Hales
a year and a half ago. I worked for MAG for 29 years. I know
all this stuff, all this stuff you're talking about, and I'm grateful
we're talking about local transportation and not regional tonight because we'd be here for
breakfast. So, and Sean, I didn't even recognize
you. You look great. You just look awesome.
Getting out of government service has probably been very good for you.
The stress is gone.
I didn't have— I could sleep.
All right. Okay, so tonight we'll
go through a bit of an introduction to the study. And we'll talk
about some context about how speed limits are set.
We'll talk about the locations that we've analyzed. We'll talk about— we've
got a few proposed speed limit changes. And then we'll
dive into traffic calming measures, different types of traffic
calming measures that we've recommended. And then
where those— and then where we recommend those.
Okay, so we, as David said,
we looked at 35 different segments in the city to
evaluate the posted speed limits and the speeds
on those roads and to look at whether traffic calming
measures are needed. And so we
came back and about half of them ended up
Warranting traffic calming measures,
locations that we recommended them. Some of them have a
greater need than others, and we'll get into that.
So what we typically take a look at when we do
a speed study is we want to look at vehicle speeds.
We laid out tubes at each of these locations. which collect vehicle
traffic, like traffic volumes, vehicle speeds,
and vehicle classification. We had these tubes
set out for 2 consecutive weekdays at each location, which is more
than we typically do, just so that we have a solid
picture of the— Of
how fast people are driving. We want
to look at, as part of that, a crucial
number is the 85th percentile speed. So that's the speed at which 85%
of cars are traveling below that speed.
We try to plan for these thresholds because it represents
the speed that the vast majority of drivers are going at or below.
And we also do a review of the safety, the crash
data. We take the 5 most recent years of crash data and we take a
special look at speed-related crashes,
especially severe speed-related crashes.
And we dive into as well crashes
involving non-motorized users, so pedestrians and cyclists, because they are
more vulnerable.
And speed, the speed of a vehicle
in a collision affects them the most greatly.
We also look at the context surrounding
the area. So the land uses, the access frequency,
the density of driveways. We also take
a look at whether We see much pedestrian or
cyclist activity in the area. And we
look at growth and development in the area. And to this I would add the
functional classification of roadways. So whether it's a local road, a collector,
or an arterial, in terms of
what the road is designed to accommodate,
whether it's designed more for mobility or for access,
we take that into consideration. And then the roadway design.
So if there are areas with limited sight distance, for instance,
Pony Express has some areas with a 35-mile-an-hour
speed limit with some vertical and horizontal curves. And we wouldn't necessarily want to
recommend raising the speed limit there because you
can't really see— you can't see far enough
for a higher speed to be appropriate.
And the roadway condition, we take that into account.
And of course, the existing speed limit.
So this is a map of all the locations that we studied.
These were— we coordinated with the city, with city staff in
determining Where these data
collection points are. So the circles, the dots represent the location
where the data collection actually occurred, and then the
lines beyond that are the broader segments between major intersections
that we looked at.
So how speed limits are set,
guidance on this is has changed in recent years.
Conventional wisdom had been to align speed limits
with the speeds of the vehicles that they're traveling.
But recent industry guidance and based on research
has been that context should be a
more important factor in determining the speed limit.
Recently, UDOT has updated its policy to reflect this,
and since implementing that policy, they've lowered the speed limit on quite
a few roads. In fact, I believe they may have lowered it
on SR 73 in recent years.
We want to look at those factors I mentioned earlier.
That's the driving factor. The speed limit,
and so the goal is still alignment.
We do want vehicle speeds and the posted speed limit to match
as close as we can. In instances where we
feel like a lower speed limit is more appropriate, in that
case, we'd recommend traffic calming measures to aid in the or if
needed, roadway design features to. To help bring those vehicle speeds
into alignment with the appropriate posted speed.
When a speed limit is changed, it doesn't—
what we found is that it typically doesn't have a huge effect on
vehicle speeds. So if
a speed limit is lowered, for instance, We'd want to make sure that we implement
traffic calming measures to go along with that,
to make sure that people are driving at the appropriate
Enforcement is certainly an important part of this,
you know, of alignment, but targeted
enforcement, if— Unless it's kept
up over time, once the
campaign has ended,
the effect wears off. So we want to— so we're
taking a careful look at design features, at traffic
calming, to make sure that these effects are
more permanent beyond just the lowering of the speed limit. Can I ask a question?
Can I just add too that the bottom quote there that talks about,
you know, raising or lowering your speed limit,
you know, when you look at the 85th percentile and you look at the context
and you say this road really should function at let's say 30 miles an hour,
right?
You— there's always that fear that if you raise the speed limit, then people are
going to go even faster. Studies have shown, data has shown that's
not true. People drive what they feel is safe for that road. And it's
how you design the road and the characteristics along that road that encourage
people to either go faster or go slower. And so
going and having a study on a corridor and saying it should be
raised or it should be lowered,
you know, people aren't going to speed just because a new sign went
up, they're not going to slow down because you've lowered the speed limit either.
You've got to do other things too if they feel already comfortable driving
that speed. So yeah, yep, when it's appropriate,
I would like to ask questions about how we can mitigate concerns
for kids crossing streets there, because on the one that
you did suggest to raise, there's 2 schools worth of kids that
are crossing at different points on it, and I just want
to figure out like school zone or what. So I want to come back to
that. When we get to those, we'll go through them.
Yeah. Okay, and this is a map showing where we've
recommended speed limit changes.
The red indicates a lower speed limit and the blue indicates a raising
of the speed limit. And then the green area along
Golden Eagle, there is no posted speed limit along that particular section.
And so we've recommended a Haste speed limit for that.
So diving into the details for some of our justifications
on this. So Silver Lake Parkway
is currently posted at 35.
The speed limit signs are up at the north end by Pony
Express. And There
is no signage between the roundabout
and the southern terminus, but it is assumed
that it is still 35. Given the school
there, the high amount of pedestrian activity,
especially the children, we recommended
And the traffic congestion there. We've recommended lowering the speed limit there to 30.
On Golden Eagle Road, where there is no posted speed limit there,
we've recommended that the speed limit there also be set to 30.
Mm-hmm. And that is because 30 miles per hour is appropriate
for a collector-type road with limited access.
And we wouldn't recommend a higher speed limit because of that similar
pedestrian activity there. Porter's Crossing
Parkway, this is a location where we did
recommend raising the speed limit to 30. It's currently posted at 25.
For similar reasons, it's a collector road with very
limited access.
However, to your point, we did recommend some traffic calming
measures there, some pedestrian safety enhancements,
because of the— in part because of the crash history that's
there. But we'll talk
about that in a bit. And then Airport Road,
we've— it's currently posted at 45. We've recommended lowering that to
40. And there is— at least within the
developed area. And the reason for that is because the
road north of there is— there's a lack of development that
the higher speed makes sense there, but we felt that a lower speed limit was
more appropriate for the developed portion, especially where there's a
crosswalk. I acknowledge that there is a school
zone which does handle the before and after school periods of
children crossing there, but— That's not a school zone. Pedestrians are also able to use
that crosswalk outside of that school period. So that's
another factor into why we recommend a lowering there.
And then last location with the change, we'd recommended
that Pole Canyon Boulevard, east of
Raccoon Lane, so think about Lake
Mountain Road, we recommended lowering
the speed limit to 30. 30 on either side of Lake Mountain Road, at least
for the portion where it's a narrow 2-lane road.
And pedestrian crash history is
part of the reason for that. It's a narrower road.
There aren't any pedestrian facilities on the
west side. And then we did notice some pedestrian activity,
even independent of the charter school there, on the east side. on the east side.
There's also the— there's a large drop
in the road grade that
we feel we wouldn't want any
speed higher than a 30-mile-an-hour limit for that,
so. Thank you.
Okay, so that's the speed limit proposed changes.
There weren't many of them, but, um, and again, I think as Joseph said,
um, you know, looking at the context of the roads, you know,
Golden Eagle, it was designed as a collector road, it's functioning
as a collector road, but there's 2 schools on it, and so there's
got to be some balance, right? And so this portion I'm going to go
through just some of the mitigation issues that we're thinking of.
Like I said earlier, you can change the speed limit, but if— especially if you're
trying to lower the speed limit, you've got to put some things in to try
to slow people down. It isn't going to happen just by signage. So the
way that we looked at this is anything where speeds
were— the 85th percentile speed was 5 miles an
hour or less over the posted speed limit, we're not proposing changes
on though. I think there's one. Generally. Yeah, generally. Yeah, and I'll go
through those. But for the most part, you know, we see that being
close enough to the posted speed limit to not
see that there's, there's a warrant to put in the cost on those.
That and looking at crash rates and so forth also.
And I think the few that we do propose, there's because there are some higher
crash rates. The 5 to 10 miles over the 85th
percentile. Those are the ones that we
have suggestions for that we would call moderate areas.
And then the 10 miles over, and it's one area of town,
you probably all saw it, but those are the ones that
we have to have a pretty good discussion on. So let's
see. So there's 2 ways to slow traffic. There's the easy
ways, the perceptual, the the way they look at things.
A lot of that can be handled with signage, with markings, with feedback
signs, you know, the speed limit, here's what you're going, that kind of thing.
They're usually quick, low cost, so forth. Physical measures,
call them vertical, so speed bumps,
that kind of thing, islands, bulb-outs, and I'll
get into each one of those in a minute. But those are more costly.
They're more permanent. They come with maintenance costs too.
So, and then at the bottom here, combining multiple
speed management measures is usually more successful.
So one area I noticed in town, you mentioned it earlier,
it's Ida Hodges Parkway.
Ida Hodges. Yeah. I've noticed there where you've done the
lane, the funneling with the white Curb lanes on
each side, right? And that tends to slow traffic down, right?
But in that case, on that road being such a— I would
call it a— it's not wide enough really to be a collector,
but it's being used as a collector to get around, right?
So probably you need a few other things in there to help out that too.
OK, so some of the types of calming techniques. We have speed cushions.
You'll notice these are— they're basically a speed hump,
but they cut out 2 places for fire trucks to be able to go down
the middle and not have to be impeded as they are going to a fire.
One downside in Eagle Mountain is that works for your fire trucks, but I
guess it would not work for your ambulances or your police cars. And so— Does
it work for school buses? Does it work for school buses? Are they about the
same size? Same track size? I don't know. I would
imagine they're similar, but I think we would need to look into that.
Our hope would be speed buses would probably— they're not in
need to get somewhere in a hurry, right, like the emergency services.
So what about normal cars, normal trucks?
Their wheelbase is narrow enough that it would require to go over— they couldn't just
line up those and just fly right over? Right. The upside is you can line
up and at least get one tire through, which is what we all do,
right? So this is if your emergency
services are concerned about the speed humps slowing
them down getting places, or speed tables.
When we talked with your staff, it wasn't as much of a concern,
so because it would only be impactful
to the fire engines and I mean, not impactful. Uh, the ambulances,
it wouldn't work. The police cars, it wouldn't work. They'd still have to slow down
to go over these. So, um, if you had ambulances
that could maneuver this, then it would be even a,
a more strong option for the city, I guess, is, is what I'm saying.
So, um, there's also speed tables.
Uh, these are good usually at crosswalks. They're the ones where you,
you go up and then you sort of level out for a bit, and then
you go back down. So a little bit longer. They're not
as— how would you put it? Severe?
Damaging to the vehicle if they accidentally hit it going too fast,
right? But they do get people to slow down. And they also are very good
at crosswalks because they mark the fact that this
is a crosswalk, right? People pay attention that it's there.
So curb extensions, they're also called These
work very well in pedestrian safety in that one,
they make it so that the cross— the pedestrian has less road
to have to cross over, for one. They also allow the pedestrian to stand
out closer to where the drivers can see them. If there's parked cars
that block where the pedestrian is, they can't be seen. And so— and they also
allow drivers to feel a little bit more narrow, and therefore they
helps slow drivers down. So probably one of the better options
for you. A lateral shift.
This is showing, and I hope you can see this, but basically
what you're doing is with paint, and also there are some islands in here in
the middle of the road and even on the shoulder to sort of aim cars
to go do a curvature as they could drive down the road. We're not talking
Lombard Street in San Francisco, but It's enough to get people to
slow down. When I talk about Golden Eagle Way or Road,
that's one place where we suggest these. And there's a straightaway on that
road where you have the highest speeds. And the lower speeds
are where the road is bending. So this would be one of those applications.
Landscaping. So a great example in Eagle Mountain, in fact,
you've got a lot of streets this way, but Silver
Lake Parkway. On the diagonal portion of Silver Lake,
it's sort of got a bend to it, but you also have a lot of
trees, and that breaks down the visual view of drivers. Now, you could argue
it makes it less safe for pedestrians because there's more things in the way,
but in this case, I just
drove it today. The speed limit's 35, and I felt comfortable. Thank you.
people around 33. And part of that's
the bend, and part of that's just I can't see very far,
right? And so landscaping can be an
item to help break down speeds.
Curb gutter sidewalk, of course, that's another way when you have a road that's not
very well defined, defining it can
help bring down speeds. But it also gives
you a safe place for your pedestrians. pedestrians. The radar feedback
signs, there's sort of mixed opinions on these.
They seem to work better in residential streets than, say,
Pony Express Parkway or major roads.
They sort of blend into the background after a while with that much traffic driving
on it. Also, they work better— you
can choose to put them in permanent locations, but Sometimes moving them around is
another way to get people to notice that,
oh yeah, I need to go slower on this road. They work better if there's
a police officer right behind them. Yeah, that's true too. Some of them
actually flash red and blue, but I guess in Utah that's illegal. But those ones
get you noticing, right? Optical speed
bars. This is relatively a newer application.
UDOT's started using these on more curvy roads, but what
they do is again they slim the lane down. They also alert you
to the fact there's a curve ahead, and that gets you slowing down. And so
we have a few places we'd suggest this. Pavement markings, just basically
the speed limit in the road. Something I don't see as much
in Utah, but— Edge striping. This is the one
I was talking about on Ida— Or
Ira Hodges. Yes, sorry. I used to know all the streets
everywhere, and now I'm starting to get old. But anyway,
narrowing the perceived width of the road down just with striping actually
gets people to slow down. Curve warning signage is good,
and then flexible delineator posts. This is showing the speed
limit sign in the middle of an island. It's a A cheap
way to do an island in this case. Obviously, in fact,
you've got them on Major Street where
you've got the pedestrian crossings and you've got these islands with the paint
in the road. That's an inexpensive way to do it. And they are noticeable.
Obviously, if you have curbing, that even gets people's attention even more.
And this is just a diagram talking about a summary of
each one of those that I talked about. I'm not going to go through each
one unless you guys want me to. It's in your report.
OK, so no traffic calming needed or recommended.
These are those areas that we collected data where the
speeds were under 5 miles an
hour or less.
Within 5 miles an hour of the recommended speed limit. Right,
right. So, um, and so, so our recommendation
is these speeds seem appropriate for those streets.
Um, we didn't have crash history that really supported
that, that there were needs on those streets. So, um,
these are the tables just showing each one of those locations. Um,
and so you'll notice the posted speed limit— NP means there is
no posted speed limit on that street. We assume it's probably 25
in most locations. But we did not find any signs on those roads.
And then the 85th percentile, so again, that's that speed with the majority
of people that you would call your non-reckless
drivers are driving. And so as you
can see, in the case of all of those, they're within that 5-mile-an-hour range.
And then the crash history, these are speed-related crashes
on those roads. And so again, The highest
one was on Aviator Avenue. And again, that is
an arterial road, I believe, in the city.
I think it might be a collector. Right. It has a lot of traffic on
it. So you would expect a few more crashes on that road.
Any questions on these ones before I move on?
Okay. Okay. 11 locations with moderate
needs. These are the ones, again, that 5 to 10 miles over the posted speed
limit. We put
crash history may support adjustments, and I'll go over those here in a minute.
The proposals that we have for mitigation projects
are about $400,000 for these roads. And again,
in the next month, we'll— we have one other element of this study we're
still going to work on now that we've gotten through this part. We do get
to write you up a nice study that'll have all the details of all of
this. So let's see, Mustang Way,
we're proposing radar feedback signs and
landscaping. Now, I'll say landscaping on that road would help a
ton, 'cause it's just straight as can be. But you also have your limitations
that you don't own that land, right? Part of it's in HOA.
So The hard part with that
road is it really does act as a collector road, even though it's not
really a collector road. So, um, and so keeping it at that 25
mph is tough, right? Um, we, we put
in there curb gutter sidewalk. Again, this area of the city,
we did witness a lot of school children, and they're walking everywhere
because there's nowhere to walk. And so, you Having a
sidewalk or a trail or something on that road would probably go a long ways.
Ranch Road south of Cedar, we put in there curve
warning signage because it is curvilinear,
optical speed bars on those
curves. Yeah, there were a couple of crashes where
people took the curve at too fast of a speed and
went off the road. And so we recommended some signage
there to alert people of the curve. So you think the curve warning and
the optical speed bars will be enough to— So the curve
warning, at least the fact that they crashed on the curve, tells us that
they didn't realize the curb was there, right? And so having something
to warn people that there's a curb there, and then also the
optical, the lines also help alert them to
the curve. That's what we're seeing in that area.
The speed is really, you know, you look at the 85th percentile,
it's not, it's actually only a mile.
The road was just not designed well right there, just where the hill and then
it dips down and it turns sharply. And as we'll talk about here
in a minute on the next list of projects, that whole area is Cedar Pass
Ranch. It's that wide open, spaces, right? And that's what
encourages people to speed or, you know, to drive
the speeds that they're going. This road is different just because it's not a very
long portion and it's got a big curve in it, and that's why they're going
slower. But we are proposing, you know,
measurements here to— mitigations to, you know,
fix the curve, basically. Yeah, draw attention to it. Right,
right. Cedar Pass Road North of Valley Drive
speed cushioning. Cushion, landscaping,
and again, landscaping, I understand this area is, again,
that wide open feeling is what we're saying is part of the issue there.
You could also do a lateral shift, which was again that using islands
and paint to actually sort of give a bend to the road type
of thing. It requires some repaving to get that.
Right, especially since that's such a narrow pavement width. So you
feel the speed cushion would be more appropriate than a speed table at that location?
Yeah, for the purposes of allowing a fire truck or
similar vehicle to pass through. Okay, and so the speed cushion,
even if someone uses one tire where there's an opening,
it will still slow the vehicle down generally because they got to go up over
the other, right? It slows them down. I would say not as much, meaning,
at least from my experiences, At least, especially if I'm a
truck, right? And again, this is something the city— give
us direction, because we could say there's no reason
to do speed cushions if your emergency services are okay with
speed tables, right? We were basically
saying this is an option, right?
Okay, so it's really just the speed of a fire truck getting somewhere. Right,
more than anything. And it's police, ambulance,
fire truck. Fire truck is fine. It's the ambulance
and the police that are the 2 that would be impacted by a
speed cushion, or speed— either one.
Yeah. So I want to be clear. So you're saying the speed
cushion's the only vehicle that that really is designed to let through
there without any impact is the fire truck? That's it? Or garbage
trucks as well. Vehicles with that
kind of— That wider footprint. There are ambulances that have wider
footprints, but just not here. I'm almost more open to the speed table,
but I guess we— yeah, we could think about
that. Something to note too
with the speed cushions, another drawback here are motorcycles.
That's another con of having the speed cushions. With the tables, you can
stop all traffic. So something to consider as well.
Right.
So— Sorry, I didn't mean to interrupt. No, that's fine. No, and in fact,
part of your recommendation, if that's the route you want to go, we'd be more
than happy to make those changes. So let's see, Ranches Parkway
north of Half Mile Road. Um,
a law enforcement pullout? Correct. Yes.
So we, we, we tried to look at, uh, ways to, to calm traffic on,
on Ranches Parkway. And, uh,
uh, the— there's no shoulder there currently.
Um, there's, there's already landscaping. So there's, there's a
lot of those, those kind of standard features we, we'd already recommend. Uh,
pedestrians have— are, are separated. Um, but it occurred
to us that, uh, it's It's very difficult
for law enforcement to police that road as they
would a normal major road, simply because they don't have a place to stop and
wait. I know I've heard they're currently using turn lanes,
like left turn lanes, to kind of camp out there and
watch for speeders, but the idea of this is we would give
them a better, more permanent location for them to So
even when that road network becomes 7 lanes, which is what it's slated
to become, should we be planning some of those
police pullouts in addition to that? That's my question. Yes,
so eventually with Phase 2, we will have those shoulders. We'll have that.
And the nice thing is, you know, when we do the half-mile signal, we'll have
the traffic signal there. But this is kind of just— we wanted them to do
the study without, you know, interference from us and present the data. And so All
right. See, David, you know I'm getting ahead of the game, right? I'm glad you
are. We didn't look at the 7-lane cross-section. So I was aware
of that, though, and I just spaced it as we did this. But putting on
my regional hat just really quick, the fact that that road is just
inundated with traffic, and it is— you have so few
ways in and out. And I'm sure your citizens are frustrated
with everything that goes on trying to get in and out of this
place, right? That's part of why people are speeding on these roads too, is they're
trying to get somewhere as quick as they can because they can't get anywhere quick,
right? So once you do finally get
the mature system, transportation system, and not everything
has to focus on these roads because you have a freeway and so forth,
hopefully that will help change, right? All right.
Stonebridge Lane. This is up at the curve right
by the charter school? Yeah. A radar feedback
sign, edge striping, that's to narrow the perception of the width of the
road. Speed cushioning and landscaping could be other options.
And again, we can change that to a speed table if that would work.
Most of that road already has enough bends and so forth in it that
traffic calms itself, right? It's just that one area.
Golden Eagle Road. Let's see,
east of Silver Creek. Radar feedback signs,
lateral shift with flexible delineator posts, curb extensions. And I'm
going to go more into depth on that road here because I know there's a
lot of interest on that road. You know, our 85th percentile on that
road by the school was 30,
32 miles an hour, but on the straightaway that's
east of the school, it was up to 38 miles an hour. So,
um, and I'll just go over that here in a minute. Porter's Crossing
Parkway, um, again, we're proposing some curb extensions
at the crosswalks to, to make those crossings less
that the, the children have to cross. That, that road,
it's, it's a collector road, and it's, you know, it, it— you have a whole
lot of, you know, the, the median down the middle, the trees, all of that's
helping to keep keep it slower. But 25 is
not the appropriate speed for that road. And so let's
put some more safety into it. Pony Express,
south of Red Hawk Ranch Road, a law enforcement pullout.
Again, that's a hard road. I mean, it's just— you
got a lot of traffic and a lot of people go fast on that road.
So there's not much else we can think of
to help with that road other than enforcement or getting your major
road system built out.
Pony Express west of Hidden Valley Parkway, and again, this is
law enforcement pullout landscaping.
Airport Road east of Barnett Peak and Fiona Street, this was that portion that
we just talked about lowering the speed limit on. We also are proposing
curb extensions, optical speed bars,
pavement speed marking, all those things to help alert drivers to slow
down. Quick question, is that where the crosswalk is
to the school? Correct. Yeah. Okay.
Yeah. Oh, there's Major Street was the last one there.
Oh, I'm sorry, I missed one. Okay, a Major Street speed table was proposed
on that road. At the crosswalk? Yeah, yeah.
Okay, Golden Eagle Road, this is just the focus— Can I ask a question about
that Major Street? Sure. Because I noticed that it this Major Street, the posted speed
limit is 25 and the 85th percentile is 31, and the other one on Ira
Hodges was 25 and 30, and you're recommending completely
different approaches to that. And I'm curious, aren't they
similar in the traffic that they're dealing with in those areas,
especially with the volume with those schools, with the school there?
They are, and the reason why we have recommended the speed table
on Major Street Major Street is
because the speeds were 31 close to this crosswalk where
the data was collected. And so we felt the speed table was an
appropriate measure for that crosswalk in particular, whereas I believe the
crosswalk on Ira Hodges is at the 4-way stop,
if I'm not mistaken.
Right. there's no pedestrian crossing mid-block on
Ira Hodges. One thing we did talk about with staff,
we didn't put it in here, but the fact that Ira Hodges
is so narrow through that neighborhood, and it's
going to a school, but it's also going to a high-growth area,
it might behoove the city in the future once, I think it's called Spring— Springwater.
Yeah, that road, once it's put through, It might be good to close
off Ira and make it so everybody takes that road from Pony instead of
the shortcut through the neighborhood. But so,
yeah, but you know, that's just something to think about for that because
that road, it just does not feel like it should be a major— it's
not major, but it does act as a collector and you have a lot of
school traffic on that road. Okay, Golden Eagle.
This is just a diagram of some of the things we're proposing along that corridor
to bring people down to that 30 mph speed
limit. Like I said, the 2 purple dots, the one closer to the school,
the 85th percentile was 32 mph, which is pretty
close to that speed limit. The other dot was 38. So people
really do speed up in that straightaway. And so the
lateral shift in the road there In the straightaway and then doing the
bulb-outs, we think would help narrow that road down to bring
people down to that more appropriate speed. And then the
radar feedback signs there by the school are
some of our proposals for that.
Okay, these are the last roads, the ones with
the greatest needs. And we went back and forth, and so we're going to sort
of have that back and conversation with you on this, but as you know,
this area, the roads are, they're narrow,
right? But they're not narrow for the
area, right? They feel like a rural-type road,
right? Yeah, I would add to that. It feels like
if you accidentally left the road in your vehicle,
like it would be pretty low consequence. And so as a result, it feels
like you can go much faster. Right, right. So I drove on them today,
and this isn't being recorded, but I know—
I, yeah, I know, I'm joking.
You know, I got myself going on one stretch of— I can't
remember the name of the road, the long road there going east and west.
Ranch Road. Ranch Road. You know, I got up to 37 at
one point. Most of the roads I was going around 32.
Just feeling comfortable driving through that. And that's what I was trying to test,
right? There were other people by me going faster
than that, right? Last night I was driving on one of those roads at 27,
and the car behind me rushed around me and passed me. Oh wow,
yes. The same thing happened to me. I was driving about 30 a couple weeks
ago, and the big SUV came around and passed me, probably doing about 50.
So these roads in red all had those 85th percentiles 11 miles
over the posted speed limit. You know,
35, 37 miles an hour was the average.
What that tells you is people feel comfortable driving that
way. And part of that is that wide-open feel, the rural
feel.
You know, they just encourage that. Even though there's a residential neighborhood, now the
homes are far apart. which also encourages that. So my
wife's from Blackfoot, Idaho, out in the farm area.
Nobody would go 25 in these kind of roads, right? That's just not what they
do. And the crash history, there's not much crash history in
this area, and I'll go over that here in a minute. So what you're saying
is we should, we should entitle a bunch of condominiums in that area.
That's what I'm hearing you say. Is this being recorded?
The comms team's over there. They're clipping it to put it on.
We could put a natural gas facility in over there.
Okay. So just going through each one of these corridors then, you'll notice
the posted speeds, the 85th percentile speeds, showing how all
of these people are driving faster.
So we put in recommendations for mostly
all of these were either speed cushions or speed tables. And again,
we can we can adjust that. These very straightaway
roads again, those lateral shifts would help, but they would probably
be more costly because you don't have as much pavement. You'd have to actually add
pavement to make that work.
Let me just talk about this here. So one
thing we noticed lower traffic counts. So this example project
is on. Canyon Wash Drive, the orange circle there.
That location, we had 560 trips a day on that road.
That's a pretty low amount of traffic, right? It suggests that
most of our traffic is internal, meaning you're not getting a lot of cut-through
trips through here. Now, we did this during the week,
right? I think it was on a— It was on a weekday, yeah. Wednesday,
Thursday type of thing. You know,
we've heard that on Sundays there's particular groups of peoples and
times that there's a lot of people going all at once, right? Sure.
Yeah. I know this was independent data and stuff, and they
say, well, that makes it look like local traffic
because of the trips per day. But you also need to know that there's only
about 8 homes on there. So that means that's about
30,000 times the amount of people that actually live there. So it's a cut-through.
Right. So even though you're saying that's a, a low trip count,
there's places where there are condominiums that have lower trip count than that.
It's because— so I don't know that that's low trip count
to me. And Canyon Wash Drive is a,
is a, is a pretty major access to this, to this neighborhood. So there
are, there are at least a few homes. So a typical home produces
about 10 trips per day, just, just for context. So you think
about how many homes this this particular connection serves. And it's
likely that there is some cut-through traffic, but what we're
seeing is that a lot of it is local residents. This was the highest
count of all the roads in the neighborhood, meaning you can see as you
work your way towards 73, this is the corridor people
are using. And I'm going to tell you, because we're all very familiar with that,
at least the majority of us are. They all live there. 3 of
us seated here live in that area. have for decades.
Right. And so what we see is, at least what I see, is I see
North Ranch traffic trying to get to Pony Express Parkway, and it's just
a connector. That— it's a collector road that brings traffic through there in both directions.
Right. And we're not saying there's none, but it's still a
pretty low amount, meaning these roads, even being narrow as they are, they're designed
for more than that. Half Mile Road, that's me. I'm on that one.
So anyway, so let's
see. I put on here similar rural areas in the Benjamin area
have 30-mile-an-hour roads. So the issue here is we can put in traffic
calming. It's going to be costly for this area.
Getting people to go 25 miles an hour when they're going 38
miles an hour might be tough. And it might be you have to put a
lot of traffic calming in. to get it to work. So the fact
that the accident rate's pretty low, you know, and the— there
are a few streets in there where you're on hills and you're on curves and
so forth. People aren't going that fast on those portions
of those roads, right? You got pedestrians, nowhere for
pedestrians to walk other than you got wide shoulders, right, or wide
areas. I think I saw signs up there's horses, you know, people ride
horses and so forth. So this is a hard one,
right? Because, you know, it seems like 37
miles an hour seems too fast, right? So there should be some things
done in this area. But is 25 the
appropriate speed limit too? So we leave that one a little open-ended as
part of our report on that.
So our next steps, obviously we'd like to get
some feedback from you tonight, and that will help us finalize our
report. We are working on the
final draft of the speed study in general. We do have one other
part of this study, the Scenic Mountain to Talus Ridge connection.
They want us to do modeling to find out the impacts of making that connection.
We put that off until after we we got this portion done. So we're going
to start working on that. Have you— did any of your modeling on Silver,
uh, Silver Lake Parkway, or did any of that include a connection
to Saratoga Springs? Because it did. Yes. So you contemplated
a connection to that high school? Yes, yes, yes. Yeah, and that,
that all was done in the Silver Lake Parkway study we did just,
just recently. And carried over to this one. And carried over to this one.
Um, and then, yeah, and then once we're done with all that, we'll be back
to present the findings. So we might fly David
back from Florida. He can come.
Okay. Yeah, we'd love to open it up to questions.
Lots. So the total cost to put all
of that into place is about $400,000?
Oh, is it $860,000? Oh, it was the first section. $400,000 for the moderate or
something. Okay, the 2 sections. $460,000 for the— I told you
guys it would be $1 million. Yeah. Oh yeah. But that's a good use of
funds. That's about $800,000, yeah. Now again,
you— and especially in Cedar Pass Ranch, you could probably
go crazy putting a lot of things in it. You know what I mean?
To try to bring it down to 25, it might be a little bit more
than what we proposed. But, you know,
I think what we would— recommend in that area is do a
more detailed study of how far—
if you were to do speed tables, how far apart should they be? You know,
where would you locate them? You know, you have to also do site
treatments where you put speed tables because people will just drive around it if you
don't have anything to block them. I guess you could throw a big boulder in
or something. Half the neighbors have already done that.
Probably recommend a sign or something. Yeah, a horse hitch,
right? A question on the— while we're talking about speed tables.
So I had in my head that the cost of a speed table was $70,000
or $80,000, and you had $8,000. Are we talking
like a fully developed crosswalk cement?
That's a big range in cost. I mean, we could do a lot of speed
tables for $8,000 apiece.
What we've seen from FHWA, I think this is specifically referring
to the asphalt ones. Yeah. It's about
$8,000 from what I've seen. And does it matter if
you do asphalt or cement, or asphalt
works fine? Yeah, asphalt works fine. I suppose
the advantage to cement is that it probably draws It
shakes out more. Yeah, yeah.
There's less maintenance too. But the concrete has a higher upfront
cost, but then there's less maintenance where the asphalt— Over time.
There's a lot of slowing down, braking there. Sometimes you get ruts on
the approach and then hard acceleration. The concrete, you don't get that as much.
Yeah. And a lot of times at speed bumps and speed tables,
the lines start to wear out, and whether you're on top of that or not
as a city— There's cities that aren't on top of it, right? So in Cedar
Pass, where you have like more country roads, maybe less traffic,
you might go asphalt. Yeah, yeah.
So just a couple comments. You guys hit pretty much the same places that we
had talked about. They're all by schools. We actually
have funded speed tables in our last budget to
stop the traffic because we— The other 15% that's
going faster is a problem when you have 1,000 students at each one of those
elementary schools. I'd like to know your opinion on that.
One of the examples you showed on Golden Eagle,
you have where you narrow the crosswalk basically. You bump
it out. Right there, the bulb-outs. The speed table is a
preference of mine because I intend for them to stop.
We want them to stop. We've already had some crosswalks
crossing guards who have been hit, unfortunately not reported. You guys
are looking at crash scenes, and I'm like, if they don't report those things,
then how do you even know that that's an issue there? Right, yeah. But I
mean, I actually saw it happen, and they didn't report it.
And each one of the schools could benefit
from the requirement of all the cars to have to stop to
allow them to safely cross. Cars are pretty bold. when they get
impatient, and as soon as there's a break, they're like, they'll just get out of
the way kind of a thing. And I just, I'm not willing to risk little
kids, especially when we have so many of them at each one of these schools.
So in the locations, Silver Lake Parkway,
Golden Eagle, the corner right there is Silver Lake Elementary School,
Brookhaven Elementary School, which is right at Seedling and Golden Eagle,
Pony Express, That's on Smith. Smith Ranch, you identified
that. Ira Hodges goes to Mountain Trails Elementary
School, which a lot of kids, it's a problem there with people speeding through there
at the pickup and drop-off times. I wonder, we didn't really
look, have you looked at Eagle Valley? I don't know if that area has the
same problem, but it's just right up the street here from City Hall.
Hidden Hollow you hit, and you hit Desert
View. And Blackridge. You literally hit every single one of the elementary
schools. Right. We look at it and say, if it's not a collector
road, let's put a speed table on it.
And the ones that are bigger than that, love to know what your ideas are
when you have a Pony Express and you can't really stop all
the traffic because you need to have the flow through there. What are some better
pedestrian options for them other than just turning lights on and hoping people
don't run through the 4 lanes?
Yeah, that's a good question. I think on a
road like Pony Express, you could consider something called a— it's
programmed into the signal, it's called a leading pedestrian interval. So what it
does is it— the pedestrian, like the walk
sign comes on a few seconds before cars are able to start moving.
So it prioritizes the pedestrians,
and they start crossing the crosswalk,
and it gives vehicles a chance to— yeah, yeah,
give them greater visibility. That's something you could do
there. And you're talking— are you talking
specifically at crossings with traffic? So Hidden Hollow Elementary, you have
Pony Express at Hidden Valley Parkway.
Then you also have the one that was over on Airport Road. He's talking about
basically school crossings. Yes. Yeah. So I
guess my thought on that, and I think Commissioner Clark asked
this earlier, but, you know, where you have school crossings now
that are signed, you have the 20-mile-an-hour flashing light. I mean, you have the safety
elements that are put in already for those locations.
If you're in a residential area, and speed table is
something that you want, I don't see a problem with that, right?
Something like on Golden Eagle that is a collector road,
that's harder, right? The speed tables don't work well on those type of roads only
because, again, you design that road a certain way.
If you put enough speed tables on it, you're bringing it back down. It was
one of those unfortunate accidents of the school district chose
without any input from anybody. Because initially,
I think everybody here would agree that Golden Eagle should have been through street,
right? Then they threw 2,000 elementary students on that road,
right? That— I mean, if you guys were over there, you probably saw them spilling
like ants out of there. And they do. They literally just cross wherever they want.
Yeah. So maybe we need to change the designation of that road
through there, because the only way that we're going to be able to prevent
the accident that's going to happen, I I mean, you saw them speed up as
soon as they get past Silver Creek Way. And once the other
side opens up, it's going to go the other direction too. So yeah,
maybe you're not wrong. Yeah, it's listed as a collector road,
but maybe it shouldn't be now because of that. It's also designed
as one though, is the problem, right? So having more driveways,
having, you know, not being as long as it
is, not going from point A to point B, That's why people use
it like they do, right? And so now that it is a collector, now if
you want to declassify it, make it a local street, you got
to do more than just take it off the map, right? If you put
the speed tables on it where the crossing is for both the elementary schools,
that mitigates a lot of that though,
doesn't it? It would certainly help, yeah,
yeah. And you could— I think that you could Keep a
collector designation and still have the speed tables there.
Typically, we try to avoid that, but if you've got,
especially in situations where you have a stop sign or at
a roundabout or a traffic signal, things like that,
you know, maybe speed tables are a good option
for crosswalks there. Another option too would be to have bulb-outs.
but also have a refuge median in the middle.
Again, that narrows the road down and alerts people that they got to slow
down for this area. Um, so that's another option that we could propose
in that. So I— sorry. Oh, go ahead.
Because it's kind of piggybacking off of Council Member Wood.
Um, when there are speed tables on places
like Golden Eagle, do you see people slow
down for the speed table and then gun it after to make up the difference.
That's the thing I'm worried about, because he said the kids spill
out like ants and they just cross wherever. That's exactly what's happening,
and I worry about the gunning it after to make up the difference.
So, so the same thing happens when you put in stop signs that aren't
warranted. Yeah, drivers typically will
then speed up because they felt like you've slowed them down unfairly. Right?
So if you only have one speed table, and again,
as we said, you've got to initiate a lot of different things.
The proposal that we put with the lateral shifts to slow people down,
all of that was to work together, right? Yeah. Now again,
we could put in a speed table. I wouldn't recommend
it for a collector road, but we can do things. I think the bulb-outs at
the crosswalks, maybe a median, that would help.
In Europe, I've seen on fail videos,
but they're awesome, those arms that come down
in certain places where there's crosswalks and stuff like that. Is that something that's done
anywhere in the United States? I'm not aware of any.
Is it something legally we could do? That's a train, Melissa. I know,
but listen, I will do what it takes to keep kids safe,
but we also need to keep the roads. Like, so I'm just wondering, is that—
no, I, I take it back to the team and see what they say.
Yeah, yeah, it seems like one of the hardest issues is
all the parents parking, and then you have kids running out behind cars,
and, you know, and, and that's the school district.
And so I'm gonna, I'm gonna throw this out there. I mean, here's an idea
that I've thought of, especially in those areas during school pickup and drop-off.
Why not do some of those bulb-outs so that you create some pedestrian
crossings that, in my opinion at least, become much safer and designate
parking, parallel parking along the side of those
collectors to reduce the width and the magnitude of those roads?
So even if it's designated as a collector at certain times of
day when, when the kids are there, perhaps you could, you could narrow
those areas down. down in a certain section of that road where the schools
are at. That's exactly what happened at Smith Ranch. You guys probably saw Smith Ranch.
It used to, it used to be the only way to get out
of that neighborhood because Porter's Crossing
didn't go all the way down. And because there were so many cars on that
road, people would creep along it because you didn't have any other choice.
So I mean, maybe that's what we need to do. If only we had
a, engineer that could just stay.
One road that came up earlier today from one of our residents, Jay Johnson,
on Lake Mountain Road. Was that in here anywhere?
No. That wasn't in here. I wonder if there's
some follow-ups maybe. So we can add that. That's unfortunately
become a speed issue in the last few weeks. It's a newer development.
Yeah. So we've noticed with the data, on traffic picking up. Cars have
found out, I don't need to wait on Pony, I can blow through Parkway Fields,
so I can go up that way. So we've just started noticing— Well, and that
one had to do with the data center put a new entry on the expansion
phase that wasn't being built, and they made an entry off the
road off that side on the east side of the property that
is Lake Mountain Road. So that's what
we want to look at next this summer, next hot topic to look at.
Yeah, but these are good ideas. I mean, we could probably figure out some of
these, these other areas. So some things that I like
personally that's different than these that I didn't see recommended anywhere— can
you go back to those pictures that show like the pop-outs and the— right there.
Whoa, you were on them fast. Sorry. Yeah, I love
those because I think I'm one of those guys that
like uses— I straddle the line all the
time because I always have a trailer, so you need more room to turn.
And I tell you, when there's something in the road, you're going to slow
down because— Do you mean this trailer? Yeah.
So to me, I think those are as effective as even
a speed table or other things. And it's way cheaper, way easier.
And so I would love to see those incorporated in some
of those areas rather than some of the other things. And then the
other thing that I had a question on And
David knows this because I specifically spoke to him. You mentioned
right off the get-go that one of the reasons we have people speeding on these
roads is because of the traffic issues out here
and they can't get anywhere quick enough. So where
I take issue is, is those, those collector roads are supposed to go faster,
which means that how do we keep— for instance, I'm going to use the
ones that I— that we all know are the, the hot topic, but I'll use
Airport Road. You mentioned lowering the speed limit. I'm completely
against that for this reason. I want to raise the speed limit so we can
go somewhere faster. But then, okay, well, how do we take
care of those kids? Why did we not do any tunnels? Because that's going to
be— that's programmed to be a 122-foot
road. I mean, that's one of our major, major— 176.
176. That's Airport Road.
You're right. That road, when it becomes the regional road that it is going to
be, you don't want a crosswalk right there. So why would that not
go under? And I didn't see that anywhere. And I only use that one as
the example because I think the Golden Eagle one is the same thing.
I think that if we've got a pedestrian problem, go under or over.
I don't think— because that's a road that's supposed to go on.
No, that's a good question. We could certainly
put that in there. I think the reason why we Didn't
in this case is because those do tend to be very expensive. I would
need to look at them. So is one life. And I think we— and
because I know these guys are getting— maybe Brad or somebody's over there having convulsions
or something, but because there's utilities, so going under it might be a problem.
So I want to make sure that I'm not just asking.
But I think that it's— we've got to think about, well,
how do we— can we keep those people going and still keep people safe?
And yes, they're expensive, but they're not too expensive that we shouldn't do it if
it's right. If it's right, it needs to be done. One thing, we looked at
the here and now, so that future road, we weren't really going
out to the big projects. But obviously, as you
build those projects, you need to look at— Yeah,
that was the goal. For this scope, it's more of the immediate conditions, not at
the 7-lane situations and these things. We can definitely look at that as we continue,
but It was more, let's fix the problem right now. What's the issue? How can
we stop it today? Yeah, I agree. As we went back and forth
on should Airport be a lower population, a lower speed.
Yeah, a lower population would work. In that— yeah,
I know. In that we know that road is going
to be a major facility. In fact, watching all of your problems regionally,
I think of how are you going to connect to the South Valley when that
area grow someday. But that's another topic. So anyway,
yeah, that's, uh, one thing I was going to point out pushing through
these pictures, the bulb-outs. Another benefit of bulb-out is people
have to slow down to make turns, which again then helps slow
down traffic overall. And they have to slow down and actually look. Do you have
a boat or an RV or a horse trailer? I'm just asking. No.
Yeah, that's why I hate those. I know you can't turn.
I can't make a right-hand turn if that's there with, with my horse trailer,
but not without cutting into this other lane over here. And specifically,
Council Member Wright and I, uh, worked on our street
standards and we made them wider. They begged us to do these in areas
and we said no way. There may be some areas where
it's appropriate, Mayor, but I think they should be limited. Maybe it's that school
zone. I think there are areas where where they could be appropriate. There's no question.
But I'm not completely against them. I just want
to— if you put that there and a sign, well, at least put the sign
back so I can jump over the curb, because I pull a trailer. The school
zones are great places for those, though. That's where these guys— they were recommended.
They have those in Daybreak all over the place, and Daybreak traffic is
slow. So I'm just going to say school buses. If you have a road this
wide, sure, it makes sense. But let's say that that bulb goes
out and you've got a narrow road. The bus is getting— the back tires are
going over that. They can't get wide enough to get through. We would not propose
you build them that trucks and trailers could not get around
them, right? I mean, they do— Well, I'm just telling you the flip
side. There'd be an appropriate design vehicle that we'd want to design those to accommodate.
Yeah. Mayor, we're going to have to send you back to the CDL driving school.
That's what I think.
That's funny.
Because I pull a trailer and I can usually get
around those without an incident. Don't you got to be able to see?
So it's 11:18 PM, just FYI.
What's the next step? Yeah. He was the one who wanted to raise
the speed limit. I was
just going to ask that same question. You know, we've all kind of given
some different ideas and suggestions, and now
is it go back and incorporate some of those and come back with a final
phase, or what? Do you have a couple more comments over here, I think?
No, I just think the next phase is like to fund it.
Next council meeting, can we bring this up for a vote? So really, just let
me ask this question. Is there anybody that sees anything that they've recommended
that you say we absolutely should not do that? I'm still
yes for speed tables at school zones, unless they're on Pony
Express or Airport Road.
So Britt wanted to talk about something on the speed cushions real quick.
As you're deliberating and kind of mucking through what you want to do,
I would just disregard speed cushions. It doesn't—
it's going to be negligible for us. We're still going to have to slow down.
The second that we run a fire truck through one of those and tip
it because they didn't angle it right or they had an issue coming
in, it's all going to go away anyway. So if you're going
to go, like, go, yeah, speed tape,
whatever you do, it's going to have an effect on 911 response and service.
I would probably recommend against the arms. That's the one thing that will
absolutely impede us from going anywhere. Just push through them.
Yeah, those are cheap to replace. Yeah, that is true.
Have you seen the bills? So regardless,
just, I would say speed cushions, don't even consider that
in your deliberations. I'm glad, I'm glad for that information because that was the
way I was leaning, thinking that we should, if we're going to do a speed
table, we should just not do speed cushions.
It doesn't benefit us. That's helpful. And at the end of the day,
you're going to get more problems from a speed— I've had
a couple areas where we've had speed cushions, and there are more
problems that it creates than it helps. And you
get pedestrian cars that will rip through and try to kick it,
and you'll get one angle up and 2 tires off.
And it's— yeah, we have plenty of job security.
We have plenty of idiots that are out there. So.
Anyway, that would be my consideration on the cushion piece.
Just don't worry about it. Mayor. Go, Melissa, go.
Mayor, um, I would like my fellow council members to
think about prioritizing at least one tunnel.
Um, I know that that wasn't any of your recommendations, but I know that in
certain school zones, that's really going to be the only, like,
true fix. And I know that Saratoga was able to do one.
with some funding from the school district, some funding from UDOT,
and I think Saratoga or MAG, something like that, I can't remember.
Where? But I think what we need to do
is get an idea on cost and say, okay,
every 2 years we're gonna put in a tunnel someplace, because we
can't fix the really dumb locations that schools were put,
and we can't change the fact that we have a bazillion children,
But we could start saving up basically to
make sure that we could put some of those in.
And I know that Council Member Wood's working with
John, just working on trying to get something going with
the state for requirements for when schools go into areas like this.
So anyway, that's— I like all the things we've talked about,
but I'd really like for us to think about Funding
a tunnel, because I think that's going to be one of the only true fixes
we have. I think we're all talking about the same location.
I think Airport Road, we'd like to know what the cost of that would be.
Okay, so on your arterial, probably. So Pony Express there
also, would you say? Well, yes, we should have one
at Hidden Hollow. Yeah, we should have one at Silver Lake,
and we should have one on Airport Road. Like, those would be the 3 'Cause
those are all ridiculous roads. I think you're gonna find
that a bridge is gonna be cheaper than a tunnel
because of all the infrastructure along Pony. Okay, so a bridge
at Pony, tunnel at Silver Lake, and tunnel at Airport Road.
And where at Silver Lake are you talking? What? Where at Silver Lake?
Where the school crossing is down there. I wouldn't do the Silver Lake one.
I think that's overkill there. Down by
the roundabout at the south end? Yeah. Okay. And on Airport,
are you talking about going under SR 73?
No, it's where the school is, where Desert View is.
Right by the Ivory, just— Oh, okay. Putting a tunnel
that's underneath it. Fiona. Fiona. Oh. I think that's the— for
me, that's a location worth looking into. I mean, maybe it's just going to be
crazy stupid, so maybe an over— Option as well. We can just put both.
Yeah. One or the other, whichever. Then at least we know what it's going
to be. And if it's something that can be expandable, because we
know it's going to get bigger, that's my only issue with going over the top
of it, because then you're tearing it back down when you widen it out.
So. Well, I think in those locations we already have the right-of-way. So if we
built it, we would build it. Build it to the width. Yeah. And then if
we have to add a wider pad on one side just to get to there,
and we could rip the pad up, but then the bridge is fixed there.
Great idea. It might be cheaper just to do a tunnel on that, on the
short, since the road's so narrow now. And then when you build the big road,
it's probably going to cost— Just add the other one on. Add the box on
potentially. Fiona. This is Fiona.
Fiona. Fiona, yeah.
Thank you. David Salazar has to build it before he
can leave the city. We've budgeted his flight
back every month. All right, I'll be on contract,
there you go. Can I just ask, like, so with the
Fiona one, if you invest in a tunnel, is that— is the route
for the school ever gonna change where it becomes nonfunctional for the school?
Or is— and then is— if it's Fiona, is that the right
location for the traffic to flow through? I just
think we've got to be particular. We're always going to have a pedestrian crossing
on that area right there. Whether they're going to the school to go to school
or crossing to the other neighborhood. But if we're going to put one there,
it's like what he talked about earlier with the other traffic calming measures and whatnot.
How far down that road are we going to try to do that to mimic
it for crossings? I don't understand
what you mean by that. So if you're going to do one at Fiona,
And you're going to bridge the gap between the Ivory development. What happens
when we go north and we develop out there and then there's flow of traffic?
We should be contemplating that for every single crossing across those roads. It's how
many of them, right? Right. So— Yeah, because you're right. There's going
to be a northern section of that that needs to be addressed.
And so Melissa made the point. I've been talking
with John Magnus and some of our state senators. The school
district should be responsible for the impact they create. And they should
be a participant in putting safe routes in when
they put a school in, particularly elementary schools, whether that's
going underneath it or over the top of it. But you can't just drop it
there and say, okay, you guys figure it out. I think I missed that dialogue
or that context. I missed hearing it, so thank you.
Just one random question. What about speed dips instead of
a speed table, like out on Cedar Pass Ranch?
Yeah, Cedar Pass. I'm wondering about that because there are
a lot of trailers going through there, horse trailers and other kind of trailers.
Yeah, that's a good question. I think the thing you need to
coordinate with that is the drainage surrounding the roadway. You just want to make sure
it doesn't pool up with water during a storm event. They've got great
swells that just push the water right up into the properties over there, so that'll
work great. Yeah, I will
say that most DIPS they've gone away from doing, meaning most of those— well,
so have staff bring back a plan to fund that.
Trailers won't bottom out. Yeah, so, so you don't see DIPS in the
industry anymore. They just, they had so many problems, um, you know,
people bottoming out and so forth. Um, I don't know why
other than I know everybody hates them. They do tend to be a little
less visible, I think, sometimes. That's probably off guard. Yeah, yeah.
So, so to move this forward, I think everybody's saying what's the
next step. This is just one that could be my opinion and might not be.
There, we could just fund it the way it sits, but I think we've had
recommendations to not do certain things. I also think there's a lot of human element,
meaning this is great data from an outside perspective.
There's also those of us who live there And I think we can say things
like, they don't have any suggestions for those things in the middle of the road.
I think in some areas we use those. So I think we need to take
this data and use the human element.
This is just my opinion. And fix it up, whether that's with staff
or have it come back, then fund it. That's just my opinion. But I mean,
if you think it's already done just like it is. No,
I would like to sit down with a map and say, put a speed table
here. I want the ability to have that conversation. Well, some— I think some of
these that might have been something less, it could be a speed table. And I
think some that were a speed table could be something different. That's the human element.
It's a conversation that probably needs to happen that's in more of a work session
environment instead of us up here and you down there. Let's sit down and take
a look at it and say, okay, this is what we're seeing on
the ground. This is what the residents have told us on the ground. We're going
to talk about IR Hodges, we're going to talk about Silver Lake.
They're going to kill you with the stories about Cedar Pass Ranch.
And we need to talk about those things so that they can say, what you're
saying there is not bringing into account what people are doing, their behavior,
because you were there for 2 days. So it's different on the weekend, or it's
different during the holiday. Well, that's the human element. I think so. So I think
this— I don't think we just say let's fund it. I think there's— No,
I think we're going to need to work Do we need to kind of— And
then say go. And then once we come up with something, maybe send it back
and say, now that you have that, you know, is this— That's my vote.
I don't know how the rest of you feel. Brett, you seem like you're
not sure on that. I'm happy to
head down that road with you, as long as there's a speed table in it.
Yeah. Well, I think we're going to upgrade some of these to speed tables,
and I think we might do some bull bouts.
This is going to take us some time. This is going to be a process.
We're not going to do all of this in a week. So I think we
need to probably prioritize the most critical
locations first, work through those, fund those,
and work our way out. See, and I think that's what, to your point,
Rich, those delineators are going to get put in in a lot of places.
I'm going to say I think we need to find a way to fund both
the yellow and The most
egregious and those that are recommended, because there are others that are going to develop
by the time we get these things kind of coming under— back
under control. So you're saying set aside at least that amount of money and then
determine how to— And we're going to be going into a new budget season,
so I think we should— staff should be looking at that, and we should be
looking at setting $1 million or $1.5 million aside for speed improvements
in the city. something like that. But I'm on board with that, and that's not
insignificant, but at least it gives us a target to work towards.
Even if we don't expend it all in, in the first year,
it gives us something to work on for the next year and a half or
2 years. So does that give us enough direction? You have a comment?
I think it gives us great directions, especially with the budget planning and all that
type of thing. But I guess maybe one thing I might suggest is that
if the council took a the time to go through,
prioritize, have this interaction dialogue,
come up with its plan, and then put it together into a project,
it would make a lot of sense that one, it would be funded as part
of this whole budgeting process, but two, it could be put together in a package
that could be executed between the end of school and the beginning
of school. Agreed. And, and because the reality
is we're already going to hit winter. We're not We're not going to rush.
We might as well do it right and not have impacts to the residents.
I agree. Okay, so let's set that plan in motion. And I also— Make it
so, what he said. Yeah. That's the plan. And I agree too that this needs
to be council-driven, because if staff brings this, we're just going to— they're going to—
I think that's what he just said. We're going to get together. We're going to
figure out that plan. That's why I said I agree with that. Package it all
up, wrap it in a bow, put our names on it, and here we go.
Yeah. And then next year we can get it done. So we'll
start working towards that and move forward.
So any last things here? No, I was
just going to say we did recommend the delineators
in the middle of the road on Cedar
Pass Ranch, but those kind of got combined
with the lateral shifts. But we'll make those more clear in our final recommendations.
One thing I would point out in the end, this diagram here of Golden Eagle,
if there are other corridors like Ranch Road or that kind of thing,
this would be the kind of thing you'd want to do is once you decide
what you want is to have a visual of where you want it and
then also how far apart do they need to be. You know, that, that,
that probably would take a little more work though. So.
Okay. Thank you guys. Appreciate you coming and hanging out to the very end.
That's interesting. Mayor, in looking
at the time, is there a way that we can forego the rest of this
and call it for the night? Yeah, I mean, the rest of this is
up to you guys. So if you— Can I ask one thing, Councilmember Wood?
There's only one thing that I want to get on our legislative priority list.
Thank you. I want to just make a motion to council and see if
someone will second it, that we require staff
At this present time, that is John Magnus, but we require staff to bring us
a quarterly report regarding the, the, our CWCD
water, um, here, uh, just, just an update,
just an update every 3 months on where we're at with that so that we
have an active eye on that.
Okay, that, that's fine. Uh, it's, it's some— it's something, Mayor,
that we can handle in a closed session. That's what I wanted to should be
handled in a closed session. But I want to make sure that this—
that the council is apprised of what we've done, what's been sold,
what's still, uh, in our reserves,
and that we're managing that as an active asset
of the citizens. I'll amend my second for all of that.
Go ahead. Okay, uh, motion by Council Member Wright and second by Council
Member Wood. We'll start the vote right here with Council Member Whiting. Yes. Council Member
Wood. Yes. Council Member Huish? Yes. Council Member Clark? Yes. Council Member Wright?
Yes. That's what John told me I had to do to get that report in.
There was a couple other— I know there's just some liaison reports if anybody has
some, but that chili cook-off for your schedule, Don will
send you out all of the information. So can, can, can— by a straw poll,
it's the 26th, it's Monday the 26th. I don't know the
time, probably 5 o'clock with the time, the time the
seniors eat is 5 o'clock. And it's gonna be at the senior center. You're gonna
have to make it at the senior center. You can't bring it made and
serve it. You have to make it there. So you can dump your whatever in
your crock pot. I just need to know if— how many
of you are gonna be available to do that so that we can then divide
and conquer and make sure we have enough for those that typically come.
Okay. And you guys are all invited to the teen activity
if you wanna come to that. It's at my house. That's what the address is,
my house. We'll see what— you're gonna need to get help with the horses.
I was gonna ask if you needed help, but we can talk offline about that.
I might need help with that. And just to put on your radars, because of
the explosion of the Youth Council members, they do need a
few thousand dollars more. So the next budget cycle's gonna be like January?
So they need maybe, I think, I can't remember, it's between $8,000 to $12,000 more,
something like that. They used to only get that.
Yeah, well, we're double the size. We already doubled it last year to 15,
I thought. Didn't we put it at 15? No, it's, it's like, I can't remember,
10 or 12. They, they need closer to 20.
Well, okay. They need like 8,000 to 10,000 more. I can't remember. I don't
remember the exact number, but it's something like that. It's just going up. Put it
on your radar. We'll talk about that. Was there any other reports
that need to be talked about? The seniors added 6 new seniors to the their
group this week and they need some more space. And money,
probably, just like everyone else. Okay.
I think that's everything I got. Motion to
adjourn. Second. All in favor? Aye. Any opposed?
Seeing none, it is 11:34.
Motion by Councilmember Wood and second by Councilmember
Whiting. All in favor? 11:35 and we are adjourned.